[Music]
so
do
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
for chess continues to thrive in madrid
for the first time in 30 years
spain's capital plays host to the
candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
[Music]
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a
[Music]
legacy from the second rest day in
madrid but there will be no more rest
for the weary as we have had
six rounds behind us we have eight more
to go
so much fighting chess to be had the
fight is real now everyone knows what's
at stake as they enter through those
beautiful doors here at the palacio de
centonia the players come into that hall
right there where they entertain fans
around the world daily here robert and i
are here daily that's grand master
robert hess for those who who need the
reminder international master danny
branch here uh robert as i said we had
the second rest day what did you do here
in madrid on the rest day i didn't do
much rest i was walking around
sightseeing i went to the prado museum
over three hours there i had a great
time that's awesome you wonder what i
did uh i don't really wanna know but
you'll tell us anyways okay
i also i also didn't rest too much took
a long walk not at the prada museum but
around the city it was gorgeous
beautiful
thank the weather ever ever since we had
a weatherman in studio the weather's
gotten nicer here so uh it's it's been
great here in madrid and we have so much
to talk about so much happened before
said rest day
the biggest win of all probably went to
the person who's still leading the
tournament yond upon mishi uh with the
white pieces he struck again against
young christoph duda for those who may
have missed that action we once again
have one of our highlight reels to show
you all that was the battle between
yonder pomnishi and young christoph duda
[Music]
jan napomnishi has the sole lead in the
candidates but today was evidently the
first day he was aided to victory by his
opening prep today
somehow
more or less for the first time in
tournaments i
got the position i
prepared before the game yeah so just
exactly the position so yeah that that
was quite helpful
defending with the black pieces jan
christophe duda felt the pressure from
an early stage
yeah amber disappointed of course um
i was under pressure most game but
yeah at some point i thought it was
basically going
to be a draw while yesterday nepo had
failed to impress the reigning world
champion magnus carlson who said he was
playing poor moves quickly today he
impressed former world champion
vishwanathan anand who quite liked ponta
h4 which he called clever h4 is a clever
move it has kept my attention but it's
again white is trying to clamp
clamp down on the king's side completely
with pawns advancing on his king duda
attempted the resourceful bishop to b4
this allowed nepo to win the trapped
bishop on h7 but for the bishop duda
collected a host of pawns including the
ones protecting nepo's king
in the resulting position perhaps duda
could even have been better
but
one pawn escaped it the pawn on h7
surprisingly could not be captured and
it proved a thorn in dude aside as nepo
marshalled his heavy pieces to attack g7
nepo reaped the first rewards of his
attack on g7 with rook takes f5 which
received the brilliant annotation from
game review six moves later he reaped
his second reward when due to resigned
with no way to defend g7
nepo now leads with plus three four and
a half points out of six the same score
he began with in the previous candidate
cycle on his way to victory still
fabiano kept up the pressure and is only
a half point back he won his game
against ali reza faruja much to nepo's
visible consternation
gotta love the the face from yanopon
rishi doing the nepo you nepo's just
doing the nippo um and uh we have to
mention a face that's missing of course
my deepest apologies to the lovely
elmira scripchanko she is playing in
france in a tournament for a couple days
uh she will be back at some point next
week so uh apologies again for just uh
going right into into the show there but
almira we we already miss you and uh we
know you'll be back soon so go go have
fun in france all right robert
about that game right yonder palmishi
takes down duda of course as i said
before the video there was also another
win and it might be debatable which win
was more important for i mean for both
players but yonder pomoshi talk about
just the style again he continues to
bring no one can stop him right now and
what do we have to say about his
performance yeah when he gets an open
position he's free-flowing he's playing
excellent chess and he has as many wins
as the rest of the field combined he
scored three victories and three's right
there i love that right three victory
three drawn in six games fabiano two
victories including right before the
rest against alareza frugia and then
hikaru nakamura has one yeah
that a great stat real time surprising
me right there
you just said it napan rishi has as many
victories as the rest of the field
combined but as we said it was not the
only victory fabiano caruana also took
down alireza perugia and i think the
reason it's open for debate is fabiano's
win came with black it came against ali
reza ferrugia which of course was a
matchup everyone had circled the the the
absolutely beast of a player we know
perugia is even if he doesn't quite have
his form right now and it also kept pace
with someone who otherwise might have
been unstoppable so let's talk a little
bit about
fabiano's win real quick yeah fabiano
played an excellent game of chess he was
very objective he was measured he
took the opening in stride maybe one
that he didn't expect but still he's
thought and then he played just good
move after good move yeah and he was
able not just to secure a decent
position but one with a slight edge and
he took it home yeah as you can see of
course nakamura and dingley run there
were two other games not just the games
that garwana and the pawn rescue one
respectively the nakamura dingley reign
was amazing an amazing game hikara
brought amazing prep and then ding
matched the computers at the board maybe
the most perfect chess game we've ever
seen as the accuracy scores we're
showing and then of course the for java
report game again because for java is
also in the bottom of the standings and
it was the sixth draw in a row for
report we we overlook it a little bit
maybe but that game could have had a
different result right at the end so if
you missed thursday one of those rare
times you might want to watch the full
broadcast but okay as we
talk about what happened we went into
the rest day let's remind everybody of
what those results did to the standings
where do we sit at this time
i said yonda palmishi is driving the car
but you know what
he's got someone in the passenger seat
you've had a backseat driver sitting
there crossing you and shotgun and like
you know given opinions like hey if your
tires scoot over maybe i'll take the
wheel a little bit this is this is and
maybe then there's a bunch of kids in
the back of the car right now sorry to
all the rest of the players right but
there's uh one man driving you got
another man in shotgun and a bunch of
other people there what are your
thoughts on the standings and how we've
gotten to round seven at this point yeah
second candidates in a row where yon
napomji starts with a blistering pace
four and a half of the six five under
carwana he's right there next to him as
you were saying because fabiano he
started with the victory his latest game
was a win and he's played some stable
chess and we heard magnus carlsen
criticized yon napamishi in yan's game
against hikaru nakamura i don't really
think we have the same criticisms of
fabiano's play maybe he shouldn't have
taken that draw against palm machine
round two and that could be a huge
storyline going forward but fabiano's
rarely had a bad position in this
tournament yeah well as we see the
standings there again the jokes aside
too they're we all know they're not kids
they are full grown uh beasts of men
especially on the chess board but it the
reality is
so collectively they're a full point
ahead on the field with yonder palmistry
being a point and a half so
what are the players going to have to do
to stop them we will look ahead to that
in a minute uh but before we do we also
want to give a little more credit where
credit is due to the other victory that
happened of course uh fabio carwana like
we said got the w with the black pieces
and then he got all caught up with our
own dina bell and kaya downstairs before
he left the palacio de centonia i won't
add any any uh context to the interview
you're about to see but it was a good
one he gave not just thoughts about his
game but on all the rest of perugia and
i'll let the video take it away
fabi congratulations on your winner how
comfortable were you in the opening
today
not too comfortable he surprised me
first by playing the catalan he's not
usually a catalan player and then by
playing this very rare move queen d3
and uh i was pretty much on my own but
okay my moves came very
naturally and logically and i guess i
was a bit worse but then he started to
play so heavily i mean he was thinking
like 30 40 minutes a move and uh
i don't know why because he he was a bit
better um
but slowly he
he made it into a slightly worse
position and
and i don't know if he sacked the
exchange or maybe i guess he he didn't
miss f5 because he reacted very quickly
to it but he allowed me this position
which is clearly
should be better for black i don't know
if it's much better but it felt better
for black
um
and yeah i guess still there were good
chances to hold but he he didn't defend
in the best way
so you think the person have
mis-evaluated the position after the
sacrifice
i guess or maybe maybe he was already a
bit uncomfortable because he was
thinking so long and
i don't know because i i can of course
play an equal position after bishop h3 i
can play queen d6 queen e7 any move i
want
um
and i actually didn't see this f5 in
advance
i saw that he can take on d7 and it's
you know i have at least equality so i
wasn't worried and then when he played
this i suddenly saw five and
and i thought i should take my chance
many people have been speculating about
alireza's chances in the candidates
now
seeing the games
do you think there is some kind of extra
pressure on his shoulders
i'm really not sure what's going on
behind the scenes but clearly he's not
playing at his usual level and it might
be uh
pressure of the first time but
we can only speculate he he would uh
know better what's going wrong
uh but clearly something's going wrong
because he's playing super slow and uh
and his quality is not as high as it
usually is
great interview there
from dena valencia and uh
and fabi of course giving lots of
thoughts we need to focus on the chess
focus on fabi's game and we'll even
shift our attention to what's coming
around seven but we got to talk a little
bit about what he said right clearly ali
reza faruja just something not quite
right at this point yeah no alireza
frugia at his best is obviously capable
of winning this tournament but right now
he hasn't found his footing and he's
with two losses four draws the bottom of
the standings and i like that fabiano
didn't want to get into why it might be
that personal could give already a help
it's a sign of respect too he's like i'm
not going to speculate it's not my place
yeah no exactly and it also doesn't give
him any information what fabinho might
think is wrong and how he can fix it so
they're still competitors even though
they have that respect for each other
yeah
well interesting interesting stuff there
of course uh we've now reminded you of
what the biggest results were in round
six the standings for round seven so
let's look ahead uh to that round and
what's in store we start at the top
report gets the white pieces against
napomnishi at this point
uh what is the cliche robert we have to
take matters into our own hands if the
players are going to stop napomrashi
some fighting chess has to be played
yeah and the rest of the field is
looking at richer and like hey can you
help us out and rapport he's had a very
interesting event he's drawn all six
games but he's probably been the most
exciting player of all with no
disrespect meant towards yonda pomacy
who keeps winning but reports games are
just fiery from the start so if report
can play a good opening we know he's
been critical of his own opening play if
he can take an edge out of the opening
and even beat yondu pomshi this term is
blown wide open and i'll add one more
thing if you can take a note out of
mbl's book if we remember round seven
was the kryptonite for yon upon machine
he did ultimately go on to win the
candidate so i guess unfair to say that
superman had any kryptonite in that
event but the truth is uh that loss uh
to maxine bashir lagos came with the
black pieces it came in round seven just
report uh look at history repeating
itself today young christophe duda gets
the white pieces against takara nakamura
uh again those are two players that are
not out of it judah you know wants to
rebound badly from the loss he had to
yawn before the uh to napalm machine
before the rest of your thoughts on what
he brings with the white pieces against
hikaru yeah they've only played one game
so the heads head lead for hikar
nakamura isn't super meaningful i think
that it's a very dangerous game for
yanchez of duda because he is the white
pieces if he's bloodthirsty if he's
thinking i'm
falling behind in this field i need to
win that could be great news for hikaru
nakamura because hikara has shown
tremendous preparation he's also been
pretty solid since that first round
right we've seen some great chess out of
the biggest chess streamer on the planet
and so i think that this could is a very
interesting matchup to watch because
hikar could reap the benefits of a
hyper-aggressive duda and he might be
the one person who if he did get that
win could turn this back into maybe a
three horse race so be interesting to
see uh dingley ren and ali raza perugia
that's a tough matchup for a youngster
right now who's trying to find his way
and also i think i i speak for maybe
with some bias we all just love dingley
wren so much but i think everyone just
is looking at the number one player from
china like he's just close to finding it
again his mojo is almost there your
thoughts on what he can do with the
white pieces yeah if we pretend the
first round didn't happen where he lost
with the white pieces against yonder
pomshy dingler may be playing some of
the best chess of the entire event if we
recall against richard report he was
this close to defeating the um player
who's drawn all six games he also had an
advantage in other games as well
including java against
move 40 was his kryptonite in that one
so for dingley wren he you know that he
is that close as you're saying and well
he has a person who's
really struggling and so if you honestly
are trying to pick on someone while
they're down this could be a moment for
dingley red
well and speaking of picking on someone
while they're down carwana does have a
great record against for java it's a
it's a 4-0 donut you see there on the
side
of the player from azerbaijan so uh your
thoughts on this matchup you mentioned
there's a dangerous game
earlier in this in this graphic like due
to nakamura because fabi's record is so
good and because he really wants to keep
pace with napomneshi is that a dangerous
game for him to maybe overpress with
white i would say for anybody else yes
but for fabiano caruana we've been
praising how objective he is he doesn't
speculate he calculates and so when he
gets this match up he's not going to say
let me play for a win at all costs he's
just going to try to play his normal
chess now there is one tricky element
that i think a lot of viewers at home
may not recognize it's that fabiano's
main trainer vladimir chucha law used to
work with timor java on one hand you
would say well that should give fabiano
crucial insight and that will help him
but they haven't worked together for a
while yeah so if you think that you have
this insight and if java has changed his
style completely you may be coming into
the game with some misleading
information not of course on purpose but
just some thoughts that might lead you
to feel overly comfortable and that's
where vajava can strike back
robert has spit in hot fire early on
here fabi doesn't speculate he
calculates let's tm that as another
accidental rhyme time moment from robert
hess but great stuff we can't wait for
these games to begin and so on that note
it's time for me to head over to
chess.com events and cast my vote before
the games begin uh right here we see
dingley wren taking the white pieces
against ali raza fruga and all i do is
head on over here
click on the uh the vote there i see a
little mirror going on up there in the
corner that's kind of fun right there
i'll uh i'll click back to the the games
actually to to maybe take away actually
no it's still cool look at that we've
got we've got this game right here uh
dingley wren playing white versus ali
rezarusha i'm i'm actually gonna take
him to get the w and it's heartbreaking
to to do it because you want only rosa
perugia to to find some form here and
kind of have a better feeling in madrid
we want him to be enjoying the city and
joining the tournament but i feel like
nina's close and he's going to get he's
going to get a victory that starts
turning some heads young christophe duda
and kara nakamura i'm going to predict
the the young player from poland brings
a lot of great prep but he car
neutralizes it and we ultimately see
peace in this game
yonder palm machine and richard report
i'm looking at this game i'm looking at
rapport wanting to get the dub and i'm
looking at how well yonda palma she has
played and i'm going to shock you right
now robert shock the world i'm going to
predict that napoleon gets a victory as
black wow i know i know i just have a
feeling that richard report might push a
little too hard with white and then we
might see napalmashi get over his
kryptonite from round seven last year uh
and i'm also going to take fabiano
caruana to get the w and maintain pace
really keeping this a two horse race so
all right there you go came up with
those ideas in real time the players
have joined us in real time remember you
use the command guess if you are
watching on any platform that isn't
already on chess.com use that command go
to the link go.chess.com
candidates-guests
cast your vote play for cash prizes not
just bragging rights with your friends
also just makes it a little more fun to
follow along uh all right we see that
the first move has already been
suggested for uh fabiana carwana and
then the palm put back in its place
yonda pomneshi
getting settled in
he's uh he's got the same suit on it's a
little bit of a story at this point
because i think jan doesn't want to hey
if it ain't broke don't fix it i guess
right yeah some chess players are
extremely superstitious that's been a
thing for decades and so for yon napalm
she as you said if he's winning with
that suit why change it yeah okay well
yeah he likes it and let's just hope
he's taking it to the dry cleaning daily
so uh so it stays
smelling as fresh as it looks as fresh
um
all right but uh
the games are getting underway we hope
that you are excited for your day with
us thanks for spending your weekend with
us no matter where you are in the world
it's uh still a saturday i think
and the moves are being played on the
board look at this our our bird's eye
view for the first time
a petrol between rapport and upon
machine
you know he he used that weapon against
young christophe duda again another
young aggressive player uh where where
yongo's into maybe his prep versus
carlson for the world championship here
robert yeah right john de palma if he
can use it against magnus carlson he can
use against anybody but i think
stylistically it's just a great choice
against that creative type of player
like richard reports so that's in the
top left-hand side of the screen and i
mean if we look across the board there
the bottom right where fabiana carwana
is on the clock that's sicilian and the
second move a6 which is quite rare
because we usually play in the center in
the opening that's what all new chess
players are taught and yet rajaba
bucking that trend and playing a6 i
moved to and maybe already taking fabi a
little bit by surprise nothing massive
but bobby is thinking right and so you
that a6 we're going to dive into it of
course when the chess analysis gets
going because it is very tricky um
there's some move order uh
idiosyncrasies that are unique to that
particular um
move too versus maybe later on in a
night or uh when the move doesn't come
to move six so uh
yeah this that'll be interesting um
we've also got
an english from dingley wren down low
yeah he's just calmly setting up his
bishop on g2 the bottom left and
and we've talked down the catalan and
all these types of positions that bishop
has that full scope so at the start of
this game we'll see how alireza frugia
comes prepared because
he has been struggling and i think a
positional approach is the right one for
dingle red it's move five when you play
a6 sorry i was doing the math that's
seven six move five i'm gonna tell you
neither uh coming up with that on the
fly but there you go uh
the players are seated the games are off
the last game we haven't touched on as
far as just setting the tone for the
opening is yonkers of duda versus hikaru
nakamura there we have a nimso indian
hikaru not going to get the same nimzod
that he did against alireza perugia we
already have a totally different
structure with this bishop d3 knight ge2
variation instead of the classical queen
c2
as ollie rozza played yeah we see that
dude just took the pawn on d5 which
leaves the car with an important choice
now normally when a pawn protects a pawn
we like almost always recapture with the
pawn to keep control of the center but
that could leave the car with an
isolated pawn in the middle and yeah
pond's best friend being another pawn
that's not the ideal situation and
hikaru he's spending time right here
right he didn't recapture immediately
which either means he's caught by
surprise by the opening and how it's
gone or he's just thinking let me gather
myself here let's not rush because when
you make rush decisions in the opening
relying on memory you could remember
incorrectly yonda palmer she taught him
that lesson uh in their game no but all
right let's let's dive into that one
we're gonna obviously go around the horn
as they say to start every show make
sure that every every game gets touched
on and we and we set the tone so as we
said this this is a and nimzo indian uh
here but not the same line ooh c takes
d4 okay yeah so real quick how we got
here we have uh a new which is defined
with bishop to b4 uh as we said
queen to c2 the variation played by aldi
rosa perugia uh against sikar nakamura
what we see very very often truth be
told maybe more often than any other
line when when two top players are
playing but young christopher says no he
goes for e3
very common development with bishop d3
and knight ge2
and after d5 we're actually in a
line that was way way more popular i
guess maybe a couple decades ago you
know in the 90s this is you saw a lot of
this type of approach um but we're going
to get a bunch of exchanges in the
center
and ultimately it is white who might be
having the isolated pawn to play for
depending on what happens with the
exchange here and as we continue white
castles this is all normal stuff and
getting the king out of the center but
if we just go here now this is a big
moment for black because the bishops
under attack people don't typically like
to retreat their pieces right their
bishops on b4 you're getting aggressive
but with that bishop now under attack do
you take this knight on c3 and if you go
for that that gives white the pair of
bishops and could correct white's pawn
structure
and as we see on the board hikaru just
retreat his bishop to d6 now white can
aim in the center right you can even
trade knights on d5 which will leave
black with an isolated pawn as well so
that looks like a pretty level trade or
if white
wants to you can
leave this pawn on e6 because the light
square bishop sitting on c8 and we see
that duda quickly leaves that knight
there he makes his rook to e1 the bishop
on c8 just like in the french defense
and all sorts of other types of
positions that bishop is blocked in by
its own pawn so white's light square
bishop
aims towards the black king side
black's light square bishop sits and is
quite a passive piece so often you want
to fianchetto that bishop that means
playing the move pawn up to b6 bishop
over to b7 to line the bishop of the
long diagonal but that has flaws in and
of itself so it's not an easy position
for hikaru nakamura to play we see him
seated at the board he's trying to
figure out what he should do and i think
the opening battle where now after
white's 11th move has been won by
yanchez of duda
he's playing within his preparation
hikaru has seen this position in similar
positions many times before but as you
can just tell by how concentrated he is
at this early stage as compared to the
previous round where against dingley
wren he played pretty much the first 25
moves instantly because he had that in
his
computer and his laptop his theory he is
really going out to struggle to come up
with a path towards equalizing this game
it's not just as simple as the eval bar
off the side says ah it's not a big deal
it's about coming up with an actual plan
here and that's not that easy for black
at the moment
so hikaru you know he's going to take
his time he's
in hikaru look number i don't even know
he had his hands on his head daddy
got to remember his opening theory
maybe
hands on head that's not a face that we
often tried to catalog when a car was
streaming because he rarely has hands on
head while streaming yeah he's got a
hand on the mouse and even over the
board he's still trying to grab that
mouse right yeah yeah that was a that
was a great moment there um
shout out to all of our team working
super hard on all the fun content fun
memes that we're catching
all right well speaking of catching we
got to catch up with the other games
because we've now set the tone for this
nimzo where do you want to where do you
want to take this this next part
well we don't even necessarily need to
go to the game but five minute car one
hasn't moved
i mean that's the storyline in and of
itself that
after black's second move and fabiano is
frozen in place yeah well we can we can
show it in fact we mentioned that there
are some tricky things about this move
order so let's just show one of one of
the basic ideas
by playing a6 uh is is to play e5
right away should white go for a
standard open sicilian so in contrast to
let's say the main line of the niner if
you have d6 d4
and when you get this position the
reason that black doesn't just play e5
right away is because with the b5 square
open white can give this check and you
know certain things happen where the
light square bishop might be traded and
suddenly white actually has
real dominance over the light squares in
a way that you don't normally see if
that light square bishop can make it to
e6 but when you play a6 first
you're actually threatening to play e5
right away
should white just go for a standard
open sicilian and just show the
differences if you play something like
knight f5 black actually has d5 on the
spot undermining that the pawn cannot
capture without the knight hanging so
this is a
this is a a just one of the tricks
there's there's many other things behind
this move order there are also some bad
things about the move order right robert
i can let you describe if you want one
of the drawbacks is that because you've
chosen a pawn move instead of a
developing move in the center sorry upon
move on the side if you do get positions
where the center opens up white is often
threatening e5 in positions where you
wouldn't normally see it uh with the
pawn on d6 for example so
fabi not it's not like he doesn't know
this opening he just needs to pause 10
seconds i guess and really make sure he
chooses the line properly yeah i think
you were raising some good points and in
particular the d5 square that's really
important in the sicilian defense
especially if you move that second pawn
to e5 like you were showing in those
variations yep when you don't have a
pawn to
uh defend the square that square is your
opponents for the taking so a6
preemptively stops all sorts of bishop
b5 ideas covers that square and allows
black to play b5 himself so rijaba might
be
trying to play b5 in the future and
fiance bishop and this move c4 which i
was actually about to mention it gives
you a moroxy bind type of structure that
white has complete control over the d5
square now also the b5 square is under
fabiano's control because the bishop on
f1 and the pawn z4 make sure that pawn
can't push too square so the knight from
b1 will come to c3 you love to say this
that a knight likes to be behind a pawn
because then the pawn knight team up and
control the square diagonal from that
pawn so i really like that five-minute
pause and play this move c4 because
instead of getting this game into
tactical waters and into java's
preparation it's going to stay into the
types of positions that are quite close
but white is typically with a slight
advantage because you have more space
and because your pawns are more advanced
yeah well well said and c4 is also a
kind of move you can play with a little
more time because black isn't playing d6
and knight f6 as in other standard
sicilians with immediate pressure on the
pawn you have a little more time to move
this pawn before playing knight c3 right
there's no rush to develop and protect
the the pressure that black is bringing
to the center because black has wasted
quote unquote a tempo on this side side
of the board move and there is a bit of
a rush right now because knight c6
protects the e5 score so black could
consider playing pawn to e5 next and the
reason you'd want to do that is because
that prevents white from playing d4 so
just like white has that clamp on d5
black will say now it's my turn to take
over the d4 square so typically what you
want to do is when your opponent is
trying to get some kind of outpost you
want to fill the square and here d4
fills that square and after this trade
we get the moroxy bind structure that
we're talking about where now you don't
have to worry about black contouring
that square white is fighting equally
for it and on the other hand as you're
highlighting these pawns are much better
than black spawns they're more advanced
to take control of vital squares
but so this is great stuff especially
for those who play sicilian you're
learning a lot more about variations
maybe you didn't know but but uh to back
up for a second and talk about the
psychology the preparation why did rajab
take this approach right i i'm trying to
think about the strategy about this
robert and i'm wondering if if a6 was a
move that was going to take bobby by
surprise and you would anticipate
that
you'll go for the best positional line
but not the sharpest stuff we've said
that this is kind of also the positions
that roger buck would rather play these
days maybe right so
on the one hand fabi is going to have a
small edge in this structure undeniably
so right uh with space and with a
meroxie bunch structure but do you think
that rajaba is also kind of getting the
kind of game he wants yes and i think we
were mentioning that maxine vashila grav
mvl was jana palm she's kryptonite round
seven let's remember what happened when
the candidates resumed last time around
fabiano caruana came in with just all
this preparation and destroyed maxime in
this like ridiculous preparation okay
maxine actually played very well he
handled it admirably for a while but the
point is those tactical situations
favored fabiano so just like
um you know we're talking about how
grijaba likes quieter positions where he
can try to slowly outplay his opponent
he gets to avoid all of fabiano's
preparation for the most part and just
get a position that's slightly better
for white where rijaba probably feels
confident that he can hold steady
yeah
well well said and we'll see uh
we'll see where this goes probably still
using his time and i think we can say
that
while it undeniably bobby's going to
have a little bit of an edge i think
raja
took fabi a little bit by surprise by
this move order which is why he's being
very deliberate as robert said he he
calculates he doesn't speculate bobby
wants to make sure he gets his type of
position before he uh rushes into
anything and if we look at the bar on
the side the wind draw loss bar here
yeah look at how
you know up there it is for white so
yeah white light is a lot of these
positions in a healthy amount of the
time and and black doesn't win nearly
the same amount and you know you never
know because there could be rating
mismatches in some of those games but
the point is that white has a very safe
position and black typically gets
squeezed you don't have space your
pieces are fighting for the same squares
and the e the ideas are not that
difficult for white once you've studied
this position
the foundation is there then you're able
to just develop your knight to c3
develop your light square bishop castle
a lot of the moves come very naturally
and then black doesn't necessarily have
active play of his own and wow e5 was
the church i was just going to say that
normally you don't see e5 anymore after
the d5 has been taken off of the agenda
uh but you can play e5 in these
positions and it's sort of a hybrid
specinicoff looking structure right
where uh when black plays e5 in a
special cop you are risking of course
all the weaknesses that you see before
you on the d-file but you're trying to
do it to accelerate development get the
bishop out early to one of these squares
uh
in some case
this is going to be a very unique
looking sicilian ahead of us we're
already on novel territory as you can
see i mean there's there are some games
but this is not going to be games uh in
the hundreds in this particular move
order certainly not the top levels wow
that's a big big decision because in the
sicilian as we're talking earlier the
key square for black typically is d5 and
where java says i'm not even going to
put up a fight for that square that's
yours and what typically happens is this
knight on d4 will re-route to the e3
square now you can jump forward to f5
and then go back to e3 you can go via c2
to e3 but the point is that d5 will be
firmly under white's control with the
second knight coming to c3 but black has
laid claim to d4 square that if this
knight on d4 moves twice then you're no
longer controlling that square yourself
so
it's a very interesting decision by
rajab it's committal but clearly we're
in his preparation and he's going to
show us what his idea is okay
well we will see uh speaking of
preparation and we're going to back out
and check in on the other games and see
what
the other players prepared
for what's on the board
what is going on in report napomnishi
we need to go to there
that is it reminds me of this game from
jordan von forrest
and i don't know if it's this exact line
but he did something just like this and
i was equally surprised that time and
now i'm like what is the material count
white is up
a rook and one pawn for just a bishop
but obviously checkmate in one is also
being threatened
and there's
probably all kinds of weird perpetuals
that can occur if white has to take h3
at some point there's there's a king
that is
wide open for business
um and you have to take on h3 right you
have because
if f3 i assume bishop c5 check not only
gains the tempo but protects the only
other way the queen has out so maybe he
just checkmate oh it's just checkmate
with queen e2 games too okay yeah yeah
it's just over okay so in fact we should
show that line real quick
if you play any other move besides
taking like f3 black has bishop to c5
check
king to h1
and queen to e2
the rook goes but it doesn't matter you
take it and you're mating uh very very
quickly so
so that's on the agenda which means that
if g takes h3 is the only move then
isn't there already a check in
queen e4 queen d3 might be the maybe the
most precise queen d3 attacks the rook
on f1 and also around the queen of f3 so
rook g1 seems like it stops the
mouse
queen f3 and this is a very common draw
where you just go back and forth like
this in fact and if you play queen d3
you're going to play king duchy one
and you already have a draw yeah
so
and if you're
yonder pomnishi coming in with the
tournament lead
coming in with the black pieces
i don't think you're terribly upset
about a half point and we might have a
game end here
before we're 20 minutes into the round
and we were talking about how rapport is
the first person to admit that he's not
the best at openings he is not as well
versed and this is an exact moment where
it comes back to bite you yeah where you
just handed your opponent a draw after
15 to 20 moves
and of course yonder palm she knew all
this at home he cooked it up and he just
gets to wipe his hands of a game with
the second move speaking of what he knew
at home we're going to back up and go
through the opening because it was a pet
shop and you're right
that line by the way
something about that that's where it
came something about that line we
analyzed with fabi during the world
championship that's what it was right
because it was potentially on the board
but we didn't get it and fabi actually
showed us that line while on the couch
uh at our studio at chess.com's
headquarters so it was this is all
theory
and again we we we kind of set the tone
on some of these pet shops in previous
round that yawn had versus young
christoph duda the tension centers
around d5 because black cannot take it
without the knight being undermined so
white kind of builds up on that tension
with queen b3 but it was this variation
that didn't happen this didn't happen
between carlson and upon rishi but favi
showed us that if it should there's some
crazy theory here that that goes well
exactly like we're now seeing on the
board it's a fourth draw for black
and reports is not gonna do his uh
his teammates so to speak any favor his
teammates who all wanted him to maybe
beat jan today that's not gonna happen
yeah and there's
he's thinking right now because king h1
is like the obvious move because it's
the only
legal move with your king but if he
would make them bishop g5
just if we go back for a second giving
away you're up a full rook let me go
bishop g5 you lose this game because
after queen takes g5 king excel is going
to h20 or queen f4 and you're still
turning queen f3 check with at least a
draw in many positions and bishop d6
lining the bishop and the queen up to h2
i mean
blacks wins wow
yawn might have an easy day at work
today like well i'm just going to wash
my hands of this one he plays queen e4
check which invites f3 but as we said f3
doesn't really do anything you still
play queen d3 and your king either steps
back to the g file uh well
maybe he tricks him into the wrong
square in the g file but you either have
a draw
or uh
where you move
i'm moving the rook probably rook f2
there's bishop c5 again yeah queen
coming to d1 and you know pieces around
your king it feels like a game that
black could like could win if rapport's
not careful but i think rapport is just
going to play king ju1 he's not going to
be happy about it but after you know
staring at the position for a while
he'll just play king g1 and the thing
about this is black is one piece away
from delivering checkmate yep right if
that rook on f8 could move like a knight
just for one turn up to g6 that would be
checkmate down the open file but
unfortunately for black you're down a
full rook and it takes time to bring
more pieces into the attack so yonda
pomshi he'll settle for that half point
it's not really settling that's the
desired result when you're playing
against a top 10 player like richard
report with the black pieces
in a situation where you're leading the
tournament anyway so there's again it's
this is not a a thing you would hold
against yonder pomnishi at all this is
exactly what he came in for hoping he
would get and richard report maybe not
knowing the opening as well as jan
uh just made it just made it easier for
him and if we're being honest this is
what frustrates a lot of people about
you know high level chess and you know
even playing just when they feel like my
opponent has memorized them they didn't
play themselves but that's part of the
game right i'm the first person to admit
that my openings are lackluster to put
it and i'm someone who loves calling you
out for it yeah you do and so
when i played games and i played someone
like you know super grand master sam
shanklin who was doing the game of the
day analysis for chess.com and he just
like blitzes out openings i'm like well
i i didn't know what else to do and you
just made a draw you didn't spend any
time yeah it definitely can frustrate
players like report who are you know
seemingly less inclined to study
openings and rely on their creativity
over the board so there is sometimes
this dynamic between players and reports
not going to be very happy that he just
wasted the first advantage and he didn't
really have a chance to win but i think
for report right now he just needs to
accept that this is his fate for today
he goes in the second half of tournament
still with chances right he's going to
be a point now behind jana palmashi but
somebody is going to have to beat you on
if jan's not going to win the tournament
that somebody doesn't have to be him
yeah
well well said i mean of course uh
report as we know creative attacking
chess in general being played here in
madrid but getting nothing nothing but
uh half points to show for it and it
looks like he might be headed toward his
seventh
half point in a row so um let's back out
to our bird's eye view reset one more
time and make sure we check in with the
one game we haven't uh
really looked at yet
and that is uh
dingley wren versus ali reza faruja
that looks interesting right there's a
bottom left-hand side screen is a pawn
thrown up all the way to a4
and that's a pawn that might be
wandering too far so if you're not
careful for black at some point that
pawn can become an easy target
let's
let's look at how this is
a weird move word in english although
the dingley wren
uh taking more time than ali rezabruge
at this point i'm always trying to
observe what does that mean about how
the players are
getting their prep or not
how comfortable they feel
white's still doing just fine but
definitely an interesting one too and
that you you we talked about the roxy
vine in fabiano's game here white
actually maybe doesn't want to go for
that structure at the cost of closing
this english kind of catalan looking
bishop there so that's an interesting
thing to see white delaying and somebody
who should know full welder that is
alireza fruga because e4 was maybe the
culprit of why he got in trouble in
round six against caruana and this
position right and we can go back and go
back into the opening okay
we started by seeing that bishop get to
g2 was looking uh pleasantly down the
long diagonal and two moves from now
you're gonna say wait what diagonal is
that bishop looking at because c6 it
blunts that bishop and it protects the
d5 square so i think a lot of people
would assume that fruija was going to
play d5 on autopilot but if you look
after knight f3 his pawn e5 is under
attack so you have to deal with that
pawn so d6 was played and this is a very
solid setup the bishop on c5 is outside
the pawn chain oftentimes we get stuck
inside and we're not very happy because
our position is passive but with the
bishop on c5 aiming towards the white
king side on f2 we feel like we do have
some more aggressive opportunities yeah
it makes sense it is it is an
interesting move because black if black
wanted d5 you could you could try to
play a move like rookie eight to protect
the pawn in a different way to support
this but there may already be a weird
sort of center fork trick is this oh
okay you know robert's not i was so
afraid to suggest it but robert says no
danny it's okay trust yourself
yeah so this this type of fork trick
often often occurs when a knight is
recapturing and a pawn would go up here
forking the two minor pieces regaining
material and often with interest because
you sort of leap frog to some central
control you gain some space in this case
it would be the same sort of thing with
white providing a fork and even winning
the bishop pair and even if even if
black took on f2 check which is often uh
kind of an
in between move tactic you try to play
white still gets the bishop here because
that bishop is gone and you could play
moves like rook f1 castle by hand you
have the f file so this actually would
be an edge for white so interesting okay
i just wanted to confirm that that was
why rookie 8 wasn't chosen by perugia
and instead d6 was on the board
rekharovka a5 d4
interesting transition there right
because rather than dealing with black
center white doesn't wait to change the
structure
open up the board and the bishop on g2
and now he's going to play on the queen
side which is this is a very
straightforward
game right now for dingley run
everything feels like it's swimmingly
moving swimmingly you're going to get b4
try to play on the queen side where
often a rook and bishop are actually
communicating in these types of
positions everyone because they both
have the same sort of long-term goals
and that type of position can be very
good if you start to open up space
by the way that is not the camera's
going black that is someone who's
showing us their back
uh at the palacio decent challenge
let's just say right in front of the
camera sorry go ahead but if we just go
back a half move here instead of rook b1
yeah the a4 score is covered by two of
white's pieces but this is a blunder
waiting to happen because knight takes
a4 so yes thank you for the pawn but
bishop takes d4 distracts the queen from
its defense of that knight so that would
actually cost white material so the a4
pawn is a long term target can't be
taken right now and so if we go to what
happened the game rook b1
what rook b1 does it allows white to
push the b pawn in a way you couldn't
with the rook on a1 because once on
passant happens yeah and the a file
opens up and yeah
i'll pretend like this was a thing
you're not going to take it but the
point is this this would ruin the
structure if you can't take with the
pawn this is not what you want with the
weakness on the a-file right exactly and
so even with the rook on b1 is white
aiming to play b3 do you want to open up
the a file for the rook sitting there so
that's one of those big questions and if
i'm alireza i'm trying to think what's
my plan some people will continue
pushing this a pawn up the board i
already went from a5 to a four why not
go to a3 that would be pushing it too
far because white is not going to take
that pawn and you immediately like throw
my pawn up to be no amazon here by the
way
it's very important for those who don't
know the rule there is no one there
that's right and once the bishop goes
back why can you play rook to b3 at some
point knight to c2 these ideas come very
quickly where the a3 pawn is just going
to drop so that is not what alireza
wants instead he's like a queen a5 to
protect the pawn and just to eye this
knight on c3 maybe he'll go like dingly
wren against
hikaru nakamura put his queen on a7 and
line the queen and bishop up towards the
king side so there are a bunch of
options and that knight on b8 is going
to go to d7 and then from d7 it's likely
to go to e5 which attacks the c4 pawn
how do you protect that you likely
played b3 at some point and i was just
mentioning that black is happy for the
move b3 to be played yes the knight
right now is currently on pre but the
opening of the a file serves blackwell
with the queen and the rook on the line
okay
you're not too bad at explaining chest
positions
we've
got a lot of chest positions still
active here although if you're just
tuning in i guess perhaps the early
story of the day is that we might have
one chess game ending
very soon richard report is thinking
about what to do with white and that's
partly because he appears to have
blundered we use that term sort of
uh loosely here uh because he's not
going to lose unless he plays really bad
moves blundered into yonda palmishi's
prep
and
robert and i both saw the position of
the board and from memory we were trying
to recall like where we'd seen it but it
wasn't too long ago where fabio caruana
was talking about some of the really
deep uh prep and and the petrol these
days at the high level where black just
has all kinds of ways to make a four
straw which is a very powerful weapon at
the high levels of chess to just know
that you have something like the four
straw we see here in your back pocket
yeah no this is a bad news for porter
you look at him he's just like he's mad
he's pissed he wanted a fight he wanted
to do everyone a favor
today yeah and he's about to have a
seventh draw in seven games yeah but
that's kind of funny because nobody ever
thinks of richard reports like oh that
guy's a boring player he just makes draw
he's solid no he's making draws from all
sorts of hectic positions and we had
fabiana carwana with us you know he
wasn't playing the world championship
and he's not playing right now yes he's
physically at the board he's in the
tournament hall look at the bottom right
he hasn't moved
well
he is down nearly half an hour against
pujabov after e5 and he is caught by
surprise yeah
officially caught by surprise i don't
think we were we were speculating didn't
want to say it for sure in the beginning
but the more fabi thinks the more we're
confident that it doesn't mean he
doesn't have an edge no but as soon as
we talk about it he moves it doesn't
mean he doesn't have an edge in the
position you see the e-belt par slightly
favors white in those moroxy bind
structures when you have a couple of a
couple of pawns in the center
but
but the clock would say that uh he did
not think rojava would go for such a
position for sure yeah he lost the
opening battle even if he's better over
the board it feels like he lost the
opening battle and
look at that move d5
oh raja is bringing some prep to the
table
fabi is about to have his work cut out
for him
on the one hand you say to yourself well
at least my opponent came for a fight
because i also want to fight i'm trying
to win this event and stay stay paced
with yonda pandashi on the other hand
that's not a fun thing to face when your
opponent without thinking roger hardly
sat in his chair he hardly sat down and
just throws a pawn into the middle of
the board and says i'm going to
sacrifice a pawn like what oh my
goodness and i think we have to explain
this because white has three pieces
aiming of the d5 square it's clear you
don't want to touch the e4 pawn because
your knight on f5 needs its defense so
we can sort of eliminate that one
this is already just a very bad position
for white now we have two options queen
takes or pawn takes d5 and we want to
think about the differences so once we
take with the queen what was that queen
doing on d1 that c2 square in particular
is quite vulnerable so yeah black can
take on f5 get these queens off the
board and then play this knight over to
probably b4 and d4 also looks okay and i
mean it's clear white's developed
nothing you're up a pawn on f5 but
you've developed none of your pieces and
black is very likely to scoop that pawn
up next and all the light squares are
vulnerable even though white's the only
one with a light square bishop so this
would be really bad for fabiano so he's
very likely just to take with the c pawn
on d5 and that doesn't end the story
black will take on f5 if you don't take
an f5 you've just given up on for
nothing at the very least here there are
these pawns d5 and f5 that black can go
after and knight d4 looks like a good
start and i think white will play moves
like knight c3 bishop d3 and try to
develop quickly
well
i guess there was a problem but yeah
this i mean it all looks very good at
this point so i don't think black is
necessarily going right back for the
pawn yeah and that's an important lesson
to people because we hear the queen's
gambit as the show but gambits in
as a concept oftentimes in gamuts our
goal is not to win back the pawn that or
whatever it is that we sacrifice right
away we want the activity so we gambit
some material for active play for good
squares and so in this type of position
knight f6 looks more to the point we're
going after this d5 pawn and f5 that's a
pawn that's pretty much not going
anywhere have a snickers right gonna be
there for a while no it's a really it's
a really instructive point and
it's funny that you say that because i
think a lot of players when they first
start playing gambits as part of their
repertoire sack upon and then spend the
rest of their game panicking to regain
the pawn and when i had students like
that i'd say like hey if you you don't
like compensation then don't sacrifice a
pawn let's change let's change the
opening right because
by rushing to get a pawn back you often
miss the whole point and yeah knight f6
bishop c5 or b4 you want rook ca you
want castles you want moves that put
pressure on your opponent and uh
okay
but as far as putting pressure goes i
cannot wait to see what rajab comes up
with here because he's
he doesn't want to sit down he just
wants the prep he's like i don't want to
sit there and even work yet i'm letting
the computer at home
uh do the job and we've
you know applauded rijaba for coming
ready to fight but could this backfire i
mean when we look at this position i
think our chest brain if we take our
commentator hat off first yeah and just
think about our chess brand we're like
wait a second white has the pair of
bishops
white is currently up a pawn the move
knight c3 is a developing move that we'd
likely want to play anyway and if you're
really going to go for my d5 pawn that
takes a couple turns you have to go
knight f6 knight takes d5 and white has
this bishop pair the king is not in any
danger from white so i feel like
white should be pretty happy about it
dwight can even play like bishop g5 and
slow it down i mean
yeah you're really taking a gamble when
you play a bad line uh
to try to catch your opponent off guard
and again i'm not saying it isn't at
times a gamble we're taking and it's
it's exciting chess so i mean i'm i'm
happy we got this conversation on the
board but for sure regardless of how
much time fabiano uses if he's just
clearly better then like i said you
can't complain you're like all right
well i'd rather have this even if my
opponent took me by surprise than some
super solid line that i was unable to
break right and there are already funny
variations that i'm just thinking of
like let's say white starts with bishop
d3 the protected f5 pawn like you take
on d5 with your queen and i play knight
c3 oh i see where you go with this right
and i go bishop e4 nice simultaneously
defending my rook on h1
through your the queen and hitting the
b7 pawn and that king on e8 is very
lonely and it's just going to be in big
trouble and we see the evil part already
over plus six so
white has all of these different ways
sure to give back that pawn but get that
rapid development we've been talking
about so i feel like fabiano despite
being surprised he shouldn't be unhappy
about the position he's received
oh man
well as we back out and uh look at the
other boards to see who might be happy
or unhappy we have an interesting stat
bobby might be really happy that he wins
this game where he could potentially tie
yonda pandashi if a draw happens in the
game with report and the reason i'm
drawing attention to that is because a
fun little stat here from the team is
that since 2013 every candidate's winner
winner was leading at the halfway point
and so
if
if you know history repeats itself here
and yonda pomeshi is the clear leader at
the halfway point bobby's not just
fighting against napalm rishi he's
fighting against history it's you know
important important that you don't fall
too far behind no it's very important
the one biggest difference of this
candidates versus previous ones is that
in the previous ones head-to-head record
meant something so perhaps the leader at
the half had beaten the person who ends
up trying to catch them and we saw in
fabiano caruana and certainly
in 2016 that they were tied going into
the last round but fabinho had to win
because he had lost their the first game
of their head-to-head or he's the worst
tiebreak so here we see that
fabiano he has his chance all four
boards look really interesting
and
after queen e4
check in the top left report still
thinks fabiano down 30 minutes on his
clock and the other two matches are more
even on the clock just just really
developing
an interesting structural change in the
due to nakamura game not something you
you see shifted to every day in fact the
position is actually transposed directly
into what would be a panoptinic opening
from a caracan in fact as someone who
plays the pan off as white and nimso as
black i've i've seen that structure for
both sides before
we'll come around to that an isolated
queen pond on d4 interesting stuff so
well wherever you are thanks for making
the candidates part of your day i think
we're going to have another round that
doesn't disappoint
i've i've been pretty happy with the
chess so far from madrid
it's been fantastic yeah and we've had
six total decisive games three by jan
napomneshi two by five anacarwana and i
guess two by nakamura but one win uh by
nakamura and so
we you know we
had some decisive games but the games
that even are drawn have been so back
and forth so full of energy and fun and
that was funny
the reason i was smiling and looked over
is because you missed it that he almost
grabbed a piece and then stopped and
smiled like he forgot his line it was
actually really funny he was you know he
did one of these and then went
oh and then like smiled so whatever he
did he was like thank god i didn't touch
that rook
um whatever he was or bishop i don't
know what he was about to touch over
there in the corner but no touchy right
look but don't touch at this point we
know what he's not touching is that h7
pawn he lined his bishop and queen up in
the top right hand side yeah to go for
checkmate and hit carr said did kevin
matombo check made off and kid um
okay wow well so many games we can go to
we saw bishop d3 played by fabiano he
likes your line of queen d5 knight c3
although i i want to go back because
report is thinking for a reason right
he's not just kicking himself that he
clearly has gone into a line that uh
that that yon was prepared to play for
maybe prepared for the world
championship now using it here
but what are the ways to maybe avoid the
draw before we just say it's over let's
go look at it and see and kind of verify
that
that he will go for the draw because
perhaps it's worse if he doesn't uh we
can have
so what king g1 kg1 is just to draw if
you do this back and forth we'll just
show that
so the
there are other moves here there are
only two other ways out one is f3 now
and the other one is in this position to
play bishop to g5 we looked at that one
but as we looked at that this is
actually
not an option at all right if you if you
go for this you're actually losing on
queen g5 and then robert's super simple
move queen to f4 which is awesomely
powerful because it hits h2 threatens
bishop d6
along with still just threatening to get
a professional check so that means the
only other way would be right here to
play f3
um but after queen to e2
oh no we need to actually now you lose
g6 so it's very important
right
yeah
although actually after both queen d3
and queen to e2 oh there's knight d2
yeah this knight d2 moves so maybe we
took this a little bit for granted
that's what reporters trying to figure
out like hey wait a second after queen
d3 what if i played knight d2 here
ah so
this is a way to avoid the draw but
there's something wrong with it
we have to switch gears somehow for
black and try to start bringing pieces
in because this move immediately defends
everything
but again this this is reminding me of
some of the lines that fabi talked about
there are ideas remember to try to come
trap the queen
oh queen d7 something like okay queen d7
right you come back and your immediate
threat on the board is knight a6 to just
trap the queen
actually how do you stop that you know
okay no you're right but that's really
important because we keep saying that
for trading moves is the hardest to find
yeah and when you just sacrificed a full
rook to
break open someone's king side defenses
you're so tunneled off and like how are
they going to
mate me and so actually this is a really
important moment for report because in
the live position he's debating do i
make the draw by going king g1 queen g6
king h1 back and forth right we've seen
this before
or after f3 and knight d2
can i somehow play for a win and if you
don't see queen d7 from a distance then
you're like well i don't see what
black's doing this is a bit of a bluff
but it looks like rapport he understands
that he should not
play on that the objective truth the
position is that the repetition
is more or less forced from his
perspective
i think he played that real quick
repetition just to make sure that uh he
gains another move on on the clock but
uh
he's
i i don't believe there's any chance he
keeps going here yeah well especially
because of the risk of the preparation
when you know now in your head that
you're playing it into something yawn
was very well prepared uh to play
probably again as we said prep he had
poor magnus carlson in dubai uh based on
the fact that we saw several petrols in
that match and um
five minute car juana was talking about
lines like this sort of being known by
the top players
there's one other way to potentially try
to get out and it's also with f3
and if queen d3 king g2
queen g6
now sacrificing the bishop
is the only other way to keep the game
going
but to me even this is like asking for
it
you're definitely asking to lose like if
you take with the bishop on g5 you're
throwing discovered checks like bishop c
one check to win the b2 pawn
and the queen on eight is still out of
play and that means you probably got to
get your king out of the line of fire so
you go back to the corner and what if
the queen just goes right back to d3
yeah it feels like right now you're in a
spot where
all you have to show for it is to go
back anyway for the draw
although you could develop to c3 to
protect the rooks but then your idea
queen became seven and the queen is
again running into fire which is so
crazy rook aided one like
queen c7
isn't your queen just trapped in the
corner over there
there is no way he plays this i see the
eval bar off to the side saying it's
only point one better for black but
you're walking into your opponent's
preparation your queen is trapped in the
corner your king isn't even that safe
anyway
there's just no way the report sits here
and goes into this line unless
you know we say something you're playing
a win you're playing a loser yeah you're
playing to lose and now report has been
known to play to lose from time to time
and uh because he loves fighting chess
so much i think it would really
uh really be something he regretted if
it got away from him and to palmer she
won its black although it would make my
prediction true i cast my vote today at
chess.com events if you haven't been
doing so shame on you you're not
competing for cash prizes but um
i did predict an abomination victory is
black because i envisioned a totally
different type of game
i don't think we'll get that i think
we'll get a draw but uh
oh but wow yona's pacing
i do have to give report credit though
yep because once you
get blindsided and you're just like oh
there's this repetition happening a lot
of people would just throw in the towel
okay we'll make this draw i'm upset i'll
go home the report he's digging deep
he's really trying to find the truth the
position instead of just believing his
opponent because we saw early in the
tournament and as much as i've said that
fabiano carwana is objective he doesn't
speculate remember against yonder palm
sheep for this knight g4 move which he
was like it's not really that great of a
move fluff
once you have the engine analysis with
you so
you know there could be a possibility a
world where what yander palms has done
in this game is a bit of a bluff it
isn't this looks like a just
a good try by black that leads to a draw
but for report he's showing everybody
out there what you should do when you're
met
with a surprise instead of just assuming
that your opponent did the right thing
and will just shake hands and make this
draw let me figure that out for myself
because if the game is going to be king
g1 black has to make that draw yeah
there's no choice so why not spend an
hour
of your time here because if the draw is
going to happen regardless and you're
going to be upset by making the draw
regardless but spend your time to make
sure that that is in fact the case yeah
you work hard in those spots and
sometimes it pays off right i love that
practical advice that don't assume that
your opponent's surprise is good for
them right very often especially if
you're a strong player you're doing your
homework the first move that's played
that you don't know
high probability it's a slightly dubious
move if not a mistake so uh in this case
i don't think that's the case as you
said
but uh
this is this is going to be tough so as
report is working hard here to see if he
can keep the game going regardless of
whether he gets his seventh draw or
surprises us with some craziness let's
remind everybody of the dynamic truly
interesting and creative chess talent
that he is
chess richard report steps into this
year's candidates with reasonable
expectations to place well throughout
his career report has been no stranger
to the top 10 in the world rankings
using his solid performances at the
series of fide grand prix events reports
secured his first bid to the candidates
the hungarian-born competitor is looking
for his first opportunity to become a
challenger for the world championship
reports surged past the 2700 barrier
before he reached 19 years old known for
his offbeat openings report is also
considered by many as the most
unpredictable opening innovator in the
field
also unpredictable is the current status
for which country report will be
representing hungarian-born report is in
the process of moving his chess
allegiances to romania either way report
would be the first from hungary or
romania to win the candidates
[Music]
not sure if he will be on his way to
winning the candidates this particular
time around we'll see i mean he's still
right in the thick of it
right now i'm frustrated that the fact
that this game
might have to end peacefully unless he
can come up with something
something truly surprising for yonder
palmishi so
all right let's let's back up and look
at the other games i kind of want to
swing back over to hikaru's game we
haven't been there in a little bit we've
definitely got an instructive one
up ahead for us uh isolated queen pons
are some of the most rich positions in
chess uh for for the viewers trying to
improve their positional understanding
and car right now
trying to make sure he fully understands
this position really really working hard
at the board i like the word use the
swing to that game because
dude his last move was swinging his
bishop to a new diagonal yeah and that's
an important lesson because uh we tuned
in
earlier i think after white's tenth move
and what's happened is that black had to
retreat with the bishop rather than
capturing this knight on c3 and instead
of
evening the isolated pawn playing field
by taking on d5
yanchez is saying no no no no no let's
not let that bishop out from ca that's
the dynamic we were highlighting earlier
so let's just play around it which is in
bishop c2
queen d3 aiming for checkmate in one and
after the move by hikar f5 he says well
my pieces aren't doing much on this
diagonal anymore there's no universe
where hikaru moves his pawn away from f5
and if that's the case let's go bishop
to b3 to put pressure on this knight on
d5 and behind it this weakened pawn on
e6 any time a pawn moves what it
previously was covering now is under
less control by your side so the f7 pawn
was great protecting e6 now that e6 pawn
becomes a target and d5 can be a bit of
an issue if white could pile up more
pressure with bishop to g5 trying to
remove the other piece defending that
square so this is a big moment for
hikaru i really like the way that
yantristov has played the opening and
you can see that not just on the board
and slight advantage for him on the
evaluation
bar but on the clock yeah car is usually
a very fast player in the opening and
this time it's jan schistoff with the
lead in the clock yep thinking got to
think this one through
you've got this rook on e1 as well
adding insult to injury if you will on
your point about the e6 pawn and yeah
again i really love bishop e3 just shows
that the structure changes
don't beat my head against a brick wall
let's relocate our pieces for a new
target and that's why white has an edge
in these positions and often the dynamic
of the isolated queen pond is
not what black want this is not what
black wants normally black wants the
pieces putting pressure on this pawn
and blockading it is one job you often
try to take so hicaro has established
that part of a strategy against an iqp
which is an isolated queen pond uh but
no pressure to come with it and so the
risk of that is that white just keeps
developing as robert said maybe this
knight maneuvers itself out you
eventually you unleash some pressure
here and and black is just going to be
in pure defense mode so that's that's
not really what hikara wants he's got to
think about how he wants to set up his
pieces here and one of the major things
you need to consider when you're playing
game like this we've traded two pawns
per side what pieces do we want to see
off the board so not only is the e6 pawn
under pressure there is a near future
where white is considering taking on d5
handing black that isolated pawn and
return yeah and if we can then actually
we can i'll just show it like yeah just
just to make it right look because i
love the point you're saying if
something like this happens you know
exactly where i'm going with it
positionally
we have a nightmare ahead for us if
we're black we've been commenting
together a long time you knew exactly
where it's going with it that when we
visualize the future for our pieces that
bishop on d7 it's a passive piece there
is not a single thing it can attack look
at white's pawns all on dark squares
black's pawns on light square so that e5
square is whites for the taking that
bishop on d7 is really just a bystander
and look at the evaluation plus two and
a half despite the material being
completely equal if that doesn't tell
you what a positional advantage in chess
is boys and girls i don't know what will
exactly that's a really great point
robert a near a near piece advantage
according to stockfish 15 in a structure
where everything is equal and material
is equal so that and and the reason
robert spots those so well
strong grand master and commentator that
he is is one of the things you want to
you want of course kha was bad so he's
not going to play that but one of the
things you want to train your chest
brain to do every time a structure
changes as robert said the pawn push
which is e6 is weak but also even though
there's a bunch of
smoke and mirrors right now if you if
you visualize the pieces coming off the
board you can spot other weaknesses
right particularly if this piece is gone
you've got dark squares that open up and
one of the things that can guide the
plan is by always being aware of the
forest through the trees should
everything remove itself right now what
are the weaknesses what is the imaginary
square i would put my knight on or my
rook or whatever and then you develop a
plan around recognizing the weaknesses
first backing up and considering the
move second so i actually actually think
that this is this is what hagar was
thinking is the line robert just showed
to be honest i mean the threat of
simplifying the position on d5 my mouse
is jumping today people like well you've
got a mouse on a couch dan what do you
expect okay
but i apologize i am not i am i did wake
up i had my coffee something a little
jumpy today anyway uh that line robert i
think is exactly what ricardo has to be
worried about how quickly this position
simplifies white starts to play boa
constriction on the boa constrictor on
the dark squares and you are in trouble
yeah and he took care of one problem
which is the checkmate yeah but young
dude keeps posing these problems for
ikaru yeah and if you could put that
pawn back on f7 right now like that
might be black's best best move on the
board
back
you obviously can't do that and so this
is a critical moment and there's a
reason why uh hikara has already spent
14 minutes and counting he's using his
time here because he knows a capture on
d5 is about to happen like that's what
he's looking at what he might be fearful
of and he's going to get a position
where he knows he's worse and he doesn't
have any counter play so i think this
was a perfect opening choice by ian
schuster he lost round six but the way
he's playing this game is like the
perfect rebound yeah i'm not even
concerned about the results so much but
when you lose a game you start
questioning yourself a bit you start
feeling like you're you're on shaky
ground tilt the word they use right and
like you don't have a chance in the
tournament so you want to put yourself
in a position
where you feel comfortable you feel like
you have a chance to play for more but
you're also not risking much this is
what they call playing
results two result position fantastic
point by robert and again it's a good
lesson that's how you you stop the
bleeding you avoid going on tilt this is
going to be a tough position for ikaru
uh
not neces
not even close to like a clear advantage
or losing yet but this is tough and and
there's no real plan for black that gets
you excited right the moves you get
excited about is black are all defensive
moves and like you said the best move is
f7 f5 and that's not a legal one
and you know e5 f7 yeah even immediate
threats kind of just help white let's
say the queen c7 and he plays queen to
b6 so that you know he's attacking the
bishop on b3 but i was going to make
this point that queen c7 like attacking
the pawn on
h2
white just plays g3 and you're helping
me to take on d5 next and then put my
piece on f4 like right you made one move
threat and it actually helps white with
the plan so he plays queen b6 instead
which attacks his bishop on b3 and now
you've a choice like how are you going
to take on d5 i think you can lead with
the bishop i don't think that
that's going to be changing all that
much you could take with the knight too
because the queen defends the bishop
you could do either one yeah
you have a choice and i think we're
going to see black with it isolated upon
d5 and i'm wondering
is there any world where you would want
to take with the knight
first
takes could you want to keep the bishop
on the board no you're just going to
take anyway
i was debating keeping the bishop here
on the board um
i think people would be nervous at this
b2 pawn now right here because like oh i
can't move my bishop to f4 like the
variations danny robert were talking
about because i'm going to lose b2 but
if you take can yeah if you guys didn't
trap my queen yeah you also lose your
bishop on d6 uh if you want that one as
well so you can get away with this uh
very cleanly it looks like
yeah so hikaru will have his work out
for him and again nothing highlights how
much you might want to move again
nothing highlights accurately today
nothing highlights like wanting to move
the pawn backwards other you know more
than a position like this where you're
just staring down the face of an outpost
square like e5 the only thing black has
has going for him here is that it
doesn't just happen immediately right
because there is there's a little bit of
some awkwardness to figure out you have
to worry a little bit about the b2 pawn
so you can't just rush forward so he
carries very good at being resourceful
and finding super precise variations
that kind of expose if you're if his
opponent had any
any flaws in the plan right hikaru will
find it but i think if duda takes the
right approach hikaru has a positional
uphill battle he needs to take a page
out of jose road capoblanca's book
because that position if you showed me
one of those like old you know books
written about capoblanca's best games
that looks like a capoblanca position
where he just crushes you and makes you
look like you don't know how to play
chess despite the position not being
that bad and despite his opponents being
stellar players so it's just a position
where black honestly miserably tries to
figure out a way to hold the game
and just has no active play of his own
so as you pointed out it's not that a
car is losing far from it it's just a
miserable feeling when you're facing the
next 30 moves of the game where you're
like okay i'm just gonna try to stop
this person from beating me rather than
having a chance to play for more
yourself yeah no no one's excited about
playing this between this black probably
the best thing is to try to leave the
tension right away and try to simplify
but either way
it will be it will be uphill and uh
it will be 10 subs to 10 random members
shout out to nintendo
nintendo
i'd say taking a page out of our own
intent dudes book right there i love
that pun night 10.64 dropping 10 for the
community we appreciate you let's back
up to the bird's eye view remind
everybody where we sit currently in
round seven of the 2022 feed of canada
this is where we sit currently they sit
in chairs downstairs and hopefully
you're sitting comfortable somewhere at
home uh fully clothed or not your choice
right your body your choice on a weekend
and uh here we go everyone's there we've
got uh
a break ahead we're gonna back out when
we return
it is
round seven of the 2022 v-day candidates
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational to kids it
feels just like playing the chess is a
great way to learn patience strategy and
critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kit helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
in qualifying for the candidates hikaru
nakamura ratcheted up the level of
interest in what is already considered
the most important tournament in chess
with millions of followers as a popular
content creator hikaru brings along his
sizable community while also attracting
more casual chess fans
although once ranked number two in the
world most believes nakamura's best days
competing in classical chess were behind
him that changed when this japanese
american grand master leaned on his
exceptional calculating ability to win
the fide grand prix the unexpected
victory earned him a bid into the
candidates for the first time in six
years a five-time u.s champion hikaru
has stayed sharp of late by dominating
in speed chess formats nakamura is
currently ranked by fide in the top two
in both rapid and blitz
a chess giant on twitch and youtube
ikaru brings a special buzz to a
tournament that already holds the keys
to becoming the next world champion
and there are certainly those who have
yet to rule out hikaru from catching
lightning in a bottle here in madrid
[Music]
this club is called amigos del retiro
friends of the retiro the retiro is uh
the most big and important park in
madrid it's a very important park in the
city because it's right in the center if
you want to play chess you don't know
the place this is a
maybe best one in madrid
punto
[Music]
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone
you don't even need to download an app
just open any mobile browser and head to
chess.com events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com events
[Music]
we're back
in madrid
the fans gather outside the palacio de
centonia it's a live shot down there
we've got some awesome people
tuning in here it's a plaza not too far
from the palacio de santonia
great restaurants here in madrid city is
alive it's a lot of fun
these players are uh
well the chess has been lively
here in the palacio de centonia and
report is trying to keep it so
but he may not have uh may not have too
much ahead in this game versus nepalm
reshape i still give him so much credit
for sitting there and thinking and
calculating yep the game is
almost certainly going to end in a draw
by repetition because it doesn't seem
like there's much better for him but the
fact that he continues to calculate to
work hard at the board he's showing what
it you know should be like to be a top
chess player yeah
not throwing up his hands
and just throwing in the towel i'm gonna
learn something about the position i've
had games like that where i told myself
that i knew i had messed up in a similar
fashion and i just like was gonna spend
a ton of time because i was like well i
thought i was having six hours today i'm
gonna be done in an hour i might as well
just learn about this position right so
sometimes you're just you know you
calculate a ton you go knee deep and
ultimately you know the position much
better than you would have otherwise so
not that he's here to learn he's here to
win but you know it's interesting but he
did come to the board to calculate
that's what he planned to do today and
that's what he's going to do yep
all right what are we going to do today
pinkie
same thing we do wait does it work the
other way pinky in the brain yeah who's
pinky who's the brain here
i'm not going to answer the question
all right well um oh there's a car
looking over with a with a bit of a a
scowl leg up yeah
not
yeah there it is oh there it is yeah
report says get out of my camera buddy
and fabiano's thinking hey danny robert
and i talked about this position back
during the world championship
well we'll see maybe we'll have bobby in
studio at some point again and we'll
talk about that game and whether he was
thinking that in his head but uh
all right speaking of fabiano i want to
go back to his game because we've seen a
couple more moves in what has been
a very interesting affair rajabov
clearly surprised bobby out of the
opening the time management sort of
backed that up but now that carwana has
gotten what seems to be a comfortable
edge he can push for whenever someone
plays a gambit you're always worried
about your king his king is in safety
he's gotten castle
and uh now it's roger's turn
to use his time
second game in a row i kind of forgot
about it but java blitz out the opening
on the white side of a sicilian against
richard report and then immediately went
to the think tank right after that king
d7 move yep now against fabiano carwana
he's played the opening very fast and
then we have a position where the white
king is very safe it's even material
white has a double pawn on the file this
f5 pawn but has the only light square
bishop and clearing out the e4 square
can be quite valuable for white as this
game continues for either the night of
the bishop as you're pointing out the e5
pawn whenever there are double pawns it
means a file opens everyone can come to
e1 and stare right down the pawn the
black king's still in the center and you
can castle queenside
that's too spicy even for my blood yeah
that you know i like i like the spice
yeah let's let's analyze it again
because
it it's everything you just said that
set the tone well and and uh you
actually called for bishop d3 we showed
a line uh last time we were here of
queen takes g2 which would have been
horrible due to this awesome bishop e4
move that both defends and attacks super
well but okay raja doesn't play that he
backs up the queen but after castles the
practical feeling you feel so good
because you know you've got your king of
center you're a strong enough player
that even if your opponent is blitzing
out prep you know when you're better so
fabi knows he's better he's got to be
loving
the imbalance of the position right
winning it will be another story but if
you came to the board hoping to get
winning chances against your opponent
white has to feel good about this and i
love how we didn't even think about that
black can go knight takes f5 and that
pawn is technically hanging but you're
about to see the evaluation bar go
go very high for white because now i can
just take on f5 you have to take back a
queen d5 and how many pieces does black
have developed
only the queen's not enough is the
scientific answer yeah and look at this
right white can just start striking in
the center b7 is hanging if you play
rook b8 just to defend the pawn that's
under attack you're going to see the
wipe is rook to e1 right and
you have to make the move f6 i think and
it's not worth a pawn to be in a
position where you're underdeveloped
you're maybe never castling this is
really terrible for black yeah
well uh let's talk a little bit again
about that rajab of
preparing
lines well to a certain point but then
maybe ultimately questioning his
decisions right we saw the same thing
against report yesterday uh where he was
in trouble there um with the white
pieces and now
this should tell you one interesting
lesson because we've talked about
different types of preparation sometimes
you prepare something specifically
against a person
but you may not know the position
as well like just intuitively right you
can't replace experience
and
just because you surprised your opponent
if it's not your style and if it's not
opening you played a hundred times where
you're you know all the ins and outs the
pawn structure the type of tactical
patterns that's maybe not advice you
would give someone yeah it's he's not
the only player to be fair we had
already as a farouza right do this
against john de palma she played a very
tactical you know attacking position
where his king was the one that was in
danger and he eventually lost that game
so uh the
advice you're giving is good right you
can't just memorize a string of moves
and we're not claiming that these
players are doing that but for everybody
who's newer to chess out there you can't
just memorize a string of moves and hope
that it will pan out especially when
you're playing against great opponents
because when they deviate from what the
top line of the engine is you need to
play the position that's in front of you
so i think that for java right now he is
just probably trying to recall
many things here you know he's looking
at this i'm underdeveloped and he played
knight to f6 so he brings his knight out
uh to develop here but you were pointing
this out earlier that white actually has
a bunch of simple moves bishop g5 comes
to mind because i want to get rid of
every single piece in black's camp that
controls these light squares yeah so i i
would almost play bishop g5 just
uh rookie one has also got to be a
candidate but
i love what you're saying one of the
best pieces of advice i was ever given
is
memorize ideas not moves yes
and that allows you to play every
opening every middle game transition
your whole
thought process changes when it's like
when you're trying to learn an opening
i'm not actually trying to memorize the
moves i'm trying to memorize every idea
behind it but then in this middle game
there's this idea there's this idea my
opponent has this idea this idea those
are the things that show an
understanding and ultimately are there
for you when you need them not trying to
pull a rabbit out of a hat a move that
you memorize magically so and again
we're not claiming any these guys are
doing they know all this stuff right and
do it way better than than either of us
but it's just super important and i
think we saw it again at the same time
we are commentators it's our job to look
at it and there are there are examples
at times where like you said with all
your research right he obviously is a
well-prepared player better than both of
us hands it doesn't matter not even a
comparison but he clearly gotten himself
into that crazy night off and the moment
one thing was different 40 minutes comes
up came off the clock for a reason he
didn't have as much experience as jan in
those positions and that can backfire
big time and can be a mistake in terms
of what you chose regardless of how well
you memorized it right and the position
type of position that we have here now
that we've escaped the you know the
opening where 11 moves in that this is a
position where fabiano caruana is going
to be very comfortable he has some clear
ideas here he's just trying to decide do
i play rookie one or bishop g5 first
because there are differences between
the move order and implying the pressure
of the pawn or to the knight so fabiano
he's
he now has
a better understanding of the position
he's been calculating for quite
some time he has spent almost an hour to
this point so i think that you know now
that he's at this position the next
bunch of moves will be easier because
his plan to take over the light squares
kind of speaks for itself
well apparently report has other plans
than just accepting the draw he has
played f3 of course he can still
go for lines that repeat
but with yonda pandashi instantly
replying with queen d3 let's remind
everybody of a line we showed earlier
robert
f3 avoids the draw by report that's true
by the way neither player of the board
but after queen d3 if you just play
knight d2 the idea is that the queen is
going to come back to d7 and you might
wish you took the draw now the knight is
moving the queen is trapped note that
the lady has no options for escape
this is this is not this is not what you
want um
and the math at the end of that will be
white will have two rooks
and a pawn for a queen so that's 11
points the queen is nine that sounds
really good but king safety whenever
there's a material imbalance you look at
who is the safer king that tells a large
part of the story so in fact if we just
like kind of force that position on the
board queen to d7 will make some kind of
move like
b3 okay
and then knight to a6
you'll see the advantage is quite large
for black over here because white's king
is not very safe the h3 pawn is already
under attack white lacks coordination
and development and so black's pieces
will eventually go to the king side and
put pressure on that lonely king so
material sounds really good for white 11
points to nine but that's why we don't
just count the individual pieces when i
was younger we would joke like the the
chess the chess dad joke watching
watching come after like oh well he has
more pieces than his opponent off the
board he would always say what's on the
board right what's on the board is what
matters not how many pieces you've taken
off the board and uh shout out to all
chess dads out there supporting their
kids even though they know nothing about
the game love you and moms anyway um
shout out to all the subscribers coming
in by the way we don't shout out all of
you but we really do appreciate the
support uh and the love and uh
yonda pandashi's face is attached to
that why because he's leading the
tournament if that changes we'll update
that with a different face but okay
report
it's it's now or never are we gonna see
92 right and then and then everyone
who's like oh like this is scary don't
let young get a win as black we won't
catch him fabiano won't be very mad yeah
if 92 is played yep and we should just
show the difference king g2 is the only
other move it looks like that should be
uh holding because black goes back queen
g6 check if
black said i don't want to make this
draw anymore after king g2 up like queen
d7 danny's line looks so good let's go
trap the queen the bishop comes out to
e3 now and there's an escape square
because the queen and bishop tag team
the a7 pawn so knight a6 the queen just
takes a7 and then white is up a rook and
two pawns and that's game so uh rapport
would love to get his queen out from the
a8 square where it's entombed but he's
not getting that right it's just not
going to happen for him
well he's still doing his best to uh
think it through
learning learning what he didn't know
about the position i guess and and i i
again i am anticipating the move kimchi
to and despite richard's best efforts uh
conceding
conceding that yawn was the better
prepared man today
okay we'll keep an eye on it in case in
case it's uh a wild decision right now
we back this thing up look at that
beautiful selection of strawberry
blueberry i guess that's peach or mango
in the lower left corner
we do have acai bowls for like
blackberry what we did have acai bowls
we did have baseballs for lunch shout
out to the team getting us lunch a lot
of variety bouncing around um right
before the show goes live we get a
little lunch do a little rehearsal do a
little dance commentate on some chess
get down tonight um
all right i i kind of want to go back to
dingley run for rougea
again we're just going to continue to to
roll around
predicting that uh at some point
china's only ever 2800 player will will
get going but ferruja
playing playing well safar holding his
own as black in this position this is a
this is going to be a truly dynamic
affair yeah and in fact that's good news
for ferruga he likes these types of
positions where it's not very clear we
see the evaluation bar off the side
saying zeros but look at how many pieces
are on the board only one pawn per side
has been traded off so there's a lot of
dynamic possibilities and that c4 pawn
that's where i keep looking because i
feel like at some point white is going
to push b3
and then we will see a capture on b3
opening up the a file which definitely
is not the end of the world for white
because black can't really do anything
with it but
that's the big question from my
perspective is when will i push that
pawn and once that happens how does that
change the game there's another dynamic
i want to highlight that adds tension
here because we highlighted how much e4
is a move that you don't want to play as
long as you have this bishop on g2 or at
least you're hoping that that becomes
something special but i was just going
to say as long as you don't play e4
you're staring down the barrel of this
bishop which is kind of irritating right
it pinned the knight previously spied
the rook and perhaps that's one of the
reasons dingley wren says yeah i don't
like that either so i'm going to put the
rook on c1 um but again that's an
interesting thing we have to keep in
mind right
for both sides not take for granted that
that shot might happen because white
would only do it if there was something
concrete because the moment you do it
you would regret it for the rest of the
game
and
but if you don't there's a bishop that's
active i agree with you i feel like this
is to be fair i'll say it this is the
first furuga s position i've seen
perugia get in several rounds yeah and i
feel like even with the black pieces we
see him taking a bottle sip of water
there we say you only do that when
you're confident he's up 20 minutes on
the clock or okay 13. i don't know i
you know dingley runs position is fine
but i think if your only roger fruit is
a fan
you're happy about this absolutely and
there's one other dynamic that we
haven't discussed is a queen in line
with a bishop the bishop typically wins
that battle on the diagonal and so if we
even go back just before rook to c1 this
goes to show that you shouldn't just
move a knight because it attacks the
queen let's say you go to e4 to d5 right
the queen goes back to d8
otherwise there's an e7 check so that's
important to note you don't have that
anymore and now you've done nothing
right you can take on f6 and trade
pieces but it's clear that black has
much more control of this board the
bishop one f5 is annoying on that
diagonal as you pointed out the bishop
on c5 clearly better than the bishop on
d2 so black's pieces would be happily
situated with those trades which is why
ding isn't just picking up his knight
and moving it away from c3 just yet yeah
i like that point again because
a lot of uh people would go for the
silly rapid tricks are for kids right i
want to move my knight this is another
option where at least here i'm trying to
get the bishop pair
but even here
the queen moves to a square and i'm not
sure that that trade is actually as good
for white as it looks right maybe maybe
you put the queen to attack the pawn and
if this trade happens
all of black's pieces are just very
active here
yeah this is a very nice position for
black and i think you said it best when
you said a very i'll raise a farouza
type of position yeah it's dynamic it's
imbalanced you can you can both out
calculate but also
kind of
where where farouza lives you know i
think in the uh the places where he does
super well it's dynamic there's always
the potential for something to go wrong
both tactically and positionally and and
anyway just looking at the clock
management look at the position
maybe ferruja is finding his form a
little bit so as dingley wren gets up to
to take a walk and purusha takes a think
we're gonna take a quick throw to an
interview that dingley ren had with our
own dina bellankaya not yesterday the
day before the rest day
in round six
ding congratulations on a nice defense
how did you manage to stay calm
when you saw your opponent was so well
prepared
yeah i think this was a good game played
by both sides
i'm very lucky to
find this idea knight g5
i nearly to play c6 instead instead of
bishop d5 but i i saw rookie for
after detective for knight d6 and my
position just
so passive
but
when i found this idea knight g5
if we play rook g3 i'll go back with
knight e4 i think
i have a clear plan to push the pump in
the game
and at some point i
i thought
i would maybe i was better but he found
a very
concrete
line
which started with rook history i think
we didn't have any chance
i think it's a
good game
in general how does a professional
player like you manage to stay calm when
he sees that the opponent is better
prepared
because i know the position objectively
is fine for black
although he's very very well prepared
but i believe in positions
so you believe in positions that's a
great advice um
there has been uh
two years of lockdown did you
by any chance work harder on your chest
or on another notes we're lacking let's
say motivation because of no tournaments
at least there are many online
tournaments
and since i can only play online
so i take it very seriously
sometimes my opponent
plays some random opening but i
i just play some mean lines and try to
take it
as serious as possible
all right thanks a lot thank you
i love dingley wren
i'm just gonna say it
out loud on camera
he is cl he's such a nice guy he's just
so nice
yeah but not normally this nice over the
chess board right he lost game one he's
drawn the rest and he said that he first
of all that variation he showed in his
game as a car was awesome like what his
calculations we didn't look at that game
right no one could see me and rob we
were looking we were just like watching
the analysis like oh man we didn't even
look at that yeah that's the best part
honestly is when you get to hear their
insight and see he's like oh i wasn't
that worried because i believed in the
position that's what you were saying he
didn't necessarily memorize as much uh
as computer prep as a car had but he
believed in the foundation the position
and one more thing i want to point out
about dingley ren and he said he takes
the online events very seriously
hikaru nakamura wins speeches
championships left and right but there
was one person who almost took him down
and it was dingley wren yeah and he was
shocking in the world but i don't think
he shocked himself because we know how
freaking strong he is
at his best and he almost took down
hikaru nakamura in a car was best format
yeah no well said and that was one of
the most exciting
matches of all time um
yeah well uh
the
position here against ellie rosa farouja
though as much as we're
talking about ding looks less
comfortable for black so
we have
omgs or snaps
we have action liftoff whatever you want
to call it we might have regret
at some point down the line
as richard report
makes the decision not to allow the draw
to go for the line with knight to d2
wow allow the queen
trap that's about to happen that knight
a6 is is going to be on the board and
just as soon as john comes back to the
board
um
[Music]
if you're fabiano carwana everyone in
that room has to focus on their own
chess we know that and sometimes that's
super important because you don't want
to let your emotions
get the best of you you're focusing on
something that is literally outside of
your control yeah
but if report goes on to lose this game
from that decision and yawn's lead is
extended going into the back half of the
event
we are never going to forget this
decision by richard report but i think
from reports perspective and i've been
kind of dwelling on this because
i was saying this would never happen
he's not going to play on this is jan's
preparation this is too risky
from his own point of view he's drawn
six games right if he drew this game
which he could have
he had that on the table
it would have been seven draws he
probably would have been starting to
feel like my chances are slipping of
winning and he doesn't care who he is
if it's not him he wants to win so
from that perspective i mean i have to
continue to give him a lot of credit
that he is willing to fight
every single game he is we saw it just
from him getting here against demetrion
draken he took a huge risk in that final
game of the fide grand prix and he
reaped the rewards he won that game yeah
and that's not to say that you should
always continue to play for a specific
result because playing for a result is
actually not good you want to play
objectively position but he's saying
that you know what
what i'm seeing what i'm visualizing
here and we're about to continue to get
moves the queen takes on that fate the
bishop i think will take back and the
king can also capture back but he's
saying this doesn't look that bad for me
at least in his head now he is facing
who knows how much more computer
preparation and that's worrisome yep but
as we look at the position as you know
pretend like we're in
sitting at the board trying to figure
this out for the first time
i mean you do the material count we're
just talking about before that you get
two rooks
and a pawn for a queen that's a lot your
king doesn't feel that safe but black
doesn't have that many pieces remaining
to go deliver a checkmate and if black
yonder palm she tries too hard to win
this game
look who has an extra pawn on the queen
side maybe i can get a pass pawn going
right and get my rooks activated
and white definitely has a chance in
this game so you know i know i was
probably a bit harsh earlier and saying
that there's no way he could do this but
now that i'm looking at it
why not
okay
i mean
yes
to everything you said
and though
if you're gone to pamnishi
and they say that you both have to play
good chess and sometimes have a few
things go your way to win a super
tournament
just like
fabiano is happy maybe ultimately with
teamwork or java's decision to give him
some lively chess
you got to be happy if you're going to
palm rishi here you're like well
uh i know this is good for me or i
wouldn't have gotten here with oh oh by
the way um an hour and 50 minutes on my
clock before this turn started right
if i didn't know it was good for black
so these are the types of opportunities
that you need to win the candidates for
the second time and challenge again for
the world championship title you need a
little help sometimes and so if he goes
on to win the everything you just said
that's true about report and i do
applaud him in the same way by the way
i'm not just saying that i'm thinking
about yawns here i'm like you gotta you
gotta be like wow this is working out
although jan is thinking right now yeah
his preparation is done okay and we saw
a game in the world championship where
magnus carlson gave up his queen for a
couple rooks yeah
and that game ended up going magnus's
way yep that was game six there's a very
long game a very different dynamic than
we see here breaking game but
the preparation is done yep and now it's
up to yan to prove his advantage
and it's not the type of position where
you're like okay i was better like hey
car against jan there's like he was
better than he made some inaccuracies
and now it's just
pretty level yeah this is type of game
where if you go wrong as black
white has two rooks for a queen
white has an extra pawn on the queen
side so if you start stumbling you're
not just maybe losing your winning
chances you might get into trouble yeah
so i think it's unbalanced in that way
right for sure so
fans saying it's unbalanced and maybe
they'd love to see report win
curmo 13 in chat we see you i would love
to see report win this one
well you wouldn't be alone report would
also love to see with this one um
gouda because i like report structure
um i don't know if there's any sarcasm
there is that like a sarcasm above it
because i don't know his structure's
that great
you mean those double h pawns
it must be a little bit of sarcasm but
we'll take it either way uh anyway all
right well no totally fair and here's
the thing either way like this is
another you know russell crowe moment
are you not entertained by this right
report
takes an hour after being surprised
decides he's not going to give up going
for fighting chess and we have liftoff
can i say one thing about richard report
yeah he should be invited to every
tournament yeah every single tournament
because of moments like this exactly
like whether or not he wins the
candidates is
not important to me in terms of my
statement because he is not the player
who ever sits there and just like let's
make a draw he could have made a draw in
this game in the candidates the most
important tournament of his life
objectively maybe the best decision but
he still goes for the fighting chess i'm
saying to every single organizer out
there invite him to every turn no he
really should and of course we know he
just switched federations again shout
out to another chat cozy kumo says what
a story that would be if report won
seriously what a story that would be if
he made that kind of decision
and uh
threw people on his back and said i'm
going to carry you to slowing down
yonder bomb rishi because someone's got
to do it what a risky decision it is but
this is no by the way you know what i
told you report is
he's one of those players who people
didn't
don't hear about as much as maybe some
of the other household names but this is
a guy who's an absolute creative genius
and
to maintain the position he does
on in his rating and in the top 10 in
the world given the type of chess that
he plays and the type of decisions that
he makes like this it shows you how
strong he is yeah no he is an absolute
monster and you know look at yon napoli
thinking right now what does that tell
you he's out of his prep so we we can
see the eval jan knows that this
position should be pretty good for black
maybe he doesn't know the exact number
and he doesn't remember how to proceed
from here so
i'm asking you seriously genuinely danny
what do you make of this moment here
where jan doesn't know how to take back
the queen it's not just this immediate
move but does he feel comfortable with
the follow-up
i'll be honest my my initial reaction to
yon slowing down was actually to applaud
yawn and not quit not not immediately
assume he was out of his prep i was
actually pausing to say like okay is
this the mature yawn that he needs to
maintain in order to maintain the lead
which is all right
here's here's what could happen but
here's here's the other narrative is jan
is genuinely surprised the report
doesn't go for the draw
knows the line knows he should be better
and now he's going to use the hour he's
gained on the clock to make sure that he
does everything right that he doesn't
make a hasty decision doesn't let his
emotions get the best of him so one
version is okay what you're saying like
he's out of prep the other version is
maybe he's he's doing the type of thing
that ultimately got him into the world
championship match versus magnus carlson
so i i don't know so i'm i'm actually
kind of waiting to see right and i think
um
again
we'd make jokes about jinxing just so
everyone knows we were talking behind
the scenes about whether we were gonna
have a quick draw whether we would get
nepo in studio here uh so early in the
show because we haven't had players in
studio as often as we like well guess
what best laid planes of mice and men i
don't think we need to worry about
getting a player in studio early in this
match today uh in these games today
because let's back out to the bird's eye
view and just reset every single one of
these games is once again going to
deliver welcome to madrid i love it this
is awesome there's
fighting chess all around look at it
karu coming up with an interesting way
to say hold on i know i'm i know i'm i
know i'm worse here
but
remember how i said before we left it
the one thing hikaru does so well right
you and i talk about this a lot is like
he's objectively worse positionally it's
it's not a great call but he's just so
darn accurate in the move orders and if
you slip for a second
like we saw against farrugia with the c3
save like he's just so pesky and
resourceful he's not going to go down
without a fight and already that
position looks more unclear than it did
when we left it yeah in the top right we
see a car plants his rook on e4
he has pawns on d5 and f5 that means e4
should be his square for the taking and
already young system he's in a moment
where he's like uh i want to play f3 but
my d4 pawn now is hanging i definitely
do not want to take your work on e4
because that allows you to recapture
with a pawn and open up your bishop
either way actually yeah exactly either
way both both would be interesting um
and so can we just go back a couple
moves yeah let's see because it felt
like jan schuster had this position
where you know he could do whatever he
wanted and now it's like just two moves
later like wait a second it feels like a
car is kind of riding the ship so maybe
young should have taken on
instead of g3 move order and your ideas
that you're gonna
follow up by
not letting the rook in i mean
yeah you you could bring the knight to
c3 if you want if you want to go that
way you could also
play g3 and you know delay in a move so
yeah because even you're right robert
because even this move order when the
world comes to e4 at least now you're
not attacking the pawn like hikaru is in
the current live position right so that
that that's a you can play f3 and then
just kick it out of there right oh even
right now oh yeah f3
get out of my house
and then
yeah i don't i don't know when you're
maybe here yeah you could work on c1 you
can use the dual open files so there are
many different
moves here and that's the tricky part
for yon trista right i don't pretend to
sit here and act like i have all the
answers but like often times in these
positions you need to find that one path
that keeps your advantage and after
what's happened in the game yep where he
allowed the capture on f4 and put rook
to e4 here he's thinking oh no like my
pawn d4 is under attack
my b2 pawn is still hanging i have to
come up with an idea how to respond and
if i take on d5 for example
with my knight which looks like a pawn
that i can just grab queen takes d4 and
off come a lot of the pieces
yeah and that's exactly what you don't
want when your opponent's pawn is the
weakest pawn on the board the last thing
you want to do is trade that for any of
your pawns you wouldn't want to trade
black's d5 pawn for your h2 pawn in this
position because
the whole
the plan was to win that thing for free
not in any kind of exchange and so
hikaru again with this with this tricky
move order rook 88
probably robert was right right here was
a super important moment
to appreciate rookie for coming
and and perhaps fine bishop takes d6 to
get the queen but by the way both off of
d4 and b2 that queen is not as effective
there and you go back to the same type
of idea to bring the knight out but
you're already in maybe a little more
accurate spot
okay but as you said it's harvested
judge just shows you
why many people don't judge they applaud
hikaru when he when he plays chess um
because uh
we we still have a game here yeah this
d4 pawn hang is super annoying yeah it's
like let's say you play rook a to d1
thinking oh i'll just protect my pawn i
don't want to trade e4 yeah i was told
not to do that uh if i bring this a rook
here
there's bishop a4 there's a queen takes
b2 in that position there's all sorts of
things that you need to calculate
because normally queen takes b2 is meant
by rook to b1 but you can't do that here
because your d4 pawn is also loose in
many positions yeah i was going to say
you could even trade yeah but definitely
to do the tempo anymore
and already we're in these spots where
black is winning enough pawns to justify
that yeah i know this guy's bad i know
i'm gonna lose him at some point but i'm
i'm picking up enough stuff
to keep it interesting um
well and young christoph is thinking
right a little bit uh
oh hey buddy
hey there you looking looking over here
i see you i see you
i see you like avatar style james
cameron like i see you what does that
mean again it's like a
see your spirit
i see you
that's an orange girl
i don't know but that's an identity
reference shout out to junk
um
okay
well
young kristoff doesn't maybe doesn't
want to see the move order that he
allowed on the board um
we see a lot of sponsors on young
kristoff's uh giddy up there which again
just shout out to all those throwing
their support behind top chess players
we know that he has a large community
behind him from poland an entire country
really
and uh
then yeah
i don't know who all the sponsors are i
have no idea who those sponsors are but
shout out to him
so i don't know either but yes he is
kind of like a national hero in poland
and he has had incredible results he won
the world cup
he also won the grand chester event in
poland so that must have been really
nice there's a reason why poland hosted
the world rapid and blitz and i'm pretty
sure
it's his celebrity that in fact plays a
part and yep you know other polish
greats you know who came before him
there's wrestler boy tacheck they're his
team of seconds there's gayevsky and he
has camille miton so poland is a very
very strong chess country
and probably we're going to be talking
about generations to come too because
usually when you have a star like young
christopher eyes in the way that he has
you uh
you have a lot of people getting
inspired to play chess so speaking of
the star that is duda he also caught up
with dina bellancaya it was an awesome
interview despite having a very very
tough loss to yon apannashi in round six
and we're going to see what they got up
to right now
young
appreciate you coming regardless of the
results
what are your first thoughts about
today's game yeah i'm very disappointed
of course um
i was under pressure most game but um
yeah at some point i thought it was
basically going
to be draw because
i mean there was
a little material left actually
so um
yeah i actually don't know when uh where
i support to be honest
um
yeah somehow i thought maybe rookies a2
was just very unpractical
but i just didn't see a single threat
from him to be honest even though the
position was tricky all the time so
yeah i honestly don't know what i did
wrong
how are you gonna approach this result
and tomorrow is the rest day are you
gonna like just not watch it this game
at all or still analyze it until very
early morning
uh yeah a little bit i guess not for
five minutes maybe ten the max
all right well thank you so much and uh
wish you forget the result very soon
thanks
you know what the best part of that
interview was
that he gave it and was courteous and
professional despite losing
and to me as a young player who's going
to be a part of the future stars for
many years to come
it's just awesome to see the
appreciation knowing how much the fans
want to hear from him everyone see him
and i'm not saying that it also wasn't
contractually required right but you can
contractually do something that's
required and say i'm just here so i
don't get fined right i mean there is
that type of attitude whether those
words are said that you can experience
from top athletes sometimes
understandably so robert because they're
they're pissed off right but the truth
is that was just awesome to see him in
that kind of spirit well dude also the
single best interview in chess history
when his mom died
his mom came and hugged him
mods out there please find the clip of
me of me uh uh saying hi mom when his
mom came in and gave him a big hug after
he won also by the way one of the most
exciting speeches championship matches
we ever had coming back for from a
two-game deficit against alexander
grisham with just minutes on the clock
so anyway young kristoff
a star for a long time to come we
certainly believe so and hope so and uh
right now
a little frustrated by how an inaccuracy
gotta carry i swear to god i almost i
almost called it i was like hey but
that's what hikaru does like you gotta
be precise here he's he's not gonna miss
a chance and unfortunately jkd maybe
played an inaccurate move order yeah he
still has you know a slight pull and
this position is one where he's not in
any danger of losing at least he
shouldn't be unless he really
goes wrong
but one idea that i'm thinking about
right now so instead of allowing black
to make trades which we know can help in
the defensive task
is the move rook d1 but the e-rook which
is incredibly counter-intuitive to bring
the rook from the open file to the
defense but because the d5 pawn is a
target we've covered d4 and queen takes
b2
is no longer an option for black in the
same way because after queen takes b2
there's no longer that rook takes e1
bailout that you were mentioning after
rook a to b1 where is that queen going
only over there to a2 and after rook
takes b7 i got my pawn back as you're
pointing out the seventh rank is white
for the taking the a7 pawn is also
hanging so if you want to keep pieces on
the board rook e to d1
and i am positive that yanchez was
thinking about this move yeah uh is
available but it's such an odd move
because after rook ed1 you mentioned
this bishop a4 idea
and in order to keep the piece on the
board you have to put yourself in knots
like all sorts of weird places where
black now has the open file the e file
it doesn't lead to checkmate so white is
okay with that but the biggest problem
for white is you need to get your knight
from d3
into e5 e5 is the eventual square you
need to get to but your d4 pawn is
continuously under attack so i'm not
sure how to get there but this is the
type of thing that a player like magnus
carlsen does where he recognizes that
okay maybe i made a slight inaccuracy
but i can still fight for a win and i
have nothing to risk in the position so
i actually think that something like
this
would give duda chances to then try to
win the game and get an advantage once
again i like it
it's awkward
um but
you pointed out again the forest through
the trees despite how awkward the
temporary requirements were to hold on
is that white is still positionally
better you can just put that pony right
where you want it right there on on e5
even other dark squares will be
available at different times you have
long term chances
but as we keep saying also shout out to
hikaru for making this tricky making
this super super difficult and
we'll see uh whether young christoph can
can find a move order that keeps the
fight alive so all right
oh man
report yondu palmashi i'm just
that game
is going to have us on the edge of our
seats with these decisions made by
rapport to keep the fight alive to play
for a win
yawn is uh
going to have a battle of queen versus
two rooks of course the last time we had
queen versus two rooks as both uh robert
hess and our own mike klein just just
tweeted live from here from madrid last
time this happened we had an eight-hour
record-setting slugfest in dubai uh that
of course did not go yonda dishes way a
little bit of a different situation here
but
but i would say much different situation
much different and the reason why is
just king safety whereas the game
against magnus carlsen yonz king was the
one that was in if your territory here
it's clear that jan king has no issues
back on g8 so
you know we did
say that okay you know we're feeling it
from report that you know we like the
spirit of it we know that jan has the
better position and right now it's about
coming up with a plan
and
that is what i'm struggling to see
because the reason why h6 danny is such
a nasty move
is you would love to play rook to d8 get
york active pin the bishop but what h6
just did well i guess they're going to
do it right now because
but even if i guess you can't move the
rook anywhere
i know the point you were making it
robert's point is that even if you get
this now and even with threats of this
you no longer have to worry about
checkmate which means that you know who
knows what that black queen would get up
to in the meantime there's so many
difficult situations also you're just no
longer worried about background
checkmate which means the bishop is free
yeah so this is now nothing it's a check
well i'm just gonna be yeah i completely
forgot the rook on f1 is hanging with
checkmate after rook d8 so i also
blunder immediate mates but i was gonna
say that rook d allows queen h4 as well
because you've taken away the g5 square
so there are all sorts of things
available and h6 is just a patient move
making sure that you're as you said your
king can escape and
it's
starting to look difficult i think that
white needs to do something on the queen
side yeah you have the extra pawn you
have to get the three on two going here
i i was actually surprised to see bishop
before by the way just to back up we
again report just thought about this
position for more than an hour i don't
think anyone knows it better than him at
this point but uh i thought the bishop
was going to e3 robert just because it's
by day seven which i thought kept the
queen down right there is no i assume
this is not a trade black would want to
make and give white this past a pawn
potential is exactly the kind of
imbalance you probably don't want
but
but there's obviously other reasons for
the bishop to be on f4 um and not e3 one
of them is that it can come to g3 in a
lot of positions which will cut off the
queen's attacking of the f3 pawn so in
fact now that i see that on the board
report has a vision here robert he wants
to put the bishop on g3 which kind of
makes the king feel safe then he can
start to get both rooks going in an
active way because that queen is no
longer spying the f3 pawn in fact right
as i say that he goes for it so
so that's the idea
again there's a reason black is better
here white's king is open
black has a couple of pawns to go with
the
queen but this this is going to be a
fight an imbalanced fight where i'll say
this to the fans regardless of
of what happens in the end
don't let the evil bar fool you for just
how difficult this position is for both
players this is this is a
really really tricky position and
whenever you have material imbalances
robert we talk about it where like
knight bishop versus rook is an
imbalance right even an exchange sack is
an imbalance and what we mean by that is
when the points
you know dr evil fingers the points are
the same but the pieces want different
things right what the queen desires is
different than what the two rooks desire
right and in those imbalances you get
large eval swings with one inaccuracy
because
the the moment you slip and you let the
rooks double in the wrong in the wrong
file or or on the wrong rank the queen
quickly becomes not as good as the other
as the other pieces right so material
imbalances are some of the hardest
positions to really outplay your
opponent in chess yeah and there's a
reason why two rooks are often
considered better than a queen yeah
that's because they can team up on
squares right or on pieces so if you get
these rooks in the seventh rank and you
just can team up on a7 and f7 and all
that stuff that's great but the problem
is white's king yeah so
well there are multiple problems but the
main issue is white's king
and white will not be able to secure the
second rank if this black queen can get
into like the second rank and start
attacking these pawns on the queen side
it's not going to be easy for white to
defend all of them yep and you've issues
in the king side and if you can't secure
the queen side that means that
you know playing on both areas will be
good for black and the queen is better
than rooks and playing on both sides of
the board yep yeah
i haven't done a video series for
chess.com a long time but one of the
ones i did talked about usually one of
the dynamic facts there are two dynamic
factors if you're trying to weigh
decisions of do i want the rooks of the
queens and unfortunately for report
robert nepo has both of those factors
here the factors are
are there are there pawn weaknesses on
both sides of the board pawn targets and
is the king open because that's
typically where the queen thrives
positions where she's on a square where
she's both spying weaknesses and spying
diagonal checks right squares where
you're hitting pawns but keeping an eye
on an open king those are the types of
positions where the queen flexes because
the only way the rooks can compete with
the queen is constant coordination and
in an open board when you have to defend
things on both sides of a board it's
hard to coordinate it's it's sometimes
impossible
so
in addition all that this is a very big
question yeah one that i asked in the
duda against hikaru game is what pieces
do both sides want to see traded here
who's happier for black can play this
logical move knight c5 here who's
happier about a nitrate
right these questions are really
important and
i would say that black is happier about
the nitrate because that knight is very
important in the defense of white's king
and the black man on a6 is just all the
way out i was gonna say two one this
knight's inactive and two this knight's
important yeah go ahead yeah so yeah
exactly that so where would that not on
a6 want to go it would love to go to the
center towards knight c5 and maybe
knight e6 which helps protect the back
rank it also can jump forward in the
future to squares like g5 and f4 so i
feel like knight c5 is a good move
removing one of white's defenders
bringing the piece that's offside into
the game and because the move h6 was
played the king always has an escape
square off the back rank there will be
no checkmate so i think that yan
should start with knight c5 but what
he's doing is not just calculating the
next three moves he's making certain
that a night trade actually helps his
winning chances at this point yeah
because the the last thing you want to
do is spoil an advantage by trading the
wrong set of pieces yeah that's a really
good point and those types of force
through the tree's questions are what
you have to ask yourself
in order to convert on advantages what
trades help me what trades help them
before you uh offer them up so
all right well let's offer up a a
different view here and remind everybody
there are four games still in progress
here in round seven
at the 2022 feet of candidates in madrid
see what dude i did
i have been top right
top right you played your move rookie
didn't you won right we were just there
talking about the fact that you need to
avoid some peace trades and uh judah
doesn't
i was looking at what fobby did he
played both bishop g5 and rookie one
um also noticed the time disparity not
nearly what it was only ten minutes
basically on the clock for java where at
one point that was about a half an hour
um
so that's that's important dimly random
perugia
have uh
actually ferruccia hasn't moved since we
left rook to c1 was played by dingley
wren and
obviously despite our uh best efforts to
applaud this is a an ali reza rouge i
think kind of position one where he
should be doing okay feeling feeling
good unlike maybe some of the openings
that you know people have been
questionable about with all due respect
i think that uh
i'm surprised to see him thinking for so
long it's concerning it's concerning
because you know yeah the person with
the least amount of time is report but
he's already moved 27. his game almost
doesn't count at this point it counts a
lot but it's like his game is very deep
this game between dingley red and reza
fruga is only on move 13.
so they have 27 moves to make 27 moves
to make till time control and he still
does have plenty of time but he's had a
tendency in this tournament to really
use a lot of clock and then when he
needs clock to figure out how to play he
doesn't have it so
this position is we've liked it from his
side and he's trying to figure out how
can he you know maintain the position or
even try to
get an advantage but i feel like if you
put him in a bullet chess game we had
one minute for the entire game yeah he
would make a move like rook f to e8
which is a great it's like a very good
move instant and he would just do it
instantly yep
yeah well we'll see it's concerning uh
it's concerning because of
how we've we've seen a couple games get
away from perugia um obviously and where
he sits at the standings you don't want
to see that um
repeat itself
uh
and again it's concerning because it
continues to add credit to the story
line of everything you talk about and
preparing for these events there's the
there's the homework you do in the
kitchen but you also have to play chess
always in order to play chess at a high
level some sometimes people forget the
best way you play chess at a high level
is by constantly playing chess at a high
level right and hicaro talked about that
like playing in the rapid chess
championship like what better
preparation can i get than playing
strong players online or offline so you
just worry about that when you see time
disparity there because those are the
practical muscles you need what are you
over thinking about you you said as a
bullet player rob you just play rook fv8
right and then you have
35 minutes back on your clock right um
and certainly again like this is his
game to play we see he's like moving in
his chair maybe he's getting ready to
move
but it's
what was it i feel like i was given a
piece of advice that at some point
you just start spinning your wheels
right hammer said that when he was here
at certain point after 15 20 minutes so
at this point like you're spinning your
wheels a little bit when you're spending
that much time on the clock
clock is part of the game yeah and i
am a culprit so i sometimes get in the
same boat where i'm trying to figure out
not just the current dynamic but
something like eight moves down the line
in six different variations and i would
have made the same move that i spent 45
minutes making in two seconds right and
i think that this position in particular
isn't that clear right there only one
pawn has been traded per side so there's
no like target to pinpoint there's no
clear threat from either side so what
ferrous is trying to do here is he's
really trying to work his way through
like what is my actual plan rook fe-8
that's an obvious move yeah but what's
the plan after that right even if you
gave black another turn from that
position what would you do and that's
actually not that easy to answer we've
talked about moves like knight to e5
which you can think about playing now as
well but you're still looking the bishop
on d2 and the queen on a5 so there's
just a lot to figure out in this moment
and i understand his impulse to spend
the time but it's become a trend and
that's the problem it was a one-off
situation we wouldn't even think about
it like okay he can spend
40 minutes on the clock but fabiano when
he was interviewed by dina he was saying
it's just he hasn't been himself he's
spending 30 minutes 40 minutes in all
these situations and that's not like him
and then he's not playing his best chess
yep
yeah and rook again we're not trying to
oversimplify rook efficiency move uh
bishop g6 is also a move to avoid any
just to kind of put peace on safe
squares you could also move the queen
right now to avoid discoveries although
i think we established that there
probably isn't really a powerful threat
of discovery um the one thing i like
about bishop g6 and rookie 8 is they
both make 97 check not an issue anymore
one way guards it one protects the
bishop so that on this move knight d5
robert you could you could keep the
queen over here right which is kind of a
cool idea that you were highlighting to
either use the diagonal or put pressure
on the pawn
and again to note everybody if knight d5
is played and you don't play one of
those moves rookie or bishop g6 there's
a threat of forking
uh
on e7 so
still still hasn't moved uh ollie rosa
perugia leaning in his chair um
all right let's let's back out again
because we kind of came here to sort of
highlight the major factor which was
that we haven't had anything major
change yet um i i want to go back to
fabiano's game
we haven't seen it in uh
a little bit
but we're doing such a god
i can't speak today doing such a god i
was gonna say good job i thought you
were like
you know seeing job wrong from arrested
development and i was just very confused
joe one of the best characters in any
show ever shout out to you arrested
development but i i i was eating some
walnuts a little protein for the show
and it's giving me cotton mouth so i'm
just gonna say it sometimes you know you
have to say you're nervous to get
through your nerves i'm just telling
everybody are you sure you're having an
allergic reaction like i'm
i hope not i have serious cotton mouth
right now super dry i'm sorry so it's
okay we're just going to continue on and
call it out keep going we can do that
thing where you drink some water and i
just talk about the game and we take us
off camera so yeah let's let's do that
thing
i'm going to drink some water even on
camera right now because i got to fix
this and let you let you talk about this
position fabiano and uh
well fabian is up from his chair we just
saw him walking around good job of
sitting and calculating and the reason
why rajabov is thinking so hard right
now is his e5 pawn is under attack
you don't gotta do that you're gonna
swish around your mouth i mean you do
for your sake you don't have to look at
me while you do it
[Laughter]
you don't
look at me while you do it okay whoa
castle queen side okay look at me while
you do it all right let's go
inside what in the world is going on
here and i think what's most shocking to
me about that danny is we we're not
really joking we were saying it was
possible for a job to castle queen side
before he went knight f6 and bishop e7
so the fact that he cleared out the king
side and then still went queenside that
was surprising
it's i mean this is like
rejava is playing for two results a draw
and a loss it feels like that's how he's
playing this what a crazy move to go for
in this spot where your opponent already
has the bishop pair already has an open
c file
and e5 is hanging by the way yeah why
don't we just take it i don't know um
what is the downside of rook takes e5 it
seems like opponent you can happily snag
let's look at it yeah rotates e5
i
i don't really see another peter says
you're not wrong robert
i guess knight c6 back hits the rook and
hits the bishop on d3 so that could be a
bit annoying but you can even bring a
rook back to e3 something that feels a
little i could see being scared to do
this right not to say that fabiano isn't
as we said the most accurate call your
bluff type of person uh in the in the
top world of chess
but it feels scary right then like
bishop c5 is coming and now what are you
doing putting the rook over here
right somewhere yeah it is awkward so it
feels like the kind of position that
you would be scared to go for although
to be fair white gets one move and like
all problems are solved right you put
the queen off the off of the file you
put a rook on d1 and you're just up a
pawn with the bishop pair with the
bishop pair so that's
fabiano as we saw in the game with ali
raza perugia he kind of said he hadn't
seen f5 robertson was on the board and
then
he'll play a risky move once it's in
front of him he's not afraid to be super
accurate and challenge his opponent's
calculation
um so don't be surprised if he goes for
that but what rajab is doing is he's
still playing in the gambit style where
he started the game off by playing a d5
move giving away a pawn and now the
material is even
and fabio doesn't have to take this pawn
e5 he can probably maintain a slight
advantage without capturing that pawn
but we don't see anything immediately
wrong with it and there's actually
another variation just quickly to show
that rook takes e5 knight c6 okay rook
takes c5 knight c6 maybe you can take an
f6 with your bishop oh and go to d5 yeah
because
i'm realizing that after
right here you can put your rook on
maybe even
i thought this is what you were going
for eliminating the knight so you could
put the rook on d5 and trey yeah exactly
right and now you're saying all right
i've closed the d file i'm up a pawn
everything seems happy and one thing
here is that knight takes e5 bishop
takes e5 it looks like your queen takes
d3 and now black is up in exchange but i
don't know if you're gonna survive after
queen to c1 and you have a very very
very big problem with your king wow what
a fine robert queen c1
the king
can't go anywhere
if only you could just leap frog over
the guard to the eight square you're
probably although even there knight a4
is coming and i don't think that it's
over over
but um
queen c4 there's knight d5
that's a move that's a move i'm gonna by
the way this comes with check but it
doesn't matter
because you take back with check and
then after king d7 you're just bringing
all the pieces 67 or something right
here rook c7 wins the bish 27 as well
and i wanted to show that knight to b6
was mate but there's there's no real way
to do it except just oh wait you can't
even move the queen off of the file but
that is a threat right there knight b6
threatening checkmate um
okay well bobby clearly a little
surprised although i've recognized a
little bit of the body language shift
robert what do you see there from favi
we call it he's ready to pounce he's got
the perch that's the fobby perch yeah
he's ready to grab that e5 pawn and then
play for a decisive result yeah he uh he
gets a little bit of a
sits up in his chair leans in
arches the back
that you should do it put your back into
it he's really tall every time i see it
i have to say that his chairs are so
tall it's so insanely tall
well
uh fit for a king i guess they wanted
every one of the players to feel like
they were sitting on a throne
and dingley wren said i don't i don't
need that
you know
um
i i can i cannot wait for the fireworks
are going to happen here and i do
applaud for java for bringing some
fighting chests to the table here not to
say that
he wasn't going to be facing a grind
playing the black pieces against bobby
on a car no matter what but he you know
he went he went for it went for a fight
yeah and it shows that he also wants to
win this tournament and face magnus for
the world championship so he's not here
just to you know be the lowest rated or
you know just try to do decently you
know he wants to win
yandaponrishi has played h5 against
report it's looking more and more
ominous
lots of craziness going on there hikaru
quickly responded to dude's decision to
keep the pieces on the board with bishop
to c6
and yet again
ali reza perugia
is in a 40 minute think tank
wow
i i just don't quite know what to say um
i'm just surprised
yeah because even like right there when
you when oftentimes when chess players
put their head in the table it's they're
calculating some long sequences they're
not looking at the position that's in
front of them they're looking at
something
far out right but this isn't a concrete
position and that's what's making me
nervous for him right is that this isn't
a position where he can just go for
something direct it's a pretty ambiguous
position yep and the fact that he
he's not moving you can't solve
positions like this with calculation not
right neural nets don't try to solve
this position with thinking 40 minutes
you know what i mean the machines don't
and they can go a mile a minute you
you make an evaluation right you
calculate critical lines you make an
evaluation
of of of a plan an approach that you
think improves your position and you and
you go for it i again that's why we keep
coming back and you know when you
weren't here i was talking with alberto
like because the talbot winning book was
such an amazing bug if you've never read
talbot binnick 1960
do what i haven't read oh my gosh you
kill me it's one of the greatest chess
books of all time i've read like three
chess books okay
sorry
if you're everyone else uh you should it
is an amazing memoir of a match and it's
tau taking you through every game not
just with x's and o's he analyzes it but
talks about the thoughts and again one
thing that really stuck with me was
everything he talked about in regards to
mikhail botvenic's practical skills not
feeling totally inlined when he went
because he hadn't played nearly as much
tal had to make it through robert this
like grueling system of candidates and
qualifiers wasn't quite called the
candidates then but a whole system of
interzonals to play badminic bodbinic
played like nine games that year or
something like that and
a lot of the early games where cal was
able to strike were actually described
like this where he could just sense that
tao was taking 30 minutes on a move that
was like a force recapture and when
you're thinking too much about positions
that aren't concrete in front of you
there's the advantage if it all works
out exactly you're ahead of the game but
the reality is you just you can't map it
out that way because the clock is a part
of the game you have to respect that
right and at some point when you need to
make 20 moves you need more than 20
minutes on your clock and and that's
what gets us worried again because it's
a pattern and i'm not trying to be able
to be critical i'm just observing what
i've seen here in several games and it
just you have you have to be concerned
about this yeah and his body language
he's been grimacing he's grabbing his
head yep he just doesn't seem like he's
very content with
the game and with his position and
he's just burning all these minutes and
you're right you can't afford it so
something just not right for alaris of
fruition two things just happened on the
top right of our screen between duda and
nakamura h4 was played putting another
pawn you know four to the dark squares
and then we see in the top left with yon
napomshi you know still has that queen
for those two rooks but
one of the rooks has lifted to d3 so
making sure that the pawn f3 is defended
and
we do see the evaluation bar we can't
ignore that but just doesn't feel like
the type position where it's like that
clear-cut where black is just much
better and there's nothing that white
has it still feels like a dynamic where
yana pomshi has the edge but he
there's a lot of opportunity to go wrong
yep
well
as you said ali rosa rooster probably
can't afford the time he's taking no one
watching can afford to go anywhere else
because we have amazing chess ahead here
all four games in action
and everyone online
well you can't afford to miss your
opportunity to compete in the chess.com
global championship open qualifiers are
running every saturday and sunday
through july 31st this is your chance to
compete in a tournament that at the
round of 64 32 chess legends and top
players will be invited to join 32
players that have qualified their way
through the gauntlet that is the next
few months go to go.chess.com cgc 2022
become verified your account gets
checked for fair play you join you join
that community that has the right to
compete in these events for more than a
million dollars in prizes
and uh you don't want to miss it every
weekend is your chance
all right we're going to take a very
quick break when we come back we've got
a lot of action ahead shout out to the
fan zone players are upstairs having a
drink chilling blitzing out some moves
watching commentary in the background
and uh a lot of fun if you happen to be
here in madrid you should definitely
consider going and checking out the fan
zone
don't go anywhere when we come back it's
more from that man and many others
playing here in the palacio de antonia
it's round seven of the 2022 feed eight
candidates we'll be back in just a few
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
i figure it's time for me to really
blend in you know dress like a local
i don't
i obviously wear jackets all the time
okay
so
we're ready for the candidates every
local madridian visits the chessboard
on a daily basis i hear they visit and
kind of
pay tribute
to queen isabella herself this is
i hear that uh
this is
this is a statue of queen isabella
herself
yeah we are here at the 2022 candidates
tournament in madrid spain and we have
our man on the inside danny wrench who's
been with the players a lot going to the
players meetings and he's here to tell
us about some special requests that a
few of the players made danny what have
they been talking about yeah well
obviously we want to and always ask the
players and get them in the spirit of
the city right the uh the place that
they're playing from so a couple of
actually kind of unique ones that have
been that have been thrown out there and
i'm going to try to represent these as
well as i can to fit a okay but the
first one was
a lot of bonus requests if you play and
win with the spanish on either side make
sense right makes sense um
there was a uh
a suggestion you know that anytime you
move the queen you you drop a dab for
queen isabella yeah yeah she's the one
that made the queen power makes sense
okay um but then the players were
unanimous on one in particular which was
that every two hours into every round
they'll have now a required siesta well
we'll see if any of these rules are
implemented for the tournament uh
especially if somebody plays the spanish
they got some money coming their way
yeah it doesn't seem likely but uh i
don't even want to know which players
made these requests but i've got a
couple ideas in my mind yeah well you
know and uh if and anything that gets
the players to play something more than
the berlin right the most exciting draw
in the world now that we have some money
on the line perhaps we see some exciting
some exciting spanish games so i'm i'm
actually excited about that one there
you go you need some alex honold on us
yes
the alex honold of chess folks climbing
without a rope oh wait i can do it
i don't know why i'm doing this but i
feel like a little kid when i get around
big things slowly checking our insurance
like chess parkour
oh did you catch that on camera
can you tell he's a dad of a teenager
always move like a knight guys i think
i'm gonna go hit a siesta over there
with the uh seems like the thing to do
with the locals you do you baby girl
yeah yeah okay i'll see you guys in a
couple hours
yeah
it's a long day dan you deserve it buddy
you deserve it
go ahead and throw that down and
just
buckle up buddy yeah
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chess or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
[Music]
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess the
world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess yet still
chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
miss amigos
i'm here with my amigo
robert hess
in studio
we're uh in in studio here in madrid
we're live in madrid and we're having a
good time the chess is delivering it's
great city
oh the candidates are scrolling i hope
it's not too grueling sitting next to me
here no it's been a great time
stop it
all right well someone who we we don't
want to ever stop what they're doing at
the board is young christoph duda
what a beast
he is what a future he has
uh and uh on the note of me kind of
giving that giving that shout out to uh
what went down
a uh a few years ago probably probably
the first time young christopher really
arrived on the scene in some ways with
this incredible match he had and we want
to show a quick uh
quick clip and highlight of young chris
up zoo does
speed chess championship victory from
2018.
christophe duda wins the final three
games to take the bench
um
i think we can hear you both now uh
alexander and young kristoff are you
there
yeah
well uh
thank you both for what is
literally the most exciting match we've
ever had just absolutely incredible
um
looks like young christophe getting a
hug is that mom there
yes yes it's my mom hi mom
hi hi mom
um
well sasha we know you're
you're devastated right now look at the
look at the clean unshaven danny wrench
and robert has there
and the uh the camera quality was so
great and our template looked really
good that way you know that was a long
time ago but how awesome was that jkd
had obviously sasha grisham was not
super happy but that was an incredible
comeback by young christopher and hi mom
yeah but you could see even before that
he was like go away go away that was the
best part about it is he was shoeing mom
like don't you do what you're about to
do mom
that's so funny all right well um
okay ecaro doesn't think the current
position's too funny he's thinking real
hard there's several moves have been
made on the other boards as well by the
way it looks like ollie russell fuja has
made multiple moves to to kind of show
us what he was deep and think about um
we have uh fabi went for the most
challenging aggressive approach i
actually kind of want to go
right back to that first because i feel
like it's
other than the report and upon rishi
game it's the game that might be getting
the most clarity uh let's just go and
show what fabi went for as we said it
was a critical decision
after castle's long to call the bluff
and take the pawn and as we said bobby
does maybe more than enemies i'm not
scared i'll be accurate as all giddy up
i'll be accurate as f that's as fobby
bobby is accurate af he certainly is he
grabs the pawn he puts the rook on d5
and
the extra pawn right now it's a double
pawn it's not going anywhere but there's
also a huge element of king safety the
king on g1
is hanging out by itself no enemy pieces
near it or attacking it the king on c8
is okay for the moment but we can see
pieces coming a rook to c1 a queen to b3
all that kind of stuff and that king on
c1 just feels a little bit less safe now
let's be honest quite a bit less safe
than the king on g1
okay morbid job i'm still up 17 minutes
on the clock but most of that time
advantage was earned early on in this
game if you happen to just be tuning in
rajabov surprised bobby with his choice
as black but fabi
bobby parried the threats i'm just going
to play through it quickly because we
can it was an a6 sicilian that first set
bobby into
a almost 10 minute think and then bobby
took another
16 minutes here after facing this
shocking d5 pawn sacrifice
but in the end
no matter what you prepared to surprise
your opponent you still have to have a
good position and bobby
probably likes his position feels like
this is an okay line for him and uh
and we're all caught up
yeah he's of a pawn so he should be
happy about the position he has right
now but there's the opposite color
bishops that's something that we
shouldn't forget about because
opposite-colored bishop endings tend to
have draj tendencies but we're very far
from an ending right and actually the
presence of opposite-colored bishops
when you're attacking is very useful
right you want to have the opposite
colored bishops as the attacker because
they can't parry your threats and the
light squares with a dark square bishop
i mean you can immediately see a
scenario where something like
okay you mentioned queen b3 queen f3 i'm
thinking about positions where the
moment this queen is spying anything on
a light square over here you just start
thinking about tactics right not i'm
just showing you the obstacle bishop
features of the position not to say that
there's an immediate sacrifice coming
but if this bishop finds this diagonal
for example somehow some way right or if
the queen and bishop start finding the
same squares to meet up and gang up on
over here the dark square bishop is a is
a bystander and that entire affair
and can never switch colors right
bishops can't trade sides um
all right well fabi's going to think
about this one before making a decision
we're going to back up and
probably
i don't want to only focus on the two
tournament leaders but they're also the
two games most likely to give us
decisive results at this point right and
yonder pandashi again just
really showing
poise
preparation
he's performing all the p's
brought all the piece here ready to
perform he's got prep
um and uh
report is
is in a tough spot i'm
still not totally counting him out okay
because
john is doing a great job he just threw
his pawn up the board he wants to
distract the bishop from the f4 square
yeah so if you take on h4 knight comes
into f4 and if you think that you know
your rook is just going down to d8 to
attack the black king and pin the bishop
in comes the black queen
to h3 and threading checkmate on g2
threatening the pawn on f3 threatening
the bishop on h4
everything is a problem for white there
so h4
can't be met by that necessarily that
means you have to find a square on this
diagonal
somewhere over there there's only one
way to go yeah all the way
bishop b8 probably has to be played by
a report and the reason why i'm still
giving reports some decent chances in
this game is the knockout
isn't quite there you know like normally
when you see such a big advantage you
see okay i can force some trades that
lead me to a huge advantage the problem
is the presence of the two rooks for the
queen
well what trades really are that good
that's the exact material imbalance
white has two rooks black has a queen
not even a pawn in addition to the queen
so if you make move like knight f4 here
we're just talking about that move
now maybe white can just take it
and we see a position where after white
plays c5 for example that bishop on f8
looks kind of useless white's pawns look
very nice and there is where's the
checkmating attack i really like what
you're highlighting by the way as we see
in the live position richard does play
bishop v8
just because
we said the eval bar is not going to
tell the story of how tricky this
position is and
the longer the game goes
the better richard's going to be feeling
right assuming time pressure doesn't
become a bad thing this is one of those
games robert i can envision where like
the final position is the eval is still
saying
black is plus one and a half or two but
it's just a draw right because you can't
make progress against the rooks and so
there's even a world where if everything
came off including everything on the
queen side and all the miners and all it
was was two rooks versus a queen and
three pawns the eval is going to
continue to say black's better in a
position like that everyone but it's
just going to be a draw because as if
black if black doesn't use the other
pieces with the queen
then the queen can't usually take down
the rooks by herself without some other
sort of major factor in the position and
i'm kind of i'm kind of hearing you on
this i think that
the more i look at it black is better
undeniably so the white king is in
danger and when you add reports time
pressure to it is eight moves to make in
20 minutes you're worried
but i i feel like the longer this game
goes
the better richard's going to be feeling
about his chances
and there just are many
opportunities as i said earlier for
black to go not wrong instead of losing
the game yeah but for example if you
said
okay from if you're playing this place
from the black side you can trade off
your a and c pawns for the three
white pawns on the queen side yeah but
it'll cost you some minor piece trades
sounds pretty good you win a pawn and
that way there's no pass pawn on the
queen side but if all the minor pieces
come off will the queen even with an
extra pawn on the king side be able to
defeat the two rooks often times the
answer is no right so black will be
better in most of the resulting
positions but you have to figure out
what trades you actually want to see and
we just show that knight f4 bishop to x4
is not really the one that you'd want
because the bishop on f8 doesn't get
into the game so you're just trying to
figure out
what pawns can i swap what i like this
threat you put out white maybe is coming
in with c5 at some point and you know
you don't want to give up the a pawn so
what if you just guard it
and you still see five c5
i don't think that how else are you
guarding the a pawn i don't quite see
what
again it's not like white's winning here
so we should overreact right and
and it is it is
still a position where objectively if
black sits tight probably white doesn't
have anything here you know because how
do you make progress when your own king
is also potentially in so much danger
but i also but i don't see how black is
improving without risking things either
and i doubt that jan is sitting at the
board thinking oh i'm minus three better
i think both players
they know that
black has the advantage yeah
but they're not
positive how big the advantage is if
rapport thought that black had a huge
advantage he would have gone into this
to begin with he's the one decided to
play on yeah and for yon he knew
probably what the starting evaluation
was
but things have changed right it's out
of preparation you no longer have any
idea what the computer is saying so
again both players agree we agree
everyone should agree that black has the
advantage but it's not clear just like
rajabov against rapport he didn't know
that he had a winning position to play
bishop h2 he doesn't have the evil bar
right so i it's still a very complex
situation
shout out to miss amigos who just
subscribed
unlike someone you know you know you did
something funny accidentally uh we love
that the community has loved miss amigos
because uh when someone goes out of
their way to make a twitch username
about the show
anyway all right well
black is
probably going to take the right
approach which is
so we we've talked about the material
imbalance that is the queen versus the
two rooks and then just giving general
advice on type of mindset you should
have when the points of the board are
equal like two rooks apparently equal 10
points according to the chess gods the
queen equals nine so the points are
roughly equal but what they want is
different often what really matters in
those positions robert is that you don't
try to get too greedy on one or two
points of material you constantly fight
for the initiative and coordination
right those are the things that you
really want so probably the best thing
for black to do is to look to be
aggressive in some way
i'm not saying g5 is a good move but
even h3
is a move
on my mind and i wonder if there's other
things i would do to kind of say if you
get this pawn
maybe i'm i'm never going to let you
recover because i have knight f4 if you
take it
that hits the rook good point right so
so the more i look at the position i
feel like
i doubt we'll see yawn make a move like
this what we'll see is an aggressive
move of some kind oh
knight g5 here we see knight g5
and
already we see the evaluation okay it's
still obviously in black's favor but
it's shrinking
right
interesting the knight is pinned to the
rook
yeah and so what if you bring this rook
up from e1 to e3 because f3 is also
under attack right so you protect your
rook
and you protect the pawn knight takes f3
i guess is a move here
that i didn't initially consider
but no it's apparently oh my gosh
because white has knight
d6 this is
and just takes f3 oh you take with tempo
yeah okay then you just regained yeah
yeah yeah okay wow
report about to respond very quickly to
the palm rishi's knight g5 and he
doesn't look like he's reaching forward
rook e to e3
what does he play
facebook d to e3 interesting he's saying
you can take this pawn
but if knight takes you're going to play
rook f1 and you win
but
the computer loves the idea of getting
these pieces off the board you
highlighted that probably the nitrate
favored black earlier in a very
different position robert
and
likely that's still the case
because with those minor pieces coming
off the board i want to put the queen
anywhere and and go back to my ideas of
h3
and make it very hard for you to defend
the king queen f2 i mean white can
hardly move because your rook on e3
needs to cover the f3 square your rook
on e1 needs to cover the f1 square
so
this does not look very pleasant how do
you deal with h3 coming
i mean there's one way to deal with it
right you can check me that's mate
another way to deal with it
allows the check and that push i assume
i'm just gonna push
this actually
this actually looks like
not a good transition for report who
lifts his eyebrows and takes a look at
yawn
well he may not be making a smooth
transition but we do those all around
here in our coverage we're going to make
a transition to reports interview that
he gave to dina belen kaya
after his round six game right before
the rest day
richard seems like tradition to avoid
castling is quite popular in your games
recently
yeah i'm not there yet to understand
this tricky move of castles
until when did you know the theory today
not long enough apparently i got into
trouble i felt okay maybe i didn't get
into trouble i don't know but things got
very complicated and
it was a long tactical sequence which i
thought i calculated well but just when
the position simplified enough to be
not really dangerous i started i mean i
just missed
made a huge blunder
another one and then i should have just
i could have just resigned and i got
very lucky there that
he allowed me to make a drawing have you
ever been a second of some players i've
helped if it could be called help my
friend lauren frassini like a decade ago
or something so that was the one
and only time
well i richard congratulations once
again on your recovery and
see you soon
fun
fun interview there i like reports
answers yeah i love the part about he
hasn't learned that tricky castling
thing yeah he doesn't learn the thing
called castling it's such a tricky move
you can move two pieces at once what
well he castle in this game and his king
got in trouble yeah
he should stop castling
if he remains in trouble and yonda
pandashi ultimately does convert on this
game robert it will be the best halfway
score
maybe we've ever had at the candidates
i'm getting a stat here at least since
both carlson
and aronian in 2013 and caruana and 2018
both had five of seven so five and a
half out of seven that is a score right
there and it's crazy because if favi
somehow wins that game which is way less
of an advantage than john has here
that would be the same score he had in
the candidates he ultimately went on to
win right so it would be
very high scoring affair from both those
two guys yeah it would be one of those
situations where you're doing extremely
well and you're like what more do i have
to do
but it's just because jan napomishi is
playing out of his mind and
he's thinking right now this is a really
big moment for yon because knight takes
e4 we're looking at it seems to be quite
forcing and at least in this position
compared to earlier ones we see a clear
breakthrough that the queen infiltrates
onto the second rank the white king is
running out of squares so as compared to
even a few moves ago
the clarity of the position clearly
favors john the palm machine
fiddling his pawn there
thinking through his decision
we'll uh we'll let him continue to do
that back up and take a look at the
other games starting to get some lift
off i kind of want to go back to dingley
and ferrugia because we we waited so
long to get action ali reza has given us
some finally now we've got some moves we
want to go see uh what his plans are
uh
jkd went for the plan as you said right
we've got an advantage for white to push
over there
but um
but it's also very deadlocked so all
right we're going to head over to
dingley running ali reza parusia
and try to get you all caught up because
what happened was queen a7 was chosen
after rook c1
so a very long think but not not rook
fe-8 not bishop g6 not even queen a6
which i think we looked at quickly to
hit c4 but he goes right away for the
battery
with queen a7 and i think he just wanted
what he was calculating before queen a7
was knight e4 takes bishop on c5 that's
what he was trying to assess so he
wasn't trying to find some kind of crazy
tactic he was really working hard to see
if
white's next move is knight e4 which
hits the queen on a5
and then you take on c5 does that leave
dingley wren with an advantage or with a
position that already just didn't feel
comfortable with so he plays queen a7 to
keep the material as is but then
dingley rank quickly plays b3 we see the
swap upon something we talked about a
long time ago and then dingle run still
goes after that bishop rook fb8 knight
a4
the theme of the position is if white
can get the bishop pair is there a
long-term advantage
and the reason we always say that just
to give some basic context sometimes
take it for granted that it's much
harder in chess to keep positions closed
than it is for them to become open right
eventually trades happen
it just it's hard to keep a position
closed if you have the knights and the
bishop's
ability to dominate a a complete color
complex when your opponent lacks the
ability to challenge it is usually a
weapon the earlier a top player a strong
player has it the more they can utilize
it so this that's why this theme of
whether aldi reza was going to allow 94.
he did he didn't he backed up the queen
but now he's in a spot where
he's still faced with the idea of that
dark square bishop exiting the board he
decides to try to get all the bishops
off the board which is often a defensive
task if you don't want your opponent to
have two bishops you trade the other
bishops
bishop c3 getting them off the board
and now to e5 really forcing the issue
here robert alirez is saying you better
take my bishop now because if you don't
i'm saving that guy i'm keeping him on
the diagonal which is why you played d6
um
your thoughts good response by ali raza
now
pretty sure dingler is going to take the
bishop on c5
because otherwise his position just
looks very awkward and after the
recapture here this is now the question
because the c4 pawn is under attack in
fact you can't take on d5 because your
bishop on c3 is loose so
where does that leave us do we have to
move my bishop to d4 or something like
that i could play knight to e3 that
looks kind of awkward but also really
good if my knight can continue
i don't want to put it there because
you're going to sack the experience but
there's bishop there's like that
intermezzo i think oh so nice
you know how afraid i was sometimes you
suggest moves and you can see the
hesitation in my mouth and i'm like am i
doing that right yeah i was also nervous
at first and then i realized i didn't
see that that's a very important very
important little in-between move okay
very nice
uh
okay so dingley wren
says all right
i have some things to think about i have
a time advantage to do so 22 minutes to
be exact
i anticipate he'll take as well but
maybe it's a simple
thing if you take and then what if i
unpin
the pawn
yeah okay
so that is so that if i need to i can
take your next and your knight can go to
e3 anyway so you
back the
lady up to e7 makes sense right and
here comes knight e3 black is very solid
here right you can your pawn d5 maybe a
bit of a target you take on c4 and the
resulting position is one where white
has an extra pawn from the e through the
h file right on the king side and then
black love an extra pawn on the queen
side and we've you know talked about how
good a bishop can be in open space but
the knight on f6 does a great job of
blocking the bishop's diagonal they're
also important squares of black controls
the e4 square the entire a file so i
think we can see the promise in black's
position even though white is the only
one with the bishop
these are the types of positions dingley
wren is looking at his head and saying
that's why i'm not moving yet i'm not
i'm not sure i'm thrilled about the
direction of that position
even if i'm not clearly worse i don't
really know what i'm doing next so he's
thinking hard about
how to deal with d5 but i don't think he
has anything better than to take the
bishop maybe go back to your line i
guess bishop d4
perhaps is helping black to clarify the
one awkward piece right let's keep this
tempo idea in mind okay on that note he
does take c5 as expected in fact i like
your move more and more robert because
now that i know i have bishop to d4
playing 93 first means i have this move
maybe next and also keeping the tension
here with maybe a threat to take the
pawn at some point right
yeah and one of the you know big things
is
black is probably going to take on c4
eventually
and you know white gets an isolated pawn
but the bishop on c3 is a good piece
even if it's not a dominant piece it's a
very good piece and that's what's
keeping i would say the balance because
i say pawns we don't really like them
for the most part but it's not that big
of a deal here by the way
look at you
predicting moves
and alireza he has
31 minutes and 45 seconds remaining and
he has 20 moves to make
so
that's
not that much time one and a half
minutes per move
yeah that's again that's that was the
worry right it was looks like he found a
great plan
and we were never really in doubt that
he would the position was pretty unclear
and and feels like one that he can
navigate
kind of in his style too
but not having a lot of time
now for the remaining moves is is what
you're worried about he plays d takes c4
okay
do you mean ben will will take back
likely with the pawn it doesn't doesn't
seem good to give the d5 square to black
by taking with the knight yeah right
knight takes probably quickly met with
something like this maybe even queen d5
checked the trade queens in fact
yeah um because the queens come off the
board then e2 is hanging
for sure right so
black is not worse at all there so i
think if dingler has any hopes to play
for a win in this game he takes on c4
with the pawn and that knight on d7
that's like the one piece that isn't
very active and it's not that easy to
see where it belongs so that's the good
news for white even if the knight e3 is
a little awkward in front of the pawn
it's
defended
and tactically speaking black can never
afford to sacrifice the exchange there
so yeah dingle red has a little bit to
play for
man
dingley red has a little bit to play for
here
time to give you a shout out to a couple
of ladies who have a lot to play for our
next women's speeches championship will
go down
on tuesday valentina gonina who we saw
here in madrid shout out shout out to
valentina i don't know if she's still
here
versus elizabeth potts it's tuesday june
28th it's our next women's speech chess
championship at 5am pacific time tune in
watch the clash it's awesome fun a
little bit faster pace than what we're
seeing there with dingley red you've
really taken his time in the corner and
uh
see you on tuesday 4c versus 13c
all right backing out looking at the
other games going hikaru ultimately
chooses to put that bishop on a4 by the
way yan found the right line against
report and i think we might have
a record-setting pace being set here by
yon napomnishi in madrid this is
unfortunately that was the other side of
the storyline you were worried about is
that maybe richard
should have done the thing we were
plotting
not to do ah right what a wild decision
this will ultimately be seen in
hindsight there's no way this decision
isn't just a huge
talking point
right yeah i think the person who might
talk about the most is fabiano caruana
because even if bobby wins the game
yeah
yeah which which is not a clear thing
against for java no of course not but i
think as the person trailing the closest
person to janna pahmache in the
standings you're like come on to the
rest of the tournament i need a little
bit of help if i'm gonna be winning my
games somebody's gonna have to slow him
down you can't just you know let him
score five and a half out of ten seven
and a half points out of seven heading
into the back half is love is the likely
score for yonda bam rishi who just
challenged for a world championship
title uh just a few months ago in dubai
and uh
wow we went we're gonna be really
circling the the eventual battle that is
fabiano caruana getting white versus
yonder palmership because he might have
no other choice but to be all in for the
win in that game in the back half and uh
that's okay because that's what the
people are here to party for you can see
right now
the standings coming into this round
already had a saying the phrase two
horse race without any disrespect meant
and of course there are still chances
for anyone to catch fire
but
if both those play if yonda palmer she
gets a win
wow
and fabi then he then he's like oh man i
have to win to keep pace and that starts
to get into your head a little bit
so we got a lot you see a visibly
a noticeably visible
concerned richard report now and um as
he probably should be
i want to go back to the game we haven't
looked at in a little while young
christophe duda and hikaru nakamura
a uh positional struggle very different
than the one we're seeing on the other
board uh not a lot has changed i don't
even know that we even need to back up
too much robert we can probably just
talk about the position as it stands we
saw hikaru get the e file as we were
applauding the accurate move order means
that white still hasn't been able to do
what you want put that pony here put it
here and all of a sudden you're talking
big advantage but hikaru just accurately
putting pressure on all the right points
you can't use that square without d4 at
least being in question
now he's poking the rook to leave the
first rank that's why the eval bar is
close to equal despite all these
potential positional problems yeah and
the rook can safely leave the first rank
because just you know rookie one check
up the reviews does nothing right
there's no shell there's no checkmate we
often fear that allowing a rook down
there is scary but
well i think the king might be better on
h2 just to avoid the diagonal but either
way the point is that this rook trade
actually really helps white because the
d4 pawn is no longer under attack but
this one is which means the d5 one is
and the knight can reroute via d3 and
things like that so this would not be a
good look for
uh hikaru so rook to d2
is available and i think what a car
wants to do is just keep
the threat is strong in the execution so
keeping the rooks in the e-file without
necessarily doing much of anything
is what's keeping hikaru
in the position in the balance right
okay so if rookie choose played and not
rookie one let's analyze this what else
is hikara going to go for maybe queen
i would say d8 first but i don't know if
i really like windy queen c6
defends and offers a queen trade
right and that way
you protect d5 all at once so it does
seem like the car is doing a great job a
queen c6 oh yeah i do not want the
knight to go to d3 without
conceding something
so
yeah it just feels like a position where
car he still
is
holding on and he's doing a great job
young krista plays rook d2 so we're
lightly predicting the lines and
the one advantage for white is this is
probably a tough position to lose the
threat on in the sense that i think
white will continue to be playing for
two results
but maybe i'm wrong maybe there's ways
to to overpress and
let the rooks get a little crazy
no you're right okay you just
hit carl if he defends accurately he
makes the draw
and so far he's defending very
accurately yep
okay
comes back to the board looks like he's
about to actually move kind of quickly
knowing that
icaru perch that that i also know well
like faviano and indeed he likes
robert's line look at you you're all
over it queen to c6 off of the queen
trade
if the trade happens would you would you
consider taking with the pawn actually
yeah because the bishop is defending in
a way that is kind of hard to remove
and now all of a sudden you don't have
to worry about d5 ever again no you have
a new problem to worry about but
but that one's covered at least yeah
interesting
so that's an advantage in this in the
change of structure yes this pawn is
weak and of course if white gets all the
moves the knight on e5 and the rook's on
the c file maybe but
but
how accurately black's pieces are placed
just make optimal coordination almost
impossible for white here it carries an
amazing job keeping the knight out of e5
yeah
and the knight f4 is good don't get us
wrong but it's more powerful on e5 where
it puts pressure on the c6 square so
by keeping the d4 pawn under threat
hikar was just making sure that
you know his remaining pawns and pieces
are
nicely placed
indeed
judah's gonna stop think about it for a
little bit we're gonna stop drop and
roll back this thing up again take a
look at all four games decide where we
want to
take this next part of the beautiful
program here
what we've got going is
some winning chances for fabiano over
there against for java but shout out to
raja for finding a way to give up that
pawn but coordinating opposite code
bishop position that right now he seems
to be holding that's interesting
um
yonder pomnishi again just
the guy is a is a wrecking ball uh if he
wins this game it would actually be his
first victory against richard report in
more than 10 games in any format
um so he hasn't beaten richard in quite
a while
but
looking more and more
like he will
yeah no that position now seems quite
clear with that queen on f2 is in the
top left-hand side of the screen and we
have richard on camera but the queen is
infiltrated the bishop's joining the
party the a7 pawn
up there can't even be captured which is
very sad news for
uh richard it's like these only chances
to get some queen side pawns
rolling up the board
and look at the clock by the way yup
if those times reversed maybe richard
would have a chance but yan says an hour
yeah let's show actually why the uh
a7 pawn can't be captured
because i believe the move you respond
with bishop g5 because the brick is
pinned to the okay exactly without
seeing it i was guessing in my head what
it was yeah there you go
and
so that's so if you can't even take the
pawn which is your only chance to get
some sort of
some sort of traction here
nine minutes left for richard for five
moves
which normally i would say that's not
the worst time pressure we've seen in
this event and it's not but given the
position he's facing and how critical
those five moves are
we are just again about to see yonder
pommashi be the first one done
as he has been a couple times
and also getting another victory in
madrid
and i'm just trying to think of
something richer can do to drum up any
sort of counter play right if you could
push your pawn in one turn from e4 to e6
maybe we can open up the rooks and have
some chance of getting after the black
king but it's all just too slow
and bishop g5 is clearly what jan wants
to play next and your rook has to leave
the third rank and then i have queen f3
check and the a3 pawns hanging the h3
pawn's in trouble everything is under
fire
yeah this looks
it's looking almost impossible
um
and johanna palmer she's he's strolling
around
he's looking like a guy who knows he's
about to go to five and a half out of
seven
yeah as he should be i mean
i'm just i'm just sitting here just
blown away right now and again
report is uh
is
getting the a for effort in this event
so far he has six draws but all six of
those games entertain the fans and this
one
even with it maybe not being the kind of
entertainment he's into it is
entertainment for all of us just seeing
the drama unfold
but
you just you saw the decision made in
that critical moment instead of going
for the draw
and hikara just went there and just
shook his head immediately yeah he shook
his head he's just like oh man this is
this is falling apart
the wheels are coming off yonder
palmishi
going to get his second victory as black
in this event
and i said coming in robert that the
or i said when that moment happened that
you have to play well to win chess
tournaments but sometimes certain things
have to go your way that are outside of
your control that can mean your opponent
played a line you were really well well
prepared for so they got unlucky right
other other competitors in the event are
just not on form right so you end up
running up against some people who at
the right time you catch them right and
sometimes it's the decisions your
opponents make and again like report
gets credit like he should be invited to
every tournament in the world as robert
said because the guy brings it every
time
but if you're in yonda palm rishi's camp
you are just absolutely thrilled out of
your mind
about what you're seeing
on the board right now um
and the decision that richard made to
give yawn these chances yeah and richard
is a well-liked player but i think
everybody in this field not named ghanda
palm street might hate him right now
yeah
and they're like right like dude just
take the draw help us out but that's the
thing about this he doesn't need to do
anybody any favors he did yonder policy
a favor by playing on but he also felt
like if he makes his draw he won't have
a chance to catch up because he would be
a point and a half behind yan then he
would also have fabiano depending on how
he does so richard thought that if i'm
going to have any chance at first place
i have to
play on in this game i have to you know
try
and it's a mistake like was it that or
do you think he
just
didn't realize how tough the position
was with the queen versus the rooks
i think
i'm not even saying it with you i know i
know
and we talked about this earlier right
like you have to calculate not just
trust your opponent but when it's yon
napomshi who played the petrov against
magnus carlsen
you kind of have to trust his
preparation a little bit a bit yeah yeah
and i think part of the problem for
richard is you know he doesn't know
theory to the extent that the other
players do he said he's worked with
laurent frescine one time ten years ago
or whatever but he doesn't have like
this deep repertoire that other players
have when hikarus showed against dingley
ren right and if you don't have deep
preparation you're probably not sure
what the
best lines are and he clearly didn't
know that black and immediate draw on
this variation and then he's like okay i
don't want to make a quick draw and
that that's where you get a little
subjective right yeah i don't want
something versus this is what the
position calls for right
yup yup yup yup well um
not anything else to talk about in this
round other than the biggest news of the
day jan obama she keeps winning and
apparently he just you know wanted to
prove me right i predicted something
wild might happen but i thought it would
be very different
than the story line
uh that we had here
so um
outside of a miracle i think we're going
to see yonder palmerishi continue his
record-setting pace literally no one has
had a five and a half out of seven score
uh moving into the back half of the
candidates tournament maybe ever we'll
check on that step but certainly not in
the the last decade or so
um in the events that we've been kind of
referring back to magnus carlsen going
on to win in 2013. fabiano car uh
karyakin of course didn't have that
score in 2016. nor did it nor did
fabiano and caruana also only had five
of seven only
five of seven in 2018 so
uh wow
um jana pandashi had a full point less
when he won
the delayed 2020 2021 candidates he had
four and a half because he lost game
seven to maxine vashey the grav so
what a spot he will be in and uh
we will have a lot ahead of us to follow
all right
where you want to where you want to head
now there's several games to look at i
think that the fabiano game is probably
the most interesting one as far as
changes go
also also dingley run perugia
yeah i think fabiano game is really
interesting with what's happening on the
d file over here yeah uh where
i think
the java is playing well like he did
give away his e5 pawn that was a choice
and he is worse here but if he can swap
off these queens yeah right get to the
end game opposite-colored bishops only
one pawn deficit it is an isolated pawn
that doesn't mean immediately that's
just going to be a draw not all opposite
code bishop's position are drawn and i
think there's one big problem for black
it's that f7 pawn yeah whereas
right now the knight on d4 is attacking
this bishop on b3 but in the event of
some trades the pawn f7 always needs to
have an eye kept on it because
it's hanging now losing that pawn also
isn't the end of the world that's the
idea i was going to say that's the other
pro right is that if you're going to
lose any pawn
you still have work to do if you're
white even if you have two pawns there
right so that just goes to show what
kind of chances team over java has in
this game
uh and actually finally needs to come up
with a move
right
now
because the position is just
odd and knight takes b3 seems to be in
the air if you move the bishop anywhere
random there's queen takes b2
potentially
uh and they're you know if the b2 pawn
falls now watch out for queen takes c3
stuff right in 92 checks all of a sudden
there's
real tactical consequences to the b2
pawn falling if you're fabiano
but if you trade queens like let's just
throw out an idea where if you bring the
queens off the board like you were
saying the problem is that without the
dynamic of black's king getting in
trouble which we would assume is not
going to be the dynamic once the queens
are traded
it's really hard to
to say you have a big advantage even
even if even if you could take and take
there on f7 it's still
not a position that is easy to win at
all yeah actually right here b5 for
black forces looks like rook takes d8
and we get this exact position where
knight takes a five at the end there's
only one extra pawn black is really
active a rook coming down to d2 this
looks this way another good lesson where
yes objectively computer says white is
better but this is a draw like if
anything i would almost prefer black
like it's crazy right but i mean
seriously yeah white would probably have
to play rook d1 and and in fact that's
probably what the computer wants because
the computer is thinking material but
this just shows you more and more why
that that's not to be trusted this is
just
black starts playing any natural moves
and these opposite code bishops are an
easy draw despite one extra pawn so
unfortunately for fabiano he especially
knowing what's happening in the other
board
with the person he is chasing about to
say hey bobby remember that bus i'm
driving time for you to get back with
the rest of the kids i don't need
someone in shotgun anymore sitting next
to me i'm going to i'm going to take the
wheel from here
and that's what fabian is looking for
and it's only moved
19 that was black's last move so 20
moves
for 23 minutes that's not a lot of good
spot for carwana what a turn of events
this has been here with the the the idea
that we were kind of like what castle's
long
rajaba took
27 minutes
on move 13 right here
to play castles long 27 minutes
goes for this forcing line but is now
getting credit for that not only did he
maybe make the right practical decision
but maybe he went deeply down that
rabbit hole with that time and just saw
like hey like i'm okay here right i'm
down a pawn but this obstacle bishop
position is going to be okay and if that
was the case
rajab
stealing fabi's thunder yeah i know
really nicely done by timor at this
point and
i think five is just trying to find a
way how do i keep pieces on the board
yep not taking some tremendous risk but
is there a way that i can maybe trade a
pair of minor pieces or or whatnot but
not trade the queens and the rooks and
just allow black to get into easy draw
territory
which is hard i mean you want to do it
objectively right not subjectively we
talked about that with richard right you
want to keep
winning chances alive if your car want
to objectively sell
and uh
i'm really trying to figure out how yeah
i don't know how you do it i mean i want
to play this like
i want to play this move but it's
probably losing no actually that's a
nice looking move
can i do it yeah do it because don't
yell at me computer no it's not going to
yell at you because black might think oh
i'm going knight takes b3 yeah just get
rid of your bishop but here there's
knight takes f6 oh
nice
removing the defender of the rook if you
take on d5 i take back with the knight
with tempo before gobbling up a piece
i love it i love it i love it
and fabiano
no the queen c4
going for the end game i am
i'm shocked
about that decision actually just
because of the position he's in that he
has to try to keep some chances on the
board so
maybe he sees something about that end
game we don't but we need to back this
thing up because we also see that across
the room
richard report has only one minute for
three moves we're gonna head over there
because
we might be about to see
a game that goes down in history as one
of the many
notches that uh
that jan earned
on his way to winning another candidate
i'm coughing on the truth i mean uh this
is just terrible a3 is hanging
behind the bishop is the pawn h3
bishop c3 disconnects the rooks from
each other
that's a huge threat you settle on oh
giving h3 with check it just can't it
can't be good no it can be good
yawn is uh doing yawn things
nepo
he's also just
it's like he put on a little bit of like
uh nepo serious face not so many
grimaces or a motor he's just like like
hey if you're gonna give me these
opportunities like let's go
i'm not gonna apologize i'm going to
take what i want
with check then i'll take another thing
i want
with tempo
i took some of those wellness that
wasn't a good call you did yeah i told
you yeah i know you told me so i had to
test it no i need water but my water is
kind of far away
so well go ahead and grab it
yeah the uh
yeah we gotta stop okay we're gonna
we're gonna go back to almonds as far as
the nuts that are hanging around besides
these two nuts sitting on chairs here
crazy crazy crazy guys i'm choking up my
water this time didn't know where you're
going with that one
they were just a couple of nuts
it didn't sound like
the rubber just looking into my water
i'm supposed to help me not you're not
supposed to hurt me
we have to change the protein snacks
that the crew is giving us
bananas and almonds you know that you
know when someone's like don't do
something you're like no i have to get
oh it tastes bad it's bad for me i had
to try it
oh man i'm
i'm i'm doing everything i can to keep
this show professional right now you are
welcome fije you are welcome world
because
i got a couple of these jokes that i
could take
okay
supposed to stop choking you're really
making this difficult
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna go
to the bird's eye view and back up are
you killing me for just a second more
water now
you just made that joke
you were like oh robert you got to be
all professional
all right all right
all right queen g3 check has been played
yawn is uh
last time i'm just saying yawn is going
nuts in this event right now he is
winning every game it's crazy
and uh
richard report regretting his decision
to go for the imbalance of versus queen
and again it's just
uh i don't i
saved there's no more criticism media
because again i want to applaud the
effort i want to applaud the idea and
the spirit of what he was trying to do
but
it's also just
it
it felt irresponsible to the to the
situation he was faced with he knows he
doesn't have the best openings he knew
he ran into one in in yonder palmer
she's prep in this petrol there's no way
and and objectively you have to you have
to believe in yon's prep and believe in
the eval and be like all right there's a
reason he spent 40 minutes trying to
figure it out
and you just feel like all those things
being said i know he wanted to win it's
not his job to worry about anything but
himself getting a w but it feels like
we're
a little bit too subjective there and
because now now you're really out of it
now you're losing right you're not
drawing and
it's just tough as someone who has made
more decisions um
without thinking things through than a
lot of people in life including
decisions i make on camera regularly uh
jokes but i get it but it's just oh man
super heartbreaking uh for richard
report here and
yeah no i i think our immediate reaction
in live in the moment was there's no way
he's gonna play on yeah there's no way
he's gonna do it
and then he's thinking he's thinking
thinking and then he does it
and
i think john made it look easy maybe it
shouldn't have been this
simple
right yeah but jan just
you know
made sure his king was safe pushed his
h-pawn up the board was able to trade
those knights
on e4 opening up the queen that was a
super accurate well-played plan there
that knight g5 plan and now let's head
over to that board i mean
it's this this knight to g5 idea
getting pieces off the board and robert
foreshadowed it super well when this
night was all the way over on a6 where
he said the way you want to approach the
technique of these positions is figure
out what traits help you what traits
hurt you how do you improve on the
material imbalance you possess versus
the imbalance that your opponent
possesses and you asked a good question
about whether the knights should be
traded and the answer was yes you should
so report uh well report didn't avoid it
right away with this and objectively
maybe black could have been taken right
away by the way but he still stayed on
this plan eventually coming around to
the king side forcing the ponies off the
board and that has just made black's
life super easy because of how important
that night was to the defense of white's
camp with that piece gone
the wheels are coming off
and uh
and now yawn is just he's in cleanup
mode he's in cleanup mode he's
dominating the 2022 feed a candidates
and there really isn't anything else to
say about it
yep the wrong rook went to e3 that's the
eastern that was the decisive mistake um
report
and i wonder if at that point you just
thought that he was lost
no matter what but if he thought he was
lost no matter what then he probably
shouldn't have played on
earlier right it's all going to come
back to that
right you know we could say that this
move was inaccurate this move was
actually a blunder but his decision to
play on when all of a sudden done
objectively was not sound yeah and we
took as you said the subjective approach
like for the tournament for his his
place in the standings trying to take
down the leader
but yeah it was wrong and i wonder if he
would do it again and i feel like the
answer might not be no
that's why he should be invited to every
journal in the world because there are
also times where
you make huge decisions like that they
pay off it just it feels
like it was it was just
wrong here and
unfortunately for the rest of the field
not just wrong for richard reports
chances but might be putting yawn in
such a spot that is impossible
impossible to catch up with so of course
there's still a lot of chess to be
played
and every single one of the players in
the field robert will get another chance
at the tournament leader right and so
you have that going for you if you're
trying to stop this thing from getting
out of hand
but
when you're playing well and you're
yonder palm rishi look out look how well
he's playing the prep he has you know
what i mean you might have your chance
but it's like yeah come and get me big
fellas right come and get me because the
try the harder you try the more you give
someone like yon napandashi when they're
on form winning chances right and now he
doesn't even have to create fighting
chess he just he just plays his game use
his prep and as people take unnecessary
risks i.e richard report before us
yonda palmicide just does his thing
and what jan needs right now besides the
next few moves to conclude this game is
he really needs rijaba to not lose to
carl fabiano because if fabiano is
trailing that closely is a half point
behind then you can't just take this
approach like you're saying just like oh
let me just be solid let me just force
you to beat me yeah and this move by the
way super strong by john
the idea everyone is that you're you're
putting the bishop on the diagonal that
holds f2 so that when you give a check
with the queen you can't block with the
rook
or you can but you'll lose it and the
whole reason for that is if you check
with the queen and you block with the
bishop
i spy with my little eye a little check
made on g2 yeah so checkmate in one
isn't your flavor and h pawn promoting
to a second queen that could that's also
pretty when there's maiden one look for
better yeah made one look for better
also prevents bishop h2 which was part
of report's idea because after queen
check now you can't you can't block
anyway you came up with the rook because
it's mate and if you move the king you
win the rook here so this we are moments
away from richard report
uh simply resigning probably he has
reached time control so there wasn't any
up and right as i said it the hands are
extended
a quick nod yawn is holding back
positive emotions
i know that
he says
he said bishop g5 is is the other way to
avoid the draw
yeah
or maybe someone with the knight g5
moment but
yeah but richard clearly didn't know the
line but no he's literally telling him
that that idea with the king g2 bishop
g5 is the right way to avoid the draw
not the knight d2 line that's what he
just said he was saying not 19 i i could
read lips lost my hearing when i was
younger long story um but
not not professionally but i could make
that out he was saying bishop g5 is the
right idea
and we'll just show that position real
quick because it is now one of the most
critical moments of the 2022 feed of
candidates which was right here
in this spot he's saying instead of
the commitment going would avoid the
draw at some point is to play the 92
idea that report did which was bad or
this move here and this is the right way
to do it after queen
well either way after bishop or queen
takes it's it's
it's crazy
but it is closer to equal than the line
that report played in the game but again
rapport doesn't know the theory and he
did his best in the situation
um ultimately was unable to figure it
out now you can meet this with like this
move and the point is white's pieces
kind of come out so yeah though you know
i think the queen come back to d7 report
probably thought i'm giving away a piece
and still gonna lose my queen so i don't
have enough material for it so yep
that's bishop g5 really hard move to
play
that is what happened all right well
that's
because it is the major story of the day
a shocking one at that yonder pomona she
wins with black again
in the first half of this event
round one he did so round seven
rinse and repeat
good shampoo avoid dandruff
and uh
head-to-head
in the in the first seven rounds went
his way let's take a quick look at what
his
next set of games will be the
head-to-head coming up for yon rounds
8-14
robert i mean we're going to get to
these other games but there's nothing
more important to talk about than this
right now circle for me the trap games
for yon the games that you think could
go the other way if this field is to
slow that man down
well he's definitely not getting black
against rapport because he just did that
so we'll fix the yes the graphic and
make sure that's accurate but we have
the white piece against dingley wren and
then black and caron that is a tough
slate of games because he does get the
first move advantage against dingley ren
but ding can play with both colors right
he doesn't have to just sit and do
nothing and then the question is what's
yon napomnishi's
mindset like is he going into the game
against stingley renzing i can just play
with white make a quick draw be happy or
is he going to play like a real game yep
yep
yeah yeah we'll definitely switch that
it'll be it's white versus report uh and
we will uh make sure we update that but
i think again yeah i think the car won a
game right there uh gets black against
farouja right ali reza a very very very
challenging opponent there yeah if
purusha is on form there in the second
half so
and start things off uh he gets white
against dingley wren so he's in a great
spot that's the reality yawn is in a
great great spot so
all right as we back up we see that uh
no longer in that spot in that chair is
yonder ponership because he got the job
done the game is over richard report out
as well
we're gonna take a very very quick break
and uh when we return we have three more
games still being played in round seven
of the 2022 feeder candidates can that
man keep pace with yonderpandashi don't
go anywhere because we're going to find
out
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more
try it for yourself at chess.com events
the fee day candidates is the most
important tournament in chess
taking place every two years the
candidates qualifies the victor to
challenge the reigning world champion in
a world chess championship title match
the 2022 candidates will feature eight
of the world's best chess players
they've all earned their spots through
two years of fierce competition they now
head to madrid spain where everything
will be settled over the board
one of those eight spots is always
reserved for the previous world chess
championship challenger jan napomnishi
would love nothing more than a second
chance at the throne but he has to get
through seven other great players in
madrid first
two spots went to the top finishers of
the most prestigious open chess
tournament in the world the feed hs.com
grand swiss ali reza faruja won the
grand swiss turned the heads of everyone
in doing so and has become the youngest
player in history to cross the 2800 evo
rating barrier he would become the
youngest world chess champion of all
time should he win the candidates and
ultimately the world chess championship
match
fabiano caruana joined him taking the
other spot from the grand swiss the u.s
number one and third highest rated
player in the history of our game is
also the only person to never lose a
classical chess game to magnus carlsen
in a world chess championship match
two of the spots were claimed by the
winners of the dramatic 2022 fide grand
priest cycle
grand master hikaru nakamura is a former
world number two
a blitz and bullet chess legend and the
most popular chess streamer in the world
he was joined by gm richard report the
hungarian number one is one of the most
creative and dangerous minds in the game
today and nobody is looking forward to
facing him in madrid
fide awarded one of the eight spots to
the wild card invite grand master taymor
rajaba
raja missed the 2021 candidate cycle in
consideration of covet concerns but as
the oldest most experienced player in
the field he's looking to use that
knowledge and punch his ticket to the
world chess championship title match
[Music]
and finally
two spots go to the top two finishers of
the world's largest knockout tournament
the absolutely grueling feed a world cup
young christophe duda the polish number
one punched his ticket by ousting none
other than world champion magnus carlson
in the semi-finals of that event
judo would ultimately defeat karjakin in
the final to win the world cup
however karjakin due to suspension from
play by fidei sees his spot go to
china's number one grandmaster dingley
rent
dingly rent takes the spot due to being
the highest rated eligible player
according to the may 2022 v-day rating
list
[Music]
so that's how each of our eight
competitors earned their bids to madrid
inside the palace of santona it's about
who can sustain the mental endurance to
secure the coveted slot as challenger
for the world title
but we're not sure who that will be just
yet we do know this
we'll enjoy watching every minute of the
candidates with the chess.com community
as we see how the most important
tournament in chess
together
and we are back in studio maybe
surprising the world that we're joined
by the man who just racked up
you have more victories than the rest of
the field so far john how are you
feeling right now about about the way
you're playing in madrid
i mean
despite the score i think it's like very
very much up and down because okay i had
some uh
really poor positions like against
fabian and against
icarus games i was losing but uh
i mean especially it was more or less
obvious in the game against hikaru but i
mean okay i just mixed up everything and
game against five he played just so
brilliantly but he didn't come up with
some computer line in the end so i
went for a repetition but i mean so far
and it's a good but
yeah
so so far so good you have five and a
half out of seven
which is a a full point more than you
had heading into the back half of the
candidates and the in the odd broken up
candidates that was the 2020 2021.
how do you
how do you maintain your your focus at
this point you maintain yourself in the
same rhythm knowing that you're you're
in a
in a potentially commanding position
well i
don't think anyone needs to maintain
focus on uh during the candidates yeah
it's like it's very challenging
tournament anyway
so i'm just
doing what i normally do yeah i just
prepare
play have some rest and then repeat yeah
and that's like repeat that's quite
[Music]
sometimes it's quite boring yeah but
sometimes this pays off like for example
uh yesterday i uh yeah
paid some attention to the line which
occurred today so it was like
quite lucky but for me but
i mean
how speaking of the line you prepared
today and and you you called it kind of
quite lucky how
how surprised were you
when
richard decided to go
against the repetition and play for
knight to d2 well this was
i would say it was smallest obvious
because he spent so much time right and
i think uh
maybe maybe because he had 66 draws
already so he wanted like to
uh to fight and uh to catch up you know
to beat the leader because also you know
optically this position is
uh is nothing but
the is nothing but clear that black is
better because okay uh for me it was
like more obvious because i knew black
is better
if white
decides not to repeat
uh but
you know okay i have this poor knight on
e6 he has like two rooks so it looks
like he quickly comes like rook d1 but
in fact i think after he gave away free
pawn it was already uh
it was never pleasant for him
and uh i'm not sure if okay i played
well uh but i think yeah i managed to
trick him into this end game with yeah
queen and bishop against turks and
bishop but i think it was pretty much
over so maybe he could
uh you know defensively you said you
knew the position well and
i'm not trying to pry where i'm not
supposed to go as far as prep goes but
obviously you just came off of a world
championship match in dubai and had a
lot of prep for that do you mind sharing
at what point
in this game were you on your own versus
the type of positions you were looking
at for that well i believe bishop f4 i
believe
something maybe something like king g2
computer says like you should like
protect this pawn at least but i'm not
sure and then i just bring my knight to
e6 and this is like rf5 right because i
mean in general yeah it's obvious if he
comes interrupt uh
you know me
retaining the queen it's it's quite uh
it's quite easy to play for me yeah like
okay just
push everything uh forward and now here
i believe i mean once again if you know
like you should like uh save if uh
fight for you know to save half a point
we might probably play differently but
after i think rookie d1 i mean it was a
logical but in fact
i guess this position is already not so
not so simple yeah i mean yeah so
pieces are stuck and
well i'm not sure maybe here a5 was the
cleanest one yeah like after a385 to
play it positionally but
somehow i felt like uh okay this h5
queen five and then and stuff yeah you
know it's time to play for tricks yeah
you like that okay
yeah uh i mean you like that here no not
to say you generally no in general
everyone likes to pleasure play for
trixian especially when it's like the
kingdom so exposed yeah
yeah so well it was
i think it was really hard for you to do
something here
well um at this point i i don't know
much more to say about the game other
than like you said it became
straightforward and and we were here
just sort of uh applauding the
performance
let me ask you i don't mean this to be
in like a uh
a trap question but at this point do you
do you feel like it's your tournament to
lose
i don't know i'm not thinking about the
overall results so i have you know one
game per day and that's that's what i do
i mean i was like uh
i don't know i can't say in the into the
same shoes like two years ago in
yakitori i mean i also had like plus
three after six rounds and then i lost
the game yeah uh but uh i mean to
compare
uh i mean it was like two different
tournaments uh different lineups and so
on and pretty much different games from
uh and pretty much different play also
but uh i believe everything can happen
so it's
i'm just
doing my stuff yeah
i i know the the answer to this is
simple that your expectations coming in
you play every tournament to win the
tournament right but from from where no
well let me yeah what were your
expectations coming in are you surprised
by how for example like uh the previous
tournament was in in romania and uh i
mean okay if it would
i would be very glad if it would go
better but in general like i had like my
task to you know to feel how it goes to
train a little bit so
uh i guess uh this is slightly
okay this approach can sometimes
backfire but in general uh yeah i mean
here it goes without saying yeah so you
hear you have only one place which
qualifies but
otherwise sometimes you just you know if
you can play it you know to enjoy some
chess or to train it's also quite good
yeah
are you enjoying the city madrid yeah a
lot yeah but uh
yeah somehow i already spent quite some
time at spain and also managed to do
barcelona
yeah
there's some some
some just some just tourism yeah
virtually
the uh so
last thing i want to ask just because
it's been a storyline first time we
haven't had a player in studio for the
whole event so i'm so i'm so excited to
have you here is
all the discussions surrounding magnus's
comments about whether he would play the
world championship match i know that
probably doesn't matter to you at all
right now but what are your thoughts on
on uh
if he didn't play the world championship
match and you were faced off in a match
versus uh the second place finisher here
would that
would that make you unhappy would you
want it do you want another crack at
magnus i'm just going to ask the
question you want another crack at the
end
i will think like after the tournament
ends and you know it depends strong
strongly depends on the result yeah uh
but
i mean
i i really don't think it's uh it's the
thing i should care you know right now
right here right it's totally fair
totally fair mid event for sure well
it's quite the event that you're having
right now john um and the uh everyone i
i speaking for everyone here it's just
been impressive it's been it's been
awesome and uh we wish you the best of
luck as you continue to uh to drive
forward and so i won't ask what you're
to do with all this extra time you have
given that you were the first game done
but i hope you enjoy your saturday and
uh get ready for tomorrow yeah okay
i have a lot of things to prepare i
guess yeah yeah we've got work to do so
we're going to let them get out of here
and get back to the three games still
going this was yonda palmershe
all right well
that was the man of the day
the man of the
hour and uh
maybe the man of the tournament at the
end when it's all said and done
yonda pomneshi
is now sitting at five and a half out of
seven points
it a uh a blistering performance being
put on here
through the first seven games in madrid
and uh
and wow i felt like i wanted to ask a
few more questions about the specific
prep of the world championship but then
i started getting the feeling respecting
the fact that there's a lot of chess
ahead respecting that um you know the uh
the answers to some of those questions
may indeed reveal themselves on the
board here at some point and ultimately
just very appreciative of yonda
palmershe's time and i hope you enjoyed
the interview too robert yeah and you
couldn't catch him you know you were
like asking him how he felt if he did
win the event yeah i just need to finish
this event out yeah no he said that he
made a specific mention of round seven
last time around yeah so he doesn't
forget that he can be beaten yeah he
looks unstoppable right now with five
and a half points out of seven games but
he knows that anybody in this field can
take him down so he's not looking too
far ahead yeah
no super smart obviously the right the
mindset of a uh a person who knows
there's a lot of chess ahead right
that's how we should be it's like you
notice when you when you're when you see
interviews with great athletes and other
sporting events you know
in the middle of a season right when
they're asked about a great victory and
how unstoppable they feel a lot of the
answers are similar like it's one game
at a time where you know we're focused
on playing together executing the game
plan right when an athlete's in a zone
right you can just tell that they've got
a mindset they know the job isn't done
and they're not going to slip and start
thinking about you know the prize before
the prize is in hand right so he didn't
answer my question about whether he
wants another crack at magnus right now
he needs to win the tournament but i
would bet that that he does want another
crack at the king and uh there's one
person who might still have a chance to
stop him from it being a foregone
conclusion that yonda pomnesi is going
to win the candidates here in madrid and
fabiana caruana has this work cut out
for him here against tamworth java so
let's dive right back into that game
yeah fabiano has been nursing an extra
pawn for quite a while now and we talked
about the opposite colored bishops but
pieces are still on the board one of the
variations we looked at earlier was
where the queens came off and the rooks
were off the board we said okay we know
that this game is going to be a draw but
now all four rooks remain
and that makes black's defensive task
much more difficult
and and for fabiano he has a rook in the
open file he can bring his a1 rook over
to d1 to line him up and his control
over the d5 square
is going to be a huge nuisance for a
java to deal with going forward
i'm surprised we got this position let's
bring up the analysis when we can
because i thought the line we looked at
was super forcing
after queen c4 i'm trying to figure out
what happened so the queens were traded
and the line we were looking at was b5
as a means to force
another trade
and and this was the end game we were
predicting remember we're like i was
like hey i'd rather be black here or
like even down upon right i mean this is
so simple so instead where jabba
trades queens and then chooses to play
the move rook to c8 instead
i wonder if there was something about b5
that would maybe maybe i was being too
careless to assume this is the move like
maybe the move is actually just
backing up the bishop actually that
makes sense and now you're worried about
your pawns right now you've made some
weaknesses a4 could pry things open on
the diagonal yeah so okay okay let's see
you fabi
rook c8 bishop here robert but now but
now i'm feeling much better again at
fabiano about fabiano's chances to keep
this thing going
no this is exactly what you want for
fabiano you have an extra pawn
you can press this advantage for a long
time and there's no easy out for black
right there's no sequence where we see
the rooks just come off or the knights
get traded there's a lot for a java to
figure out and they're only at move 24.
so both players
have quite
a handful to do here there's a lot of
work left because you need to get to
move 40 to get more time and there's
currently a struggle with how should
black continue to withstand the pressure
that fabi is trying to build up on yeah
and even though the queens are off and i
i kind of alluded to the fact earlier
that
with the
with the ladies gone the chances of a of
an attack a checkmate attack on the on
the light scores are way less but the
truth is
now that we've seen the bishop
reposition itself
and this rook coming to d1 don't count
out the fact that black is dealing with
some real pressure over there on the
queen side with the rook and bishop
lined up on that diagonal the fact that
this knight
not only has ideas of maybe jumping into
that party
on b7 but there's also other squares
that the knight can join so
this is
this is there's definitely a fight here
ahead
obviously yonder pon rishi going to be
going to be hoping that tamora jabba
holds this one just makes makes his job
easier of course as he said he's focused
on his chess
but uh everyone else thinking well if
this is going to remain a two-horse race
then fabiano's got to pull this one out
yeah and one more thing in initially
what you mentioned the d5 square and the
knight hopping around there's a
possibility that bishop on e4 takes the
knight on c6
so what has draws tendencies are
opposite-colored bishops yep but if this
you know rook a1 d1 and rook to d7 these
kind of ideas happen at some moment
black really has to look out for bishop
take c6 because that's not really a
trade that black would want like if you
make a move and i
maybe i come in here
be a little careful
but if i come in here
there's threats of taking and then
knight to d5 yeah but there's also
threats of taking here exactly because
if you take with the rook the seventh
rank is mine and if you take with the
pawn it's even better right or in some
ways the knight versus bishop is the
dynamic you you would much prefer over
obstacle bishops
yeah this this has
gone back
we're swinging back now to the fact that
i'm i'm more confident that white has a
lot to play for here i actually don't
see an easy plan for black this is
looking
really problematic for rajabov and
i understand that he was worried about
the b5 a6 pawn configuration but this is
clearly less pleasant
right like maybe the other position had
some holes and i'm not going to dismiss
that but this is just a clearly fabiano
can play with zero risk
and
right now i'm sure javascript can i take
on c3 and then will that hurt white's
queen side pawn structure but then we'll
never have opposite color bishops
because only one of us has a bishop so
i'm
i mean really liking the look of this
position for fabiano i'm sure he's very
very happy to be wearing let's look at
that so taking obviously gives the
imbalance of the bishop versus knight
the other way meaning black is
volunteering and it does put a weakness
on c3
but i guess the big problem is that this
this dominance of the d file is so
concrete right and it's coming so fast
that you don't have time to move this
knight and go for anything aggressive if
you're black and black has to play f6
before white does because white if you
give white a free move f6 is about to
win the h pawn and that that that's
going to be enough you split the board
and the bishop has things to attack on
both sides that is exactly where it will
flex its muscles over a piece like the
knight
and
so if you play f6 well now
i think and then once black plays rook
c7 we have bishop takes c6 here really
important move and
maybe black can hold this but i don't
think so you're down a clear pawn yeah
and what white can do
is trade a pair of rooks bring the king
up to f2
play g4 h4 so i throw in the pawns up
the board and this four on three despite
the double pawns now that's a real extra
point advantage because you can just
throw your pawns forward wow so it turns
out maybe maybe fabiano's queen c4 they
kind of
had a surprise because of the line we
were assuming is ultimately okay given
that that forcing line we looked at with
b5 had more chances to if you didn't
trade than we realized so caruana's
showing that there was more that meets
the eye he knows he still has a ton of
work ahead and now knowing that
his friend richard report was not able
to be be an amigo right he's saying miss
amigos my friends
someone someone else has to stop
yandapamnishi right um but uh right now
no nobody can
though favi wins and we have we have two
people at five and a half and five
wow i guess we know what we're talking
about for the rest of the event
whatever game those two guys are getting
into we already were talking about that
coming into this round like oh does
anyone else have a chance but they're
both winning and nobody else is then
that just leaves us with yon and fabi
down the stretch well we're not there
yet so let's back up and again remind
you where we stand yes you are seeing
correctly if you just tuned in where
have you been
yonda pomneshi wins again with black
but there are two other games going on
and it's not a two horse race yet
decisive
victories for any of the other players
in the field could change that storyline
but uh
we've had let's see we've had the most
changes in dingley run for ruja
so i feel like we should head over there
even though i know it's
looking more like a draw because i don't
see how that b-pawn can advance
quickly right you've got you've got an
outside pass b-pawn if you're perugia
which in theory is better than white's
four on three but the pawn is
sufficiently blockaded by dingley wren's
night and brook
and uh
hard to see this getting too spicy from
here yeah it's one of these situations
where is that pawn a strength as an
outside pass pawn yeah or is it a
weakness because it's an isolated pawn
so if this king on g2
can quickly run king f3 king e3 you know
wherever to get to c5 you can team up
against that pawn so
i even if you lose the pawn that's the
problem for
uh white in if you ever hope to have
winning chances let's say the knights
get traded about and white wins the pawn
the four on three on the king side is
still a theoretical draw that ali reza
fruga knows very well although in theory
if the other trade happens the rooks
come off the board with the pawn that's
actually a good lesson for for for
viewers that
the end games often refer to as closest
to king and pawn endings are night
endings because if you have an extra
pawn even with no other advantages on
this side of the board there actually
are some real winning chances there even
in a night end game very different than
a rook ending so so perugia i don't you
know expect that to be the case i expect
this one to end peacefully but if that
time pressure somehow played tricks
with his head he does have seven moves
to make in 11 minutes you have to be
very careful not to get a knight versus
knight four on three end game but but
okay um
f6 was the last move we we highlighted
dingley ren's idea of getting the king
and faruja has similar plans
up his sleeve um
and okay let's let's back let's back up
again and and head on over to the other
game we haven't touched on in a while
that of course is
young chris of dude's battle with hikaru
nakamura whoa
this one is this one is different
different than we left it and different
in terms of one side having chances i
think duda is
well wait but the d-pawn's also hanging
wait yeah but he's willing to give that
pawn to infiltrate with his rook
well actually this is a really
interesting idea so rook takes d4 okay
if we can get this on there we'll
analyze it rook takes d4 yeah rook e7
so i'm actually giving up a pawn
temporarily
and once you play your bishop move then
i can take on b7 bishop c6 i think i
think you need to protect the pawn like
this and then i take here so after
bishop takes b7 i i don't want to do
something else right
keep the bishop on the board
yeah that's actually kind of annoying
and then if i go knight d8 you can still
take on uh wait you can't take on c5
right because you're rookie 7 at the end
with a pin
so you'd have to move the bishop to a
random square
but then i could take on a7 ah
and i can't take c5 even with d4 this is
going to be a wild position oh yeah your
point is actually but maybe this move is
better
but i forgot with the d5 pawn actually
being a usable piece right it's been
stuck in place for the weakest thing on
the board on any board it's like an
isolated pawn that you
wanted to forget about
but
in the game we see knight to d8 played
and car was about to move right there
but that's not yet
yes d4 pawn that's been the key
that's been unfortunately for duda but
great play by hikaru that d4 pawn has
been targeted like all game and that's
the reason why dude has been unable to
increase his advantage yeah
he finally did get probably debating
between taking the pawn or maybe playing
a move like king of f8 because
it's you're going to lose a pawn no
matter what right you're trading b for
for for d here but if you play king of
eight you're stopping the rook from
coming in right so is that the idea
maybe are you more worried about rookie
7 than you are about losing the b7 pawn
i'm not sure i think both king of fate
and brook takes c4 are possible right
yeah and
the question becomes can we trade off
the minor pieces from a car's
perspective and then just liquidate into
a position where the pawns are getting
traded for one another the rooks will
just start gobbling upon and if that's
the case then hikara will definitely go
for that there way there's no risk
whatsoever
hey carl looking like he was about to
play king of faith they're looking over
here at the camera what's up buddy
we see you
your car is thinking about what he's
gonna do next and uh
we're gonna we're gonna catch up next
here with his interview that he gave to
dina bell and kaya after round six
before the rest day he caught up
downstairs before he exited the palacio
de santonia we'll see what he had to say
thanks for joining uh we were
speculating today uh
has that been your biggest preparation
ever
no i mean i've had some other games um
which have been worse uh there's one in
particular i had this game against david
howell actually in the london chess
classic um
i know it was 2012 and basically he
played the first i had prepared the
first maybe 40 moves unfortunately he um
he managed to find all the best 40 moves
as well in the game ended in a draw so
that was actually a little bit worse
than today but um i mean joking aside i
think ding i mean he found all the best
moves bush takes b5 isn't it probably
isn't the best way to
to simplify but
the way he found like the c5 i mean all
these moves i mean this is the main line
of what i had looked at so i was just
very impressive by by ding over the
board to figure it all out
so there was no moment where you could
have played little bit better
i mean maybe after knight g5 i mean i'm
sure after knight g5 there's probably
some some work in pawn end game i can
get somehow where i'm up a pawn but it
should be a technical draw i mean i
think i saw one with bishop g5 queen g5
maybe queen d4 queen c1 and queen c4 and
i think i can get maybe four pawns
versus three on the king side but it is
a draw if ding plays plays accurately so
um that's why i didn't do that i mean
also of course i saw yon was was doing
great and probably winning so i figured
i would just kind of play this whole
rook g3 thing after thinking forever and
i wasn't really sure if it was okay or
not okay but i figured who cares i mean
if it doesn't work it doesn't work and
um and yeah i just unfortunately ding
found rook d5 and and i had to go for
this bishop g7
um if he had played something else i
think maybe i would have had some
chances to win but hey played a good
game
rook a3 was your preparation but still
didn't you have some flashback from
yesterday's rook lift
um no not at all i mean i actually
wasn't thinking about that
during the game i mean i was basically
trying i was basically hoping that ding
would make a blunder and he kept playing
every best move i mean he played bishop
five rooked the eight c five all these
moves and of course this is unknown so
for him to find all these moves was just
uh disappointing so i was waiting for
that that uh move which i hadn't looked
at and he kept finding the best moves
but that's life
perhaps one more question for today when
you play online you
always explain your moves your ideas
when you play here at the candidates do
you still have that kind of a
voice inside of your head explaining the
most not really i mean i think the one
thing i would say is there are certain
times like yesterday's game against yon
where there's this one position where i
can play either rookie through or knight
h4 but those are the only two moves in
my mind i was kind of thinking about
what are the possibilities and sort of
talking to myself about what the two
moves were but in general i mean i think
you just you just try to play and i
don't really think about such things
during the game for the most part
all right thanks a lot sure
that was a great interview
i'm gonna go deena i'm gonna go hit
carter that was awesome yeah it was
about as thorough as hikaru's
preparation against both dingley ren and
david howell yeah
the uh
the preparation was thorough and dingley
wren's defense was amazing
i like the question about whether hikaru
has his own voice in his own head while
he's talking through variations in his
games
um and uh because we all know that voice
as he talks through variations on stream
to thousands take six six six eight take
six six six and then and then take six
and then
[Laughter]
the hikaru pop wait i got an idea
um
he's got his jacket on we know we've
seen him do that a few times robert and
it kind of means he thinks the game is a
draw i don't know if that's the case
today maybe maybe they lowered the air
conditioning it is getting a little hot
in here by the way maybe they lowered
the ac downstairs who knows but
no i think he believes after bishop c6
that should be a draw should be a
drawing we were talking about this right
before we played that interview that in
many of these positions what black is
about to be able to do is probably trade
minor pieces and then just trade some of
the queenside pawns and hold the balance
so i mean great play by hikar if you
scroll through this game quickly yeah
you would think that was nothing it was
just a draw but he actually was in some
trouble yeah because the knight was just
clearly better than the bishop and at
the highest levels of chess that can
make all the difference right or just a
nagging advantage that continues to
pester your opponent until they feel
like i need to do something really
active
change the nature of the game and car
didn't do that he just played good move
after good move and was able now to get
in a position where he should be able to
make a draw without too much more effort
yep
yeah let's bring up the analysis board
and uh
scroll through that because it is super
instructive because
just to just to show that we were
looking at a position like this
after young krista had induced the move
f5
because of the threat of checkmate right
so you induce this move f5 but that's
such a huge commitment to your structure
weakening the pawns weakening the dark
square in front of it and robert did a
really good job at the time of saying
that bishop b3 has a concrete threat
depending on on what happens in the
position make some random move
the the piece is getting traded on this
square
changing the structure opening up the
weakness of e5
potentially goes for a position where we
pointed out just how bad the position is
for black when the material is equal and
the computer thinks that white is
basically up two and a half points just
so look at the structure here and look
at the computer's eval right look how
dominant this position is for white not
just our chest positional the way we
like to teach thing even the computer
agrees mathematically this is basically
loss for black and then look at what
happened in the game and see if you can
notice the difference he played queen b6
we end up getting that structure but but
everything was super accurate this move
is accurate enough to just make make it
not so easy for black to be able to deal
with the e file then instead of taking
here and helping white you play rook e8
which brings the rook to e4 very quickly
and so in this position again it's the
same structure robert that's what's
fascinating to me about this right
literally the same position we just had
the computer saying you're up a piece
but because of the unique accurate
defensive aggressive move cecaro played
white is never able to get access to the
weaknesses or even the pawns without
consequences right so again i think what
you're saying is really true just super
interesting to see how precise hikaru
was in his defense as we catch up to the
live game that will probably be a draw
yeah from
duda's perspective he was a bit
imprecise and that allowed hikar to get
the activity but right now this is
actually an extremely interesting moment
because hikaru can play the move rook d4
to a4 because judy did not just take the
pawn a7 and by putting the rook there
you're protecting your a7 pawn while
attacking a3 black's already up a pawn
and judo won't even take a pawn after
rookie four he's gonna bring his king up
to f3 he's waiting for hikaru to take
his pawn his king is gonna walk up the
dark squares and despite in that initial
position being two pawns down
white is definitely no worse and black
may still have a few things to figure
out
yeah carlo is
he put on his jacket but you can see
he's taking pause and appreciating the
dangers in this
position up there it is got an idea
pop pop up um
but i really like that in fact let's go
right back to the analysis board and
show that because that that is that's
instructive if this happens
and you and you carelessly take this
pawn again carelessly how many people
watching would just take this pawn right
it just it's with check everyone in chat
just raised their hand everyone chat if
they were honest just raise their hand
unless they're playing armchair engine
chess engine quarterback
here comes king f4
and all of a sudden
you try to like go after another pawn
and okay well now i can take it because
i've already solved my problem of
getting out but any any other careless
moves here like let's say a5 or
something right you try to come up here
comes the king and this is one of those
positions where you see the dangers of
your king being on the back rank despite
being down upon in a rook ending
white is winning yeah so i love that
that was a really instructive idea you
showed of dude's plan to put the king on
f3 and i expect that after rook a4 which
is now on the board dude we'll play king
of three
nope he's taking okay well that was uh
that was fun at least we learned
something chat
because apparently dude why would i i
really thought he was going to three was
was a better try what was what was the
car going to do instead of taking the
pawn
i don't have an exact answer for you i
mean it's still even with best play
maybe you start with a5 that way you
don't want the king in and only after
the rook takes on c6 now you're the
black kid now you can take and then come
up although this still is not that easy
well not so simple yeah white is the
king e5
i think due to
okay it was objectively withdrawn anyway
but i think he i think he could have
taken a page out of robert hess's book
over there i think carter would have
played king after i think akara would
have played king of three i think magnus
would have played king of three i think
maybe duda just decided all right it was
over he's just trading down here c6 is a
literal draw offer and we're about to
see our second game
finish here in round seven at the 2022
feeding candidates
and the car is making that face of how
do i want this draw to occur should i
push my a pawn or should i just take the
c6 pawn right now and immediately trade
the queen side so that's what he's
trying to figure out yeah instead of
just offering a draw at some point how
do we get that repetition going
okay five
a three
he's taking on oh
a through you're right i thought you
could take on c6 you know
he's gonna force duda to push that pawn
yeah
not much to analyze anymore here
we're gonna let them wrap this thing up
and right as we said it
they shake hands
and another game is done here in round
seven
not quite as exciting as the report
napomnishi explosive result with
explosive effects
for the rest of the standings but
igaro is kind of not sure what else
yon kristoff could have done there it's
kind of funny you say that because i
feel like games like the one that these
two just played like the most
interesting because some games where the
report game for example oh you should
have taken the draw or if you were going
to plan you shouldn't this is a very
easy explanation yeah the most part of
how that game could have gone here it's
like
for 12 consecutive moves you can argue
about like these little nuances yeah
yeah and that's a lot of fun as a chess
player to go through but i don't think
young dude is having a lot of fun he
would have preferred to
squeeze a victory out of his advantage
yep
and there we see what remains ahead
we have dingley ren and ali reza perugia
only four minutes for farouja so we'll
probably head over there and just check
where things are at in terms of the move
number only a couple of moves to make
wow but rajab of now is in big time
children
big time trouble and he actually just
made a huge commitment
to take on c3 you know what we're going
to go over there change of plans
carwana rajabov it is because bishop
takes c3 robert i think is telling of
what he's figured out which is you know
what i can't just sit anymore
there is
and there's no there's no passive way
for me to hold this i have to do
something very active right now and if
you look do i move 28 from hijab of and
if you look at the clocks that means he
has 30 seconds per move going forward
and bobby not in much better shape
actually fabi also has 12 moves to make
in only eight and a half minutes so both
of these players are going to be on the
edge of their seat which gets me excited
you know there's only two things in life
i like better than time pressure
i'm not going to neither one of them or
something we're going to talk about i'm
very tempted to
allow you to say no let's avoid that
here we go time pressure it is 120
minutes is what the players have to make
their first 40 moves after that you get
an hour added onto the clock and if you
are still playing at move 60 it's
increment time which means you get 30
seconds per move for the rest of the
game so that time control has led to
some of the exciting moments we have
here in the candidates it's also been
met with some criticism by the players
it's a fun storyline we'll get into it
later right now let's talk about the
chess okay well 500 just played move
rook c1 clearpoint defending this pawn
on c3 and f6 played by
timor jarvan and the evaluation went up
but i'm actually not so concerned with
the evaluation as i am concerned with
the idea f6 prevents white from playing
that move why was ready to sacrifice
upon any moment to shatter black's king
side structure yeah the problem with
playing f6 is king g3 king h4 king h5 at
the right moment maybe that moment is
now and if i'm able to kick your knight
out of e5 with an eventual f4
this would be a losing ending so this is
actually a scenario where i think
fabiano has great chances because he's a
very clear path for his king yep
well
we've got uh
we've got fireworks potentially about to
happen here on the board um
we also being told we have hikaru
nakamura here in studio i'm not sure
what's gonna happen with that or how
we're gonna how we're gonna how we're
gonna transition or handle this but huge
shout out to hikaru for being here um
bobby by the way went for your idea
robert immediately playing king g3 and i
i really like how quickly you pointed
out that
the night while looking pretty on e5
this is not a real outpost square
everyone remember an outpost square is a
square where you can't be kicked by a
pawn so while the knight might look
pretty it's not permanently stable there
and the moment white has a reason to do
it white will kick that knight and this
is a moment where the double pawns are
good because if you put that f3 pawn on
say e3 then the knight has a stable
outpost and you're never getting the g6
yeah so fabiano's plan is clear rajabov
is move 30. he's now down five minutes
18 seconds he's really in some huge time
trouble because fabiano's path king age
four king h5 how is your java going to
survive this game with that plan being
so obvious
yeah and and also with only five minutes
to figure out what he's going to do for
the next 10 moves so
it was an active transition let's
analyze it real quick back up just just
a little bit to what happened with
bishop takes c3
great move by fabian yeah rook 5 to d2
by the way almost i guess in hindsight
that's what i didn't realize when we
came to it that's why i wanted to go is
it was basically
forced
you basically had to take c3
because knight d5
is uh is about to be on the board so now
that i see that i realized it wasn't
just that he chose not to sit he
actually was forced to do so put the
knight on e5 after fabi defense the pawn
where we stand so but it shows you how
tricky this position became
the moment that uh that relocation of
the bishop to this diagonal was on the
board
and yeah all right well we've got
we've got a position where rajab is
in some in some real pressure here
and uh we we have now a real treat in
studio as we are joined
by the one and only hikaru nakamura he
caro thank you for being here yeah no
problem i mean it's uh been an
interesting event i guess you could say
yeah
i want to get your thoughts about what
happened in this round i would love to
get your thoughts on how did you react
to what was happening on on the board
between report and and napalm machine
yeah well i mean i think the thing is
fortunately my game was very dry from
the start so it wasn't like there was a
moment where i could suddenly change
something based on what was happening um
in the other game but
i mean when i when i saw this position i
mean obviously white can take a
repetition and make a draw and with the
time control the way it is with no
increment i mean the more richard
thought and finally didn't take the draw
i had a feeling he was going to lose the
game because it seemed like a situation
where he should probably think for maybe
15 20 minutes and then either you just
you go into it or you take the draw but
you make a decision right there and you
leave yourself a bunch of time because
uh in the game it looked like he was
probably okay but he was already long
low on the clock like everybody else is
against nepo and uh just fell apart for
like a better way of putting it
we we could
it's unfortunate this is the first
interview we've been able to have in the
event because there's just been so much
that's happened
so many great games i would love to talk
to you about your victory versus for
java the incredible game versus all the
russia perugia so i'm saying that
because i don't know how to get into all
those topics i'm not sure we'll be able
to but i also would love if you analyze
a little bit of this one with me because
you might be able to help me kind of
close it out sure yeah i mean i think i
think first and foremost what i would
say is this tournament it has some
shades of uh actually the tournament the
fabiano one and st louis now mind you
and st louis fabian was the only player
who was winning games but when when you
have so many strong players it feels
like there are very few opportunities to
win games and all the opportunities seem
to be being nepo's game and i guess to a
lesser extent fabiano's i mean he
obviously got a bit of a gift from ali
rezzo and when oliver went insane
um but there are so few opportunities it
feels like all those opportunities are
happening in one person's games and
there there just aren't really there
isn't much to go around i guess
i was telling that with robert earlier i
was saying that in some ways obviously
you have to play well
to win a tournament like this right
obviously but you also
have to get opportunities right you have
to for lack of a better way to put it
not lucky necessarily but there has to
be a chance to push and how much do you
think a little bit of luck plays into
all who ultimately goes on to win these
tournaments well i mean i think you
create your own luck obviously jan has
been moving very quickly very
confidently throughout the event and so
he's made his own luck i mean but but
yeah there certainly is a factor i think
like today for example in my game uh if
the other yawn had been a little bit
more aggressive the game could have
gotten really interesting but instead he
just traded everything off on d5 and
there's just nothing there at all even
though i think objectively i might have
been a little bit worse if you hadn't
done that so
it's just it's what it is but um you
know it's every tournament is different
i guess the end of the day
you hope you'll get opportunities if you
don't well that's just life really if
your opponents play well i mean i i
thought for example my game against ding
lauren is a perfect example where i had
great preparation i think i caught him
by surprise and then he played every
best move yeah um and i feel like you
know for example you look at like a game
of yawns say someone finds all the best
moves and makes a draw it's a different
situation but they don't find the best
moves and then like in in my case
against ding ding finds all the best
moves i mean it's just sometimes it
seems very random but i mean to be fair
jan has created a lot of his
opportunities because because of how
quickly he's played and how confident
he's been throughout so yeah it's not
too much of a surprise perhaps you could
say
well said you might you might analyze a
little bit of this only because right
when you came in we're kind of in the
time pressure moment where we've got
three minutes
for her job up to make
six moves and actually bobby just
playing f4 this is looking a little bit
tougher by the by the move for black
yeah i mean like
i mean teamwork decides like like this
is another example teamwork decides to
play a very random sicilian
we were super surprised by that yeah no
i mean i think what he did was was okay
objectively but he plays a random
ceiling out of nowhere instead of being
like rock solid like he normally is so
again sometimes if you want to call it
luck or whatever that that plays a role
but still fabiano i mean i thought he
was surprised in the opening but he
responded in a way that seemed very
human and i i don't know where timor
went wrong but it just looked like he
ended up down a pawn and maybe there's
some way with this knight on d4 to
simplify i mean i didn't really look at
it very closely but now it just looks i
mean completely lost any any chance for
black to hold this so if the knight
moves king g6 or take me sorry take me
through what you're seeing here well the
problem is where's the counter play
basically i mean you're you're not
you're not like for example say there
were no a pawns on the board right and
you were able to win the c pawn you
would have passed b pawn right but with
with a and c versus a and b i mean
basically even if you get the c three
upon at some point your whole king side
is collapsing you just lose yeah because
you don't have a passport on the queen
side so
i mean if if teamwork saves this i mean
i i would i'll probably i'll give 200
subs to the chest
because
there's just i i don't see the counter
play basically i mean where is the
counter play the king's going to g6 and
then you can slowly play g3 g4 h4 right
and
i mean maybe even put the bishop on f3
at the right moment put the rook stack
that works on the d file or put them on
d4 and e1 even i just i don't see it i i
really don't see it here um
this also looks bad no because now
there's bishop d5 knight b6 bishop e6
and king g6 and alejale to the to the
up up the king side oh man no i mean
this is just this is just terrible
no i mean this this should just be uh
pretty cleanly winning i i i mean okay
what is that what is the time yeah but
knight f8 um
[Music]
uh g4 rook d7
oh yeah and there's there's some kind of
made on h3 if i go over doing roxy three
at the end of the line yeah yeah maybe i
mean
still though i think i think i'm
translating hikaru right and that you
were quickly calculating you have to be
careful of this yeah because like rookie
four would be winning if there's not a
right there isn't some rick h3 the
request is checking so
that would be that very unfortunate um
but i mean the thing is what what is the
time situation fabiano has six more
moves to make in three minutes for fobby
two minutes for java yeah i mean if fabi
fabian doesn't blunder before time time
control he's going to win this game yeah
because if he gets to move 40 then he's
going to have an hour to think and
calculate all the very long lines and
he'll he'll find something to win the
game so basically if if if fabiano
doesn't plunder the next six moves he's
going to win this game is that ever in
your head at this point i mean are you
still always trying to just play the
most accurate move next or are you
sometimes like okay
just pat just it's like possession in in
like nfl just hold on to the ball to get
to move 40. are you ever thinking like
that here well it's tricky because the
time control there's no increment i mean
as i've said many times every tournament
that i've that i play has increment
except this one so it's a little bit odd
that you don't have increment because
when you're getting those 30 seconds if
you run your clock down to like five
seconds you make the move you get 30
seconds you can think but if you make a
movie and you're down to like five
seconds and you don't have the next plan
you're in big trouble right so
it's kind of yeah it's a situation where
you kind of just like uh have to make
some moves although now it's getting
tricky
just like i said it's getting a little
bit tricky here isn't it yeah fabiano
didn't play your bishop d5 move that
probably was a little more accurate so
now he has to
figure out how to deal with c3 i mean
i mean of course the the eval bar says
white is winning i mean i can i can see
that but
yeah i mean this is this is very
unpleasant suddenly let's see if 227 so
227 minute 29 four moves to make
yeah the problem is like rook d8 if
knight c3 you don't have rook d6 because
your your bishop hangs on e4 you could
go rook three d6 you'd make max move
bishop's hanging okay so he plays
can you hear six okay
where job up takes the pawn no yeah but
see but see now there's going to be
counter play because you're going to get
past pawns on on the on the queen's side
that's great i spoke too soon so no but
that was the idea you were pointing out
that's actually super important and
how does white break through here
because you got to get something on the
seventh rank before g7 can fall yeah i
mean you're gonna have to go what bishop
f3 knight a2 rook d7 or something and
maybe it's still winning but again
it's getting messy
yeah i mean timor is going to get
counter play here he's going to get he's
going to get at least get a hope um
whereas i don't think he should have
gotten any of this counter play so he's
going to at least get a hope
i mean i still again obviously i can see
the bar so i can tell that it's lost but
i mean considering how bad the position
was at least at least you have a glimmer
of some kind of counter play here and
he's going for it knight a2
yeah this is
that means that the chat has a glimmer
of hope that hikaru is going to gift 100
subs so watch out everybody yeah i mean
again i i still think fabiano should win
this i mean rook d7
yeah d7 b4 king g7 knight c3
i mean
i mean it should be winning it should be
winning but yeah it's just somehow
it feels scary
yeah because you could also lose this
now like because if you go like king f6
b3 for example and then you trade rooks
and go rook d2 then i go a5 a4 and just
like that i think i think you might be
lost
um okay i mean computer what says
white's still okay but yeah it gets very
very messy very very messy out of
nowhere so i mean
yeah it looks like one move now to make
with one minute
for both players roughly yeah i mean
this move is very obvious i mean you
just go b4 knight c3 i mean
some combination which one do you play
plays nicely
yeah
yeah i mean and this is also dangerous
because now i mean there's no no
increment in second control so like if
fabiano thinks which i expect him to
think for like 20 or 30 minutes after
king g7 b4 he's still gonna have to use
time on every single move so
yeah i mean you assume he'll find a way
but i i really want i wouldn't like this
position i wouldn't like to be white
here yeah based on based on the
trajectory of the way the game was going
versus where we are now i would not have
uh i would not be happy if i was fabiano
here i would not be happy at all with
this but he's got 30 seconds to find one
more move once he does we'll
we'll probably take a breath and have a
couple more questions with the man
hikaru here but um don't go anywhere
everybody we still have two games in
progress in this round
and uh
king g7 b4 well roger has the time but
he plays it anyway
no no actually he didn't move forward
right yeah but i mean that this is going
to be very
very tricky here you know it's stressful
when both players get it doesn't matter
who it is right they're like all right
let's take a break uh yeah i mean what
the computer says you what you can go
king f6 b4 rook d2 and then just run the
king and go f6 f7 i guess but
yeah i mean this
this probably will happen on b3 and then
i think you go rook d2 and black's just
two slopes a5 king six a four f six a
three f seven mi the f pawn uh e6 okay
oh sorry i i thought you said that i was
just moving yeah i said g6 but i mean it
doesn't matter i mean either way yeah
yeah and you're just too fast here i
guess
it's just one template so fabiano i mean
actually
i assume he'll find this
because it's actually it's not that hard
because black doesn't have many moves
here either i mean if you get to this
position after this is a position right
now right yep so after king f6 b3 rook
d2 a5 is the only move because you're
just going to go i mean you have a clear
plan move the king 1 e6 g6 and just push
the pawn up the board so it's actually
not so hard to calculate because black
doesn't have alternatives so as long as
you can see that you can move the king
um yeah fabiano should win this game
all right well let's back out real quick
because i you you made
you made a comment if i'm quoting it
correctly i heard that you said that you
thought if there was increment roger
might have held that game against you
here we have a game that without
increment obviously had a lot more drama
what are your thoughts on the time
control in general and and obviously the
fact that it doesn't line up with what
you've consistently played but but if it
wasn't for that are you are you
generally okay with it just give me your
thoughts on it i mean the game changes i
mean i'll say this i think i would have
be i think i would have beat nepo if
there was increment i think there was an
increment i probably would have kept the
game going even though i had already
thrown it away to some degree with this
whole knight b3 bishop c3 if i have
seven minutes there and i'm getting 30
seconds every move i probably still play
on quite quite a bit but without the
increment it's a completely different
ball game so that's another game that i
think would have gone differently if the
time control were diff was different um
i i think it's just weird because i
think all of us are so used to playing
with increment whether it's the world
rapid and blitz you know rapid or blitz
or classical chess whatever it is you
know i think about people like chris
chuck without increment i mean that guy
i mean he probably would have lost like
50 points in the last two years or
something he would have lost so many of
his games and those scrambles um but i
mean you adjust to it obviously i think
it's just the main thing is if you get
below a certain uh certain point a
certain amount of time you just have to
go with it yep uh actually i would say
it's very similar to the rcc which i
played on chess.com the the first day
it's 10-0 and then on the second day
it's 10 plus two um and like on the
first day there's a certain amount of
time i would say somewhere around like
two and a half to three minutes where if
it's headed towards an end game you just
have to you just have to go into it you
can't really calculate at that point um
so yeah it's it's difficult getting used
to it and i think in a tournament like
this where everybody's so well prepared
they're going to be a lot of surprise in
the opening so it definitely adds um to
the drama i think for spectators it's
probably better i think for the players
it's much worse yeah so it cuts both
ways is what i would say about the time
control i'm gonna i'm gonna ask the the
overarching question because we were
unfortunately not able to have you after
some of the earlier games just give me
your quick synopsis if you would on how
you feel you played through the first
half of the candidates here in madrid
both your
your form and maybe some of the critical
moments how do you feel that things have
gone i mean i think i've played
excellently i think uh if i look at my
results it's it's about where i should
be maybe i could be on plus one if i had
beaten yan um but i think i've played
well fabiano of course i made this one
very big uh error castle and kingside
when i shuntab in the first round uh
maybe i shouldn't have lost that game at
the same time you could probably argue
that i could have lost ali reza so i
think that's pretty much a wash um i've
played well i'm i can't complain
certainly if there's one thing i would
say i'm a little bit surprised uh
i mean obviously tournament still is a
long way to go but i am a little bit
surprised at perhaps a preparation from
some of the players it doesn't feel like
they necessarily used all this time to
find a lot of great ideas i guess what i
would say i mean i i think richard for
example i'm a little bit surprised by
what he's done throughout this event um
i mean dingle ryan i guess didn't have
much time but ali reza also it doesn't
seem like he i mean has has come up with
a lot of really brilliant opening ideas
the way i would have expected
considering he had like nine months to
prepare for literally prepare for this
tournament and only this tournament so
he hadn't played much yeah so i mean i
would say that's maybe the one surprise
to me um
but overall i'm happy with my play i
mean if if people like yon are just
gonna win every game there's there's not
much that i can do about that i mean you
can only concentrate on your own game so
you know what are your thoughts on that
i mean if you look at moving in the back
half and
you know obviously the storyline is
right now
who's gonna stop yawn can anybody at
this point five and a half out of seven
it's one of the best scorers ever there
so what would be your approach going up
against him and what do you think is
going through all the players minds
right now well first thing first thing i
would say is i i mean i said this on my
stream so to me this is no surprise i i
literally said on my stream multiple
times the odds makers i don't know what
they're talking about
like if there was real money and betting
on chess at this point like we would be
making a lot of money because the odd
major audit makers definitely had this
wrong well i mean i said it multiple
times i thought there were two clear
favorites fabiano and jan because
they're the two players who have played
this tournament and won this tournament
so they have a lot of experience in it
um whereas ding he only played last time
and sure you can say what you want about
covet and and perhaps being stuck in a
bit of a lockdown before the event but
he didn't he didn't perform well last
time so i thought he and ali raza were a
little bit of outsiders perhaps you know
i think uh just drawing on my own
experience from playing in the
candidates uh in 2016 i mean i was very
nervous i slept horribly it was a very
very rough event for me i mean at a
certain point i was on minus two i did
win a couple of games in a row to get
back to even but i was never really in
contention and the pressure just kept
building every day whereas this time i i
don't really feel any pressure at all
i'm just trying to play and play good
chess so it's night and day for me and
having had that experience i think
certainly for someone like ali reza
who's who's never played before uh it's
it's a lot to expect him to suddenly
play play really really well considering
the stakes are so different than any
other event he's played in so for me
it's not a surprise um can someone stop
beyond i mean obviously it's possible
uh fabiano if he wins this game he's
also going to be on plus three so he'll
be half point behind um but yeah i mean
i think
one of those guys what we have to carve
in here because i want to ask one more
question i don't want people to be mad
that we don't have the boards up we're
going to
keep hiccaro here because because he's
he's an awesome interview so that way
people don't get mad about where that's
going i want to ask you about that so
the
what you said about ali raza you know
everyone another storyline everyone was
talking about not just the pressure on
him the comments magnus made but then
the fact that he kind of disappeared
for the last six months and now we've
seen some difficulties for him coming
out of the gate like
what would be your assessment of what's
kind of going on there as foruga seems
to be struggling a little bit with this
form i mean there are there are a couple
of things first thing um is that i i
think actually again drawing on my own
experience from 2016 when you put all
your eggs in one basket and it's all
about this one tournament
there it really does feel like every
single game there's this massive
pressure on you and i think uh alireza
and probably his father and his brother
they perhaps didn't realize just how
much pressure it's going to be and then
secondly um
as well like when we talk about the
pressure i've said this many times on my
stream the candidate generally is a term
where people play the worst objectively
if you look at the quality of the play
the blunders that you see for example
bishop h2 that rajab missed i mean
if this is i'm just going to use a term
and there's nothing against alternatives
turn like norwich has i mean rajab finds
a move he finds a move in five seconds
no issues whatsoever but suddenly in the
candidates he doesn't find it you know i
made this huge blunder uh i mean richard
didn't win that game against ali reza
and so
it's just a it's just a different beast
completely when you play in the
candidates it's just because the
pressure of what's at stake yeah i mean
it's the only tournament where you
finish second and you feel like you've
finished in last place only tournament
that you can do that you can you can
gain 10 points finish in second place i
mean i think like fabiano in 2016 when
he when he finished second after after
um sergey sergey who won the event i
mean he felt terrible but i think he had
a very good event overall it was it was
great but finished second it's just a
huge failure so
yeah i mean i think there's a lot to be
learned for for ali reza um certainly as
well it's it's it's also a different
term because players have a lot more
time to prepare for example if i look at
the grand prix which i played in berlin
i mean i maybe you know did like a
little bit of casual prep the week or
two weeks before the event and that was
all i did yeah but here everybody has
months to prepare so it's much harder to
find surprises and and catch people off
guard and i think i mean that also makes
it a lot different a lot a lot more
challenging in many ways so i'm sure
he'll learn from it um
but it's it's certainly something that i
think you should just kind of try to
play just try to keep some sort of
routine and not not bet everything not
but the whole house on on this one one
event because certainly it hasn't gone
his way great answers hikara you're an
awesome interview i have one more
question i want to ask and then
we'll let you if so if fabiano is to go
on and on i mean i can just stay here
okay well i mean i can see here for
another time um this is awesome to have
you here and it's and it's uh great
great thoughts great content right how
did you know you're you're the biggest
the biggest chess streamer in the world
um
if fabiano does go on to win this game
and the story line becomes with with all
due respect that you kind of have a
two-horse race going right does that
change your approach to how you play
them does it change other players
approaches and what's going through the
other six you guys are you guys are all
you know can i say badasses of what you
do you're all badasses so like but but
now you've got two guys
that are leading are you gonna change
your approach against them um i mean
we'll see i play 500 tomorrow so
probably it's better if i don't answer
that right super clearly but
you know i i think uh there is one thing
that is a problem with the format which
is that as everybody knows the prizes
are based on every half point you score
so if you end up in a situation where
only two players are in the running for
first place
there's some incentive for the other
players to not not particularly give it
their give it their best effort um
considering how much money there is for
every every game in a sense um
as far as far as my approach i mean
we'll we'll see um whether i change
something or i don't change something uh
but as i've said before i'm just gonna
play my own game if things things break
my way that's great i mean it doesn't
seem like they are but uh i just you
know keep playing you keep playing
don't rule out the idea that you might
be able to put a few wins together right
i mean you never you never think about
it i mean actually that's the thing is
when i played in 2016 it was very it was
a very bad event because i mean i
started off i think uh i lost i mean i
drew drew uh my first game to fabiano i
think i lost in round two or maybe it
was round three to sergey and then two
two or three rounds later i also lost
lavon so i was very quickly on minus two
at the halfway mark um and i mean it
felt like the world was ending just
really really miserable i was not in a
good mood and then i was able to sort of
catch lightning in a bottle and win two
games in the middle against topalov and
on i'm not in the middle sorry towards
the end but i won two games in her own
suddenly just like that it was a
completely completely fine result so
i mean you kind of just take it one game
at a time you hope something happens i
mean i was today actually i was a little
bit optimistic for about one moment that
i might get some chances but then dude i
just killed the game so
yeah it's that's it's what it is but
it's it's fun to play and it's uh well
let me i'm enjoying it let me
i guess i should i'll bring i guess i'll
bring it to a close there to
you know to see make sure we catch some
of the final moments and kind of
whatever although i mean you're going to
get a 20-minute thing here by fabiano so
that's not that that's probably true so
that's why that's all right i am going
to get one more question out of ricardo
go back i want people to see fabian's
game because i want to get his answer to
this because is there you you made it i
played fabian 100 times because he's
gonna he's gonna think for 20 or 30
minutes here and he's going to calculate
it move by move and then he's going to
blitz out like four or five minutes and
he's going to win there you go and
probably he's going to win
there's four shouting from a card last
question and this is the last i want to
say you made comments about the format
obviously the incentive potentially not
being good or draw there's another hot
take here which is that with all due
respect to richard report as a creative
you know genius in many ways he's a very
strong player exciting and i applaud the
idea that he would play that position
for a win because he cares about his
chances not others but
the hot take is his loss
in around robin is very different than
him taking his fate into his own hands
in a knockout right and if you're if
you're looking at a format is it fair to
the other players if someone makes a
reckless decision in hindsight because
of the round robin format versus a
knockout where you're only responsible
for your own life if you if you screw up
you're out of the tournament
so your thoughts on that format
comparison
i mean
i i think i mean he's trying to take his
chances against many players some of
them just haven't capitalized i mean you
could say you could say the same thing
about his game against timor i mean it
was completely finally made a one-move
blunder and should have lost that game
and and he didn't i mean i think uh you
it's really you roll the dice a
situation like today he's rolling the
dice but i i really felt that without
the increment he had to make a decision
just just make a decision after 15-20
minutes and not just think i think he
thought for 40 or 15 minutes at that
moment and you just make the decision
you you live you you live you live and
die die by the sword kind of um i i
don't think you can say it's reckless i
mean it's uh obviously he's trying to
he's trying to play play as his best um
but it certainly i guess what you'd say
is that it feels weird once against jan
he does that when you have a feeling
that against someone i'm not gonna say
like myself but someone who's in the
middle of the pack like let's say myself
say i don't know ding or someone he's
actually probably less likely to take
that risk um so but uh it's it's what it
is and i i can't i mean i can't really
fault him for the decision i think it
was just uh he he should have made the
decision much sooner he should have
thought for 20 minutes make the decision
and then then he would have had more
time to figure it out although to me it
it seemed very i don't know it seemed
seemed insane to do it because i saw
zero winning chances and only losing
chances yeah with the queen versus the
two rooks i mean
i i feel like actually on that note i
feel like i've had probably at least
like three or four games against fabiano
and actually not in classical but like
in rapid and blitz one in classical i
guess but where he said the queen of
i've had the rooks and it's just been
like a queen against two rooks those
type of ones and somehow fabiano just
holds it with the queen and so having
had having had those experiences um i
when i was looking at the yangon i'm
just like there's there's no way that
the rooks are ever going to beat the
queen there right and so it just it
seemed like a an attempt to to lose but
yeah i mean obviously there's a lot of
pressure a lot of things probably were
going through his mind so that's what it
is
all right man
thank you for being here this was
awesome yeah no worries uh you're
awesome your stream is awesome shout out
to everyone tune in here you can also go
check out hicaro's channel which is live
as we as we speak as well i'm sure
you'll be joining that soon yeah yeah so
that's the content go go check out
hicaro joining his own channel here
probably in the next
you know a little bit but uh yeah well
it's it's awesome
to have you here awesome to have you in
madrid we'll hopefully catch up with you
again at some point we've still got some
more rounds to go yeah something like
that yeah yeah so we're gonna with that
we're gonna we're gonna head to break
here around can i say one last thing
though i will say that at some point
like in the last day or two i've started
getting a little bit antsy and i'm just
like i am uh i am kind of counting down
the days until i can actually get back
to streaming i do have to say that you
miss it you miss the community you miss
it yeah i mean i think it's like 10 days
or 9 or 10 days and so i am actually in
my mind counting down and getting
getting kind of excited about about that
return i have to say cool well your
videos have also been incredible by the
way there's never been someone playing
at this level giving that type of
insight and content so it's been anyway
all right can i i'll just say one thing
on that too though i mean it's not
unprecedented though i mean sure the the
medium for doing it is different but i
mean i remember in 95 uh game i think it
was game 10 the one that gary won
against vicious the very famous uh open
spanish with the whole night g5 sack uh
the tal sack and everything else um he
wrote i think he wrote up an analysis of
that the day after for usa today so i
mean it was for a newspaper it wasn't
you know it wasn't like for for the
internet per se but i still think it's
quite quite similar and so i don't think
it's like that unprecedented or that
unheard of and also for this event
everybody's done so much prep that i
don't think that say as long as i'm
careful with what i say about the
openings it's not really taking away
from the the overall um my my overall is
helpful for you do you enjoy it it's
like good therapy a little bit oh i i
mean i love it i mean i think at the end
of the day we're all here to try and
raise awareness for the game and i think
the fact that i'm doing that giving
people insight um it's something no one
else is doing and so yeah i enjoy it and
it's fun cool all it's all all good fun
we we enjoy it as well the fans do and
uh
on that note we will we will officially
let you get to it on your own stream and
uh eventually a video later on on
hikaru's youtube channel which you'll
want to check out so all right everybody
we are gonna when we come back i'll be
rejoined by robert hess we'll see the
the next series of moves ricardo
predicted maybe that from fabiano and
the
next
moments for round seven of the 2022 feta
candidates in just a few
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chest or mini
chest variants and with any starting
position you want club arenas are the
most flexible tournament format on
chess.com try one out today
apparently this is the horse she rode in
on literally queen isabella herself on a
night a noble steed you know changed the
world forever it's why
everyone in madrid
knows the game of chess they know that
the candidates is here
they know that uh that this is
one of the capital cities of our great
game and it's all because of that lady
right there on that noble steed now
that's a 9. thank god for queen isabella
changing the rules right and giving the
queen her powers
i know that in the filming we're really
running with this but in my head it was
the queen of france so that begs the
question who is the chess.com historian
and can i fire them
well you'd have to fire yourself i think
yeah that's a good point
that's uh call that's an out take i
believe they call it in the day i'll
take so mike's gonna say was the queen
of spain next time he knows yeah he
knows yeah we gotta find more about this
lady and find more about what the people
know here
[Music]
you guys excited for the candidates
hey can we talk for a second about this
here we go
to the plaza we go
which way is the plaza
you guys play chess yeah yeah
there you go
are you excited for the candidates yeah
yeah
you don't know what it is
okay what is it we've watched the
queen's game oh you've watched the
queen's gambit me too okay you guys
actually play chess like on your phone
what are you playing chess.com yeah
you're about 1300 unleashes yeah so it
means you'd be like 900 on chess.com
actually yeah give me your username i'll
give you a diamond membership
not kidding he's gonna be a contender in
like three years
he's up and coming so i'll give you a
premium membership and then you won't
have an excuse then you can use it i'll
go back to it yeah all right man oh
you're an am that's me man
yeah so this tournament decides who
plays magnus carlson
so the next challenger comes out of this
tournament all right guys enjoy thank
you so much have fun
see you great trip guys there you go no
drinking no drinking
still no drinking that's true you guys
are connected now yeah no we're buddies
on we're going to send each other some
ticks do you think they already talked
and then we'll we'll we'll talk about it
is that your phone blessing but they are
they there they already yeah they're
already hitting me up for my digits okay
yep maybe wearing a pager wasn't the
smartest idea to fit in with them
want to play us online or learn how to
improve join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
madrid
civilization here
is almost as old as the game of chess
some claim the queen was given her
powers to honor queen isabella
now that my friends is a chess legacy
passion for chess continues to thrive in
madrid
for the first time in 30 years spain's
capital plays host to the candidates
the most important tournament in chess
at the palace of santona the stakes are
high
eight of the world's best players
competing for the right to challenge for
the most coveted title in chess
the world chess championship
the candidates is grueling
the winner requires mental endurance and
unbreakable focus
there are those familiar with the
biggest stages in chess
yet still chasing unfinished business
and others from the next wave of stars
with little patience for yielding to
those before them
[Music]
miss amigos the next challenger to the
world champion of chess must come
through madrid
like queen isabella before them the
candidates is all about leaving a legacy
[Music]
we are back
bobby mccarwana
wants his legacy to be that he
challenged not once but twice for the
world chess championship at least maybe
even becoming the next world chess
champion he's not into this whole
yandapamrashi is going to run away with
that thing robert he's got different
plans yeah no he
made time patrol he has several extra
pawns on the king side that are about to
go rolling down the board and he wants
to keep pace with john the palms the
last thing he wants is to see jan start
to run away with it because kind of what
you and hikar were talking about like
the pressure on people he said that
report wouldn't have done what he had
done
some in the middle of the pack if you're
a full point down entering the second
half you feel like you just have to
catch up no matter who you're playing
whereas if you're only down a half point
you don't need to risk all that much to
start with because you still have your
crack at yonge machine yeah
the interview go okay by the way do you
like it
do you need my approval yeah i do i need
your approval okay i thought you did a
great job it was really funny because
you sound like every streamer who's
about to end their stream you're like
one more
one more like last one i promise well it
was so wild for everyone hikaru just
showed up in studio and shout out to him
and it was awesome and so we were me and
rob were kind of nervous time pressure
all the stuff but it worked out great
thank you again to akaru and and we
still haven't missed any final moments
of this game but let's let's dive into
this game we'll also of course check
back in with dingley wren and ali russo
russia at some point but
hikaru predicted king of 652 and set a5
and it's kind of a forced line you slide
the king and push him baby and
bobby is double checking all of those
things to be true of course but you see
this game going any different kind of
way than what nakamura predicted
well if you can just calculate a line to
the finish that's exactly what fabinho
will do he just gained an hour in the
clock so he's going to use it but i
think the other temptation besides
sliding your king to the side and
pushing your pawn would be to make a
move like rook to d8 at some point right
because your rook goes to a8 that king
is not very safe for black and you could
have a checkmating attack so we see
bobby nope he's moving his king and he
slides it towards the center
that was the one that i accidentally did
because i thought hikaru said it uh he
actually had said king to g6 which
might have actually been the more
accurate approach but it seems like it's
still winning i mean because at this
point
the king isn't really touchable there
because of how powerful the bishop is
right there's no real ways for the rooks
to bother the knight is is too many too
many squares away from delivering any
kind of check that wouldn't work anyway
so
it seems pretty straightforward and the
threat of pushing the pawn perhaps is
actually now more clear because the king
protects the rook roberts so there's not
even any like b2 shenanigans right
trying to distract the rook it's just
one of those moments where you're so
accustomed to keeping your king away
from the middle of the board yeah they
still have two rooks and a minor piece
and all these past pawns but fabiano
calculated that his king's in no danger
they're no checks right the knight is
quite far away from the king and so
f6 f7 f8 that's the
that's the game plan and that might just
be the game yeah
well let's let's bring up the analysis
board and see if we can just do a little
bit of not necessarily guess the move
but just give you the
concrete suggestion of where we see this
game going if black plays a4
why is black too slow because we just
push and if a3
i think just f7 it is kind of scary when
you've got games like this you know but
it makes so much more sense when i play
king e6 now okay the king we're on g6 b1
queens with check oh
okay so bobby is literally calculating
the most concrete lines and now we see
before us that this move wins because
when the queen comes here there is no
check on g6 so there's you know just
whatever it is there's going to be a
checkmate over here in some sort of
fashion yeah everything at that point is
yeah you go queen takes work on c5
because the rook on c7 was pinned just a
moment ago oh that's true that's
definitely just everything
yep okay so that's actually really cool
to have the foresight of putting the
king away from a square that might
become a check
in addition to the potential usefulness
of the king helping out uh with the
other pieces so king e6 it's kind of
funny that there are two almost
competing thought processes one is with
so many pieces on the board you
typically don't want your king out in
the open yeah but the other is as we're
pointing out that with
mutual promotions happening that you
want to make sure that your king is not
checked first right that's always the
issue when we see a new queen appear is
that if you're both getting queens if
you're the person with the first punch
you typically win that game so not
allowing that check on b1 is really
important so king e6 that looks like the
right start yeah king e6
not sure what else raja would have in
store here we see him with
head in hand
facing a perched fabiano caruana as
we've said
and uh
a lot of things to unpack about about
some different comments that hikara made
about the players playing these guys in
the back half he said he's playing
faviano tomorrow so he's not going to
reveal whether he changes anything
different because of the standings but
overall i mean
it does seem like we're we're going to
be having just more and more two horse
race conversations and
uh
if fabiano wins this game at least we
have that and not a one-horse race
nothing against yon or favi either way
but of course we want drama right
everyone wants there to be you know more
battles that really really matter in an
event that is becoming lopsided and i
agree with hikaru's self-assessment that
he said he's playing quite well i think
that he has shown great play thus far
and he got off to a bad start by losing
to fabiano and then he immediately won
against timor jabov and he's like i
think maybe i could have a half point
more but i'm about where i should be and
i think like oftentimes players feel
that way right they think about all
those you know half points left on the
table results that could have gone
differently but i do think ultimately
ignoring the specific specifics excuse
me of the result that occurred has
played very well well he was fair too he
said objectively you could say i maybe
should have lost ali reza so he was very
fair in the assessment that even if he
thinks he should have a half a point
different so yeah it makes sense all
right
this uh this is huge for fabiano i mean
catching our breath again and just
appreciating that
fabiano has to convert on this game
especially now that he has this winning
advantage we expect him to do so but um
while we
what we see whether rajab can make
anything spicy down the stretch we
actually have
um another potentially spicy interview
ahead for you we had nakamura in studio
our own dina bellancaya in the meantime
was catching up with richard report
let's see what uh the man from hungary
now now representing romania had to say
about his game versus yonder pawn
machine
rich thanks for joining us regardless of
the result uh what was the resultative
decisive so to be a factor that made you
play on
i don't know i guess i should throw away
my computer because i'm pretty sure the
line is bishop g6 instead of bishop h3
queen takes c7 then bishop hd it's a duo
so i figured i should be better here
because okay it was not i should play on
but i played so badly
even afterwards i'm probably just worse
so i guess you know
i kind of treat myself i was trying to
figure this out like how to defend
afterwards but i got really upset about
this that i played on
no one knows for what reason exactly and
positions clearly seems dangerous
and also many other small things
which were not going my way
before the game already
so clearly it was extremely stupid for
me to play on regardless what's the
evaluation of the position what to do
so you don't think it was just your
chest style or character that wanted to
fight
maybe but okay i mean
it's more like i wanted to lose than
anything else so
at least we'll see now you know um
okay if i will do the same tomorrow
because i have another light so
you're really curious that's what we
were speculating on and uh
uh do you mean that you played badly and
there were better ways to play even
after you refused the repetition or it's
just the repetition itself okay you tell
me i don't know i mean i guess there was
better ways to play because i don't
think white is losing on the spot yet
but
i'm just started to play
i started to miss very
strange things
i guess this happens yeah
all right thanks a lot richard and good
luck in the following white game
that was
just heart i would pound my heart but
it's next to my mic and i don't wanna
that
was heartbreaking yeah for richard i
mean to hear what he said about throwing
his computer out the window i'll be
there to catch it he has so many
interesting ideas that i want to see
what's on that laptop right but in all
seriousness
you know this is a creative player who
says that his he messed up his
preparation somewhere and that was clear
when he allowed a four straw and then
he's being very
self-critical and he's like i don't know
what i was doing i was playing to lose
and we were talking about that during
the game but it
you know with every jubilant player who
wins there's somebody on the side of
that and it's clear how much rapport
cares yeah how much this means to him
and it's really it is heartbreaking to
see somebody feel that dejected and yeah
richard's a great player he still may
have a say in this event it's not
looking like he will necessarily be the
champion here but he can win a few games
and he can change the storyline yeah
yeah that's true and it's only
one of the only other storylines i
didn't ask akara about as far as whether
or not a player ever truly feels like
they embrace the role of playing spoiler
you know and we know that they're
they're going to stay the course and and
have the approach that they have and
you know he referenced the tournament
where he kind of caught lighting in a
bottle won a couple games in a row
against apollo and anon respectively and
i think every one of these players here
knows what they're capable of if they
get on a roll you get you get maybe a
lucky break based on prep
but do you ever really embrace the role
of spoiler if you're in last place for
example in the standings and because you
don't really want to admit that you
never want to admit that you are in that
role and that's an interesting
interesting thing to consider well all
right
rajabov took on d7 now fabiano is
considering where to go next it feels
pretty straightforward still with f6 to
me
um
it's just so clear why the king's on e6
like at first i was my instincts were
like king of the center that's wrong but
the more we look at it you're saying f6
looks you know like the obvious move
view but after f6 black will push his
own passer right and it's just so
important that the king is not on g6
because if you play f7 f7 b2
b1 equals queen yup there would be a
check give the king around g6 so once
again showing the importance of the king
being on e6 and this looks crazy still
because black queen first but the big
issue for black is look at the c6 square
covered by the bishop on f3 so the only
available checks that black has are
either on this a2 e6 diagonal
g6 square
or on e1
and
it seems like no matter where you give a
check you're running out of checks
immediately and white is up a pawn as
well this is one of those rare engines
you can see where both sides get a queen
and then they might immediately trade
queens and go right back to the pawn
race right where again you have a pawn
versus f on and
at least in this scenario
black seems to be a little more on equal
ground but but i guess the problem is
that white will switch gears play a
little more prophylactically on the
queen side before just
closing his eyes and pushing the pawn um
yeah and it just
but don't be surprised if we see
something like this no and this rook d8
rook 8 idea could happen in the game
continuation as well like instead of
just pushing the pawn up to
f6 which is very tempting like even you
would start with rook to da and the
point is that
uh after king a6 or d8 if you play b2
you lose the pawn immediately because
rookie check the king has to go the b
file you check again you win the pawn
and with that pawn gone so are black's
chances
yeah
so we have b2 is an imp possible move
for black but that means it's a slow
push towards the other side yep so if
you you know the pawn back on b3 and you
say after rook d8
how else are you gonna you're gonna if
you try to do this way but now now
you're too slow right because you can't
push a3 you'll lose that pawn yep just
because the check and capture and if you
push b2 we already saw what happens you
check you check you win the pawn so it
looks like the more we look at it where
it feels like rook d8 is probably what
the doctor ordered not not my initially
suggested six
it seems like both are good but yes rook
did i guess now that we're making the
moves it feels like perhaps it's a a
little bit easier although
ah you can't play rook c7 i was like oh
yeah it's so hard for black this bishop
is just a monster yeah
and i was thinking you play rook c7
right and to cover the b file or
something but after rook b8 you can't
play rook b7 because the bishop covers
that square too
yeah and there's you don't have time for
things like knight to b5 to slow down in
this position even with the knight d4
check coming
f6
b2
and bishop e4 the knight's no longer on
c3 so your bishop can help defend the
square
but these are tricky things i mean we're
we're playing them out now we have the
benefici you know the benefit of each
other i am a benefit
we have the benefit of each other the
benefit of the eval bar
notice how i slip that in but it's it's
hard to be on your own lost in thought
this is that even that line is very
tricky right because how nerve-wracking
is it when your opponent can block the
only file available to stop them from
queening right there's just so much to
calculate here
like even here at b2 i know that's why
you check and check right
but if here if like knight to b5 first
you could be nervous about b2 coming
but again the whole point is that if the
knight leaves that square you have
bishop e4 so very nice
yeah and even here there's probably a
couple more moves that have to be played
but the issue for black is b1 is covered
f8 is not and bishops being long range
pieces knights short range yep clear the
bishop has the advantage
okay well
hikaru predicted he's like fabiano's
just gonna take a bunch of time and then
bust out the rest of his to the end
didn't take as much time as we thought
he was going to before rookie two but
again he's just he's very precise as we
said just technical
he uh he rarely lets his prey off of the
hook he also literally doesn't care
about the chat getting 100 subs that's
true he literally doesn't care about the
chat getting on herself in fact if
that's right if bobby blows this chat
you get you get a hundred subs so now
who are you rooting for
he's gonna car nakamura and i don't i
will text him right away if that happens
and say you better come drive a hundred
subs right and he will he will he would
do it for the content anyway um
all right well caruana winning this will
will
keep
yonder pomnishi on his toes
only a half a point ahead of at least
one player he would be also getting that
player with the black pieces in the back
half so we have
we have quite the storyline ahead for us
even if it is a two horse race it is
still a race and a lot
the highest title in chess as we know at
stake do you mind if i go off script for
a second here
what are those cups
the players have oh like what
i don't know yeah that's a that's a
really tall plastic cup yeah and it's
you know
opaque
and you know it almost feels like
the cups you go to at rogers had orange
juice in it earlier go ahead you think
like a fast food restaurant it's a free
restaurant you know yeah but usually
they're not see-through
yeah there's the oj the remnants of an
oj by the way with extra pulp clearly
who likes who likes oj with pulp come on
chat
no pulp is what i want give me oj with
no pulp unless it's freshly squeezed
i just never have seen cups like that so
the good news is they're really tall
because as chess players we want tall
chairs we want tall cups i definitely
want a tall chair but how many games
have you played where you get some water
but the cup is like oh yeah really
that's the most painful so at least you
have
tall shady jess right on cue tall cups
for tall chairs exactly
we love you shady jess i don't really
like looking at the
the pulp stain
easy to knock over that's true
yeah i'm really not a fan of pulp in my
but you're a fan of pulp fiction i am a
huge fan of pulp fiction
great movie
f6 from fabiano he does not go for rook
to eight okay hold the phone actually
uh easy to knock over from by the way
look at that username
oh
that's a creative little username there
we like that um okay bobby doesn't play
rook d8 so we still have a little bit of
a thing to calculate now we're back to
the line that i was looking at if we
analyze b2
f7
both sides get queens
we could get something like
that check and queen trade line so let's
let's go for it okay so
i i think now you got to go for f7 we
have no choice because you don't have
time anymore
yeah you got to go
you got when you got to go you got to go
yes me too yes this is true and the
problem for black right there are those
three checks oh sorry there i guess
they're four but the a2 e6 diagonal as
soon as you play move like queen a2
check the king goes to f6 and then there
are no more checks yeah so the checks
run out very very quickly uh on the
diagonal here
king f6 you don't have queen b6 check
because rook d6 just simply pins and
wins your queen
so
yeah i i i think that we could get that
line i was looking at with queen g6 i
think i think it's the best check
right and then queen f6 is
the reply is your shot gotta block and
this is much easier though because
before and hikara was saying this it
looked scary because there were two
pawns yeah coming down main street now
it's just one off the side over there
easy to see how you get behind it the f
pawn is running again and if we get
another mutual queens that would be
funny but i don't think day pawn is fast
enough
so yeah fabiano he's got the perch going
he's still there he's still
leaning over the board ready to end this
game
still got the perch
raja is still
deep in think
that
i mean that's not a thing that you would
normally say if you're speaking
correctly from the kids who do grammar
good
um
but i said deep in think and then when i
said it i liked it i liked how it
sounded yeah you did it earlier today
and i didn't correct you on it but i
thought about it and i've thought about
it it sounds like
the title of something you know
[Laughter]
chat is rooting for pulp
that better stay under 50 chat or i'm
going to mute all of you i better stay
under 50 percent i am not
happy about the uh the vote for there to
be more okay no it did standard 50 good
that's right but the fact that it's that
close to 50 is really impossible
kind of a kind of a monster are you chat
what do you want to chew your orange
juice
[Laughter]
what's wrong with you all right let's
let's head over and uh
take a quick look at dingley ren and
farouja i think we should um i actually
forgot that game was still going i i
i didn't but
it doesn't seem like much has changed
um
outside that the dynamic we talked about
right which is you have the outside pass
b pawn versus the extra pawn on the
kingside majority
um
the valuation is right at 50 for good
reason
it's kind of game where if either player
does anything too crazy they could lose
but it's not over yet i mean maybe we
shouldn't just dismiss that this game is
going to be a peaceful result they are
playing for a reason
you know wonder which of them thinks
they have the better chances right
because
uh this at this moment here the knight
f5 is well placed but the h3 pawn is an
easy target
from black's perspective the other rook
a3 or knight f4 check both of them will
scoop up that pawn on h3 so
there's a little bit here but where's
that king going that's the question that
black needs to answer is where are you
going to put your king
yeah
you'd love to run this way because then
the king is ultimately helpful there's a
little bit of danger
from a discovered check or at least it
you know you always have to double check
but the truth is there isn't really
anything that well king e3 right the
king moves over now you're now you're on
the side of the board where you can help
with the pawn but in some ways maybe
that's
the opposite of where you want to be
because
if white gets aggressive and i don't
know that this works or not but if white
gets aggressive now you may wish your
king was actually back home in fact ali
reza says
yeah i like that idea i like my king
or i can see him like that king where i
can see him right in front of my
my king side there i think that's a good
choice because there's no real reason to
take
any sort of risk and i think many people
say there's no risk whatsoever but there
is right if you
totally ditch your king side white
already has one extra pawn there and if
i can kick your knight which is a nice
blockader then my epon at some point
might start rolling so black is the one
with the best pawn on the board with
this b5 pawn it just can't get very far
and now rook c1 activating the rook
makes perfect sense and the h3 pawn i
don't think you want to go like knight
f4 check and take that pawn yep that
night as i keep saying really important
blockading piece as soon as you do this
e6 happens threatening both e7 and rook
ca checkmate so this is how you lose a
game that
should not really be losing good tip for
me
no dan this is how you lose a game
you know danny i have a lot of faith and
respect for your chess
you heard it it was on camera someone
clip it clip it and ship it you can't
take it back um
but
yes somehow i have this feeling that
dingley wren is looking at
the situation looking at the clock
by the way they still have 13 moves to
make before they get increment
so this is
again objectively
we're at a we're at a deadlock eval bar
for a reason right this is this is an
objectively equal position
but
equal positions aren't just wrong you
still have to draw them right and uh i
would always used to tell my students
you know who wins equal positions the
person who plays better magnus carlson
and magnus carlson he wins from both
sides yeah so um
there's something to the fact that this
game is still going
we're obviously going to keep a slightly
closer eye on the caruana job of battle
over there
but nothing has happened yet in that
game
and
farouza earlier in this tournament
against report in that rook end game
right he went wrong despite the computer
evaluation this one has
been easier quite a bit easier to play
and against
magnus carlsen that's been one of
ours of just fatal flaws is the end game
where it looks like he's about to make a
draw he's very close and then something
goes haywire so right right here is not
a moment where you just assume that the
draw is within reach you have to prove
it and that's why you never stop
calculating because as soon as you do
that then dingley ryan gets one little
idea yep then another and part of the
reason is that white has a much safer
king
right
we don't dismiss checkmating ideas in
the end game just because no queens are
on the board that this king on f8 is in
more potential danger than the king on
d3 even though it doesn't look like that
much trouble
no it's true and again look at the time
i mean hicaro made the observation uh
when he thought maybe bobby might be
slightly misplaying the winning chances
turns out probably was okay but
picard made a good observation which you
say you don't get increment in the
second time which will either and so
often what happens is you pass time
control you take a breath maybe you then
spend 20 30 minutes on the next couple
critical moves before you know it you're
back in a spot where you have to make 20
moves in about 30 minutes and that's not
so easy here ollie russo perugia
has to make 13 moves in 16 minutes
it's um
in fact no he still has to make his 46
move so he has to make
no sorry it is 13. he has to make 13
moves
in 16 minutes
and dingley wren has not offered the
draw for a reason maybe he wants to take
advantage of that time control situation
right and if you know some of the most
tempting moves are just going pawn
hunting and we keep talking about like
rook a3 let's do the rook one actually
let's analyze that because if the rook
goes here
you can also get
in
trouble yeah and i guess after king d5
you do have these night checks
nine of four
and you're just in time with rook d
three check yeah okay and now now the
tables are turning
yeah still should be probably should
still be a draw but it's it's
okay so if the rook goes for each and
maybe this is what aliens is calculating
is we already established the moving the
knight away from the e6 square is not
okay because it needs to block ad6
but you could maybe go take the palm
with the rook here white doesn't have a
concrete knockout
no not at all i want to attack the
knight right so king has to go up to f7
because i don't want to let that pawn to
push
worst case scenario i can go knight five
you can just make a draw on the spot at
the very least
just back and forth man yeah is there
anything more
olly russell peru plays knight of fort
check
he's just gonna repeat he's not he's not
taking h3 for sure no i don't know um
after after king e3 he'll probably play
knight d5 check
and just
do that dance it's actually an
interesting thing to observe that the
rook is cutting off the king from the
fourth rank everyone so there's no
there's none of that which means you can
just
check this one home
because because the king would love to
play king d4 or king e4 to come forward
but no way to do that nope and if you
start running to the king side like
instead of king d3 if you play king over
there to f3
uh then black maybe can't think about
bringing that rook forward because look
at this king e4 afterward k3 check big
mistake knight c3
oh yeah and your king has nowhere to go
yep if you go anywhere else there's a
discovery on a2
so look at that yeah so
we would anticipate that if knight f4
is followed with knight d5 we will get a
perpetual check for a draw
if i was calling
my shots here
yeah it looks like a straightforward
repetition which means that
both these players still remain
quite a distance away from janupamshi
our leader yep and for farouza drawing
dealing around with the black pieces
that's a very good result so he can
enter the second half of the tournament
he made a stable draw right he wasn't in
any real danger throughout the game so
that's a very nice game from alireza
yeah
dingley wren thinking about the check
but as we said unless he's gonna run
this way but that also feels well
actually no if you go there you get
forked and if you go to c2
that just feels wrong you're just going
the wrong way going the wrong way so the
king the king is going to keep itself in
the center and i think we're going to
see the perpetual there so
all right let's back up again and uh
reset what we're looking at here because
well even though rajab hasn't moved that
is definitely the spicier of the two
games still remaining
taymor trying to calculate his way back
into this one
and i'm wondering what it is exactly
that he's thinking about and
you know
in his game we talk about b2 f7 the
pawn's pushing going for promotion but
because he can't stop the pawn he can't
play rook c8
in the bottom right hand side of the
screen because then the bishop gives
that check on b7 just to win the rook
yeah so
i think i mean he's he's
he's way far down the rabbit hole at
this point he took the red pill like 10
minutes ago like he's just you know he's
not looking at anything we're looking at
he's trying to see is there some
variation where we both get queens and i
can perpetual check my way
swindle my way into a victory because we
have the benefit of the eval bar saying
hey there is no swindle here unless
white blunders but he doesn't have that
right so so and if fabi went for a line
as we go let's head over to that board
if bobby goes for a line
that allows both players to get a queen
then uh
who knows what can happen right so let's
let's look at that if
b1 queen
happens and f8 queen happens he doesn't
know like we do that this is just a uh
a win for white he's got a lot of checks
to consider queen e1 check queen g6
check queen b3
yeah i just feel like the checks run out
so quickly that that's really i think
where his mind is taking him yeah that
i'm not going to be able to check the
white king i can't allow the queens to
stay on the board because the king on a6
will get mated quite quickly right and
if the queen trade happens do i have any
shot whatsoever
it's not looking likely after a queen
trade that black
can come remotely close to holding and
you're just forced to do it maybe he's
considering other checks but then you
get to move your king with chess i love
when you can move out of check
putting someone into a check it's one of
my favorite things in chess yeah it is
really cool
f7
yeah we're gonna get this line f7 now on
the board
queen
queen i think we're gonna get queen g6
and queen f6 and then do this whole dog
and pony show again we're gonna race
pawns again of the port
and white again is gonna be
uh in the driver's seat as far as uh
that contest goes
gotta love a good bishop you gotta love
a good bishop you know
that is a bishop not just dominating a
knight by keeping the knight out of
potentially very useful squares for
black but preventing the rook from doing
any damage robert made a really good
observation which is why we're going to
see both queens because black has no
option of rook c8 because of bishop b7
so this bishop is uh a bit of a freak
over here
i just thought of heath ledger's joker
yeah just a freak
i was thinking of giannis you know oh
well
yeah freak of nature yeah the greek
freak that's a pretty good reference
but yeah this pawn is pawns are
promoting and
i mean
which i looked up at fabi there for a
second just a glance at him and he's
trying to find any possible way to make
this complicated yeah and the issue is
trading queens doesn't exactly leave
as many complications
but
it's not complicated if you keep the
queens on the board because you just get
checkmated yeah it's not too complicated
when you're getting mated yeah um
yeah there's no other move here there is
a
funny move brick up five i just want to
say it because it's funny wow that
actually is
wasn't even on my radar but it's a good
thing to show yeah let's show rook five
and you take it the point is you get a
queen with check and yet white still
wins so what's funny is you move the
king and now there's no more checks
so what is the win
king g7
king g7 oh my gosh that is hilarious
i love it
in fact and you know raja would would
find a light a line like that right
you're looking at every possible
resource and so this is actually a
common theme for those watching it's an
instructive one to there are many end
game puzzles and
and different moments where you force
it's an attraction sacrifice you attract
someone to a square that they don't want
to go
in order to
achieve achieve another another means
and in this case it would be to get a
queen with check unfortunately for black
it's not enough
because this pass pawn is just so strong
so um
it's a cool idea to keep in mind it does
not work for tamera java and
he's going to continue to try to do the
work he can to save this one but uh i
don't see it happening
that was a really good line though yeah
work out five broke up yeah because it's
like a last-ditch effort it also stops
the pawn from promoting and as you're
pointing out you're dragging that king
to a square it really doesn't want to be
on the diagonal so
for rajabov
i mean look at him he's got the queen in
hand he's ready to to promote that pawn
fun fact for the viewers
you are not required to get a queen if
you touch the queen if you touch the
pawn you have to move it it's actually a
important rule
that if you touch the piece you're
promoting to off the board you're not
required to promote to that piece
i never even thought about that before
it actually i mean as a
you know i'm a certified national
tournament director right excuse me i
used to run international events i don't
know if i could i took the test wow i
feel like i'm i'm not a fide arbiter but
i am i don't know what my
i think i might be a senior arbiter i
know i'm a senior teacher brush the dirt
off your shows told me that i'm not even
belonging in the same room as you
uh in a four in a previous life when i
was
well let's just talk about the chat
rojava intermittently stares at bobby's
forehead and attempt to steal the moves
from his mind
get that person to diamond membership
that's my favorite comment of the day
you also probably like you get a diamond
membership you like the username
i love the username yeah mcgowan
let's get that let's get that person a
diamond membership
that's it that's all i got anyway back
to my story thank you so uh
yeah it took all the tests to become a
senior tv and it was a there was a
a tournament where i was like making a
ruling where someone in a times in time
scrambles it's scary you touch the piece
off the boat off the board and then you
realize what would often happen it's
stalemate
so you put the queen back
and then the opponent made a claim you
had to get a queen
and so i had to look it up at the time i
didn't know it wasn't on the test but i
looked it up and made the right call
so anyway so it's a good fun fact if you
ever playing over the board chess you
you only legally have to make the moves
of the pieces you touch on the board you
can touch a piece off the board and
you're not required to get the queen so
fun fact even if getting the queen was a
stalemate you can still change your mind
and favi just got the queen bobby got
the queen
you can get the queen
no you get the queen
well they both did we're gonna do two
queens
and for java yes he has been staring at
bobby a bit and it's
it comes off as the look of a person who
knows that he's losing this game yeah
but i think we're gonna get that line i
think we're gonna queen g6 queen of six
and
do it again
yeah
oh we're having a great time we had a
great interview with akara nakamura
earlier if you're just tuning in it was
fantastic we also have had many great
interviews with dina bell and kaya and
the players downstairs
we've got this this game going here
where fabiano caruana is trying to keep
pace with right now clear tournament
leader by a point and a half over
fabiana caruana
and yonda pomeshi who won with the black
pieces over richard report in
in fine fashion we got to stop taking
that zoom in take of the pieces with
those cups right in front of them we
keep doing it and the cups are like can
we get an arbiter to walk through the
room and remove those cups
i mean i'm i'm only half kidding
can someone in the team be like hey
could you guys move those cups i feel
like that's distracting to the player it
is but put them on the other side guys
content think of the content i think the
content that fabiano's thing about is
winning his game that is it that is the
content he's supposed to think about and
i'm supposed to be thinking about this
content you know
um it's interesting that fabi hasn't
moved yet do you think there's a
possibility
he's thinking about playing king e7 here
king to e7 instead of trading queens
well he hasn't made his move so
is there
a variation here with king e7 where you
keep the queens on the board because
there's not a single check that black
has after king e7 at least not one that
doesn't give away material immediately
to the bat cave let's analyze it let's
go
king to e7 we gotta review
it i guess after kingston there is queen
h7 check but that doesn't really
kinky e7 put too much fear into anyone's
heart
yeah queen chapman doesn't actually help
you just
you you go king to uh
yeah oh my gosh i love this
so much
and it's one of those rare cases where
robert was saying almost often the first
person who delivers the check
in in games where both players are
getting queens
goes on to win or at least have a
perpetual
very rarely do you see situations like
this where the king is hiding in the in
the middle of the board right hiding in
plain sight
as they say but the problem is now black
can run with the king to b5 and now we
have a dogfight yeah you do not want
this situation where your king is on e7
yeah there's a queen a rook and a knight
that can all eventually go after your
king
and the black king may be able to run
away as well over it's like it's funny
because you start looking at lines like
this queen b8 you assume it's going to
be win but then this you give another
check and you're like where's the mate
and all of a sudden it's like you got
nothing yeah no no you're losing maybe
well you're in some trouble because
queen g7 check is an idea and that king
is not very happily placed on e7 so yeah
so more evidence as to suggest that i
think we will get queen f6
um
this king e7 being met by king b5 would
be
not what fabiano wants
no especially because after queen f6 the
lines we've been talking about where you
trade queens and after a4 you put your
rook down on d8 it seems like this is
much more clear-cut although black can't
play rook c7 here and that's something
that wasn't available in the previous
lines because that's a rook a7 right if
you trade rooks are you going to be able
to stop the a pawn the answer doesn't
seem to be yes very easily
actually not at all yeah and we talked
about the bishop dominating the board
dominating the night this is a rare spot
where suddenly the tables turn in the
open board and the knight is perfectly
positioned
yep so
the
pawn on a4 is very dangerous if you can
block the a file so the rook can't
chase it down
although here the move rook c8 looks
very nice just to
kick that knight away that way your rook
can always come back down to c1 to stop
that pawn and that's a nice that's okay
i didn't see that that's key if you have
that but again
we're we're making it sound like it's
easy but fabiano's got to be calculating
stuff like this right because this is
super nerve-wracking like you said
robert there's there's an idea
that makes your job hard when it comes
to calculating the the pure race
position that is pawn versus pawn oops
they don't move like that
well they can they can't if you capture
and then go that's true
i'm supporting you thank you
um
the knight is actually in a really
irritating spot preventing the bishop
from moving to what could be a couple of
useful diagonals over here
so this is
this is why i mean that's uh
bobby who knows that he's in the
driver's seat but i don't i don't think
he has a clear vision of where he wants
this game to go yet
um
and he has plenty of time right so he's
trying to
ensure that he does not let this
advantage slip he's well aware that
young she won his game and that if he
can only draw that's a full point of
separation so he is doing everything
within his power to
play methodically
and convert his advantage that he knows
he has
so
yeah this is uh good dingley wren still
playing methodically over there against
ollie rosa perugia he doesn't want to
just
repeat moves
some sort of perpetual check
if you had asked me like two hours ago
how much longer the game would have gone
i would have said 20 minutes yeah 15 20
minutes and yet they're still digging
running ali reza frusia duking it out
um
in a game that we don't have on screen
but a game that is still going you can
go to chess.com events and uh
choose your own adventure always
remember that option is available to you
at all times
you can also watch this show from
chess.com that's embedded in the uh the
upper right corner so if you want to
toggle back and forth between games and
keep the commentary going you can do
that
and invite sent to all those watching on
twitch youtube and everywhere else if
you want to head over
to our events portal you can do so
some people
are looking for chess coaches out there
let's head over to that cta
we call that a call to action
in showbiz kids and we're going to
remind you that now fridays every friday
at 6 p.m eastern 3 p.m pacific
we've got chess lessons happening
brought to you by coach james canty it's
the chess kids summer summer clubhouse
camp level up your chest this summer if
you have kids get them involved
grandkids anyone anyone who's a kid
can be involved in this but that's the
only requirement gotta be a kid and get
coaching from james canty all right
you like how i threw that up there yeah
i had no idea where you're going with it
you said anyone wants a coach i was like
are you offering my coaching services
if there's a few
if there are very few joys remaining in
my life when i do commentary with you
[Laughter]
if there are a few things i really enjoy
left it's when i can actually surprise
you throw you off your game wait that
sounded very sad
no i'm kidding obviously it hurt very
this is super messy honestly again this
is where this is where i feel like our
commentary
information can be really misleading not
not doing justice to how difficult this
moment is right the pressure is on the
line fabiano knows he has to win this
game
and uh
with two queens on the board and your
king in the middle
you are you are a one land mine away
from it blowing up in your face right so
literally you have to be so careful in
positions like this i mean we'll
probably if he does indeed win this game
and comes for an interview we'll
probably ask him but i think something
that a lot of fans get curious about is
how many moves ahead do you think fabian
is calculating right now yeah well we'll
ask him about that if he wins this game
we will get fabiano in studio so that
it's another reason why all 23 000 of
you on twitch and tens of thousands
other places should not go anywhere
we got plenty more ahead even if the
result is what we expect it to be but
that question is often asked
half-heartedly like oh like how many
moves can you see without expecting an
answer but this is a good moment
to illustrate that sometimes players
really do think towards the exact end of
the game yeah we'll ask him about this
moment too because i just saw the dive
in there from bobby he missed something
and it doesn't mean he doesn't know he's
winning but he clearly missed something
in this in this line he went for and you
could argue
that you know rook d8 as robert was
saying was much better than pushing the
f pawn right away and
whatever it is that he's struggling with
right now he clearly he clearly missed
something not super thrilled about the
tactics on the board and his king coming
under fire on e6
i wonder what it is and sometimes
players see ghosts right yeah they don't
they think that a position isn't winning
but it's because it's in their head
they're mistaking where the pieces are
that happens plenty often and right now
you you know he's looking at queen f6
right that's like the move you'd want to
play just offering a queen trade you are
up a pawn you have a bishop and a rook
teaming up very nicely that can stop the
a-pawn but as you're saying that there
clearly is something that's making him
nervous right now and it could be in
part the magnitude of the moment but it
also is probably something in the
variations that he you know when
previously when the pawns were still on
the board before they promoted he was
like okay i have this and now he's like
whoa not so fast maybe that's not such a
good idea
he's got 23 minutes to 27 minutes to
make 13 moves so it's
it's not real
time pressure yet but you know not an
eternity either especially in in a
position that could get away from you
quickly when you have your king in the
middle of the board
and all kinds of opportunities to go
wrong which is which is why i think
ultimately we will just see queen f6
robert even if whatever he's struggling
with right now to play i think he will
go for it because i don't think he's
going to want to risk king e7 unless he
sees a concrete win and you're
absolutely right though like we see him
like he's fidgeting a lot yeah
and normally he just kind of sits and
thinks yeah but it does seem like he's
very uncomfortable with some sort of
variation
yep let's bring up the analysis board
and uh
show what i think was
so again it was right here where rook d8
in hindsight was
the most
accurate thing to do but again we have
all the benefits of everything you know
each other as i said as well as the
engine and the eval bar and even if it's
not the engine moves all the time we
still have so much more complete
information that
just having someone tap on your shoulder
and say hey you're winning allows you to
often find better moves um
but he doesn't go for that he plays f6
and at the time he was still confident
about it and then roger went for a long
think before committing
all out to the race
he
so i'm just i'm sitting here wondering
like what is it in the line let's look
at so what is it deep down the line that
we think is
awkward for him to spot
maybe he doesn't because he missed it
earlier robert i'm wearing maybe he just
doesn't realize how strong this idea is
right we have that idea because we now
found it once and we have the computer
telling us why it's better but maybe
he's underestimating how strong that
point is it's very possible and actually
can we just go back before the queen
trade right there after queen f6 is
their queen e8 check
uh and that you have to find this
yeah that move by itself isn't the issue
it's more like uh how many moves that
king have the c5 rook is because
otherwise knight b5 would be checkmate
yeah
yeah the king were on b6 here that would
have been a puzzle
knight b5 is checkmate
so this is the kind of thing perhaps
that he's working his way through
because it's really not fun to have your
king out in the open you're always
looking out for a potential checkmate
and you know am i at risk of a
bunch of checks that may not be a mate
but may lead to a draw by perpetual
check so i could see this
he knows he has to win right because you
start even looking at this sort of stuff
right no oh wait never that's checked i
was gonna say i thought there was like a
queen e3 check and like it's just an
absolute mess right but
that is one important benefit is that
you have the check coming to the black
king
in discovered fashion
but even here like let's say you play
queen c8 just to protect your rook yep
and you get your discover check with
king e7 and the king goes to b5
and then it's like wait the black king i
don't see
a good check against that king right
yeah that's not easy it's getting wild
again so maybe he missed that queen
queenie check allows black to keep the
queens on the board and now he's trying
to figure out all right if the queens
are here to stay
what should i do
to keep my king safe and to hound the
black king yeah it's just so much easier
for us to look at this position and say
like oh it should be
who wants to play this position for
either side i mean look at this the
kings are like this is like not fun
right even when you think you're the one
who should probably be winning that's
such a scary position to go for and then
now
the only good thing for fabi in the live
position as we back out and look at it
like he has no choice
at this point whether whether you play
king e7 or queen f6 robert he has no
choice but to go for the crazy like he's
already here there's no turning back so
he's nervous and we see him fidgeting
but i think he'll probably find the
right variations because there's no
bailout here right there's no way to go
backward no
so queen f6 it is and
yeah i'm really curious
as to what is making him quite so
nervous yep
but
i guess the question for you today is is
the more he thinks
is there a possibility there's king e7
here yep and doesn't offer the queen
trade just yet we've seen this before
with dingley ren we saw it right the
longer he thought the more we knew that
something wasn't uh
gonna go right and the more you think in
positions like this sometimes you can
become your own worst enemy in those
spots so
all right
i think we run in and all the reservoirs
are also still playing i
think we're gonna have a lot more ahead
in this game so we are going to take a
very quick break
don't go anywhere when we return
we continue
our coverage
round seven of the 2022 f8 candidates
from madrid
knight settles upon the city of madrid
and often the city comes to life we're
eating dinner around midnight here in
madrid and it's because pretty much
everywhere you're looking downtown this
is this is the vibe it's pretty chill
and pretty awesome don't go anywhere
this show is going to continue to be
pretty chill and pretty awesome
chess.com coverage of the feed a
candidates returns in a moment
did you know you can watch top chess
events right on your phone you don't
even need to download an app just open
any mobile browser and head to chess.com
events
you can see what's happening right now
check out top games
see results
and so much more try it for yourself at
chess.com events
i was told by the locals of a chess
school and there's people out there we
should go we should go while they're
opening the door for us let's go let's
go school of chess don't cost nothing
dodging traffic
a game as old as chess itself
and half as dangerous
this is the most dangerous part of our
career
it's game on gotta give the people what
they want
game one keep going don't stop
so we tell them that chess education
gives you better life decisions as we
get hit by a car crossing the road in a
non-crosswalk
at 5 20.
5 20 what's home he got
started
dude
stay and crash of all the places we
could film in spain the fact there's
going to be a class and we're here
we can film other stuff but we got to
stay for that yeah i agree people say
crashing weddings is fun we're crushing
a school
if the chess is not taking place check
it out
flamenco dancing huh you think of what
i'm thinking you want to be my partner
are there partners in flamenco we're not
even graffitiing a building we're like
trying to help local kids and yet
somehow i see this going poorly
this would be like you know being at the
public courts and like federer comes
but we are walking quickly i heard the
word siguride and i was like no security
dodd mike leave me not yeah
the police not
but we got to go
you know they obviously kind of knew
that we were
you know we kind of knew we were a big
deal they opened up their arms and so
this is why when we were kids our dad
told us to say open sesame yeah which
gets you into the building but if you
say open ahadres you do not get in you
don't get in the village no no it's open
sesame you gotta remember that dad was
right i play a lot of it yeah i love it
you could have gotten us into the
building you play on chess.com yes of
course do you know who that is
no
you don't need to no you just need to
use the app he's the face of chess.com
do you have a diamond membership no
that's like the paid membership yeah no
i'll give it to you
seriously yeah for now you get a
peccatina there you go
so just
next time you're on the site just send a
message to support and say i met danny
in spain say i met danny and danny said
he would i could get a diamond
membership okay all right i love your
work
i love your work thanks guys bye-bye so
it's funny danny we were sold a bill of
goods they flew us here to do real work
yeah and i realize our entire job is
just to go around getting out of the
stickers honestly let's oh well there
you go i can't even do that well
[Music]
chess kid is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing the
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to mastery this
curriculum is designed to work with
common core standards and global
educational guidelines there are more
than 50 000 chess puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
games were completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send them
messages
chess kit is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
[Music]
and while we were away
actually right after we went to the
break
we had a result come in
no surprises robert dingley wren and all
the rest of perugia did end their game
in a draw
i think we have a lot of fighting just
ahead today it's going to be awesome
robert hess here with me danny wrench we
are in madrid
and uh we have one game still in action
it's been an awesome day once again
players delivering
tons of fun chess and right now that guy
needs to deliver in order to keep pace
with the under pawn machine
yeah because john de palma she keeps
winning he has four wins out of seven
games so people are sometimes
complaining oh too many draws in chess
yonda palmichi singh
hold on to those complaints i'm gonna
keep winning games hop on my back here i
got some decisive chests for you i got
your decisive chest right here
there you go how do you like them apples
yonder palmy
says he's uh
he's on fire
and bobby on caruana is looking nervous
this game slips
you got a real problem yeah he still has
his head in his hand so something about
the ensuing
ending
likely without the queens but maybe
there's some 28 checks not that as we're
discussing something is really bothering
him yep and it might be that he assumed
not only assumed but he calculated but
missed something that he was easily
winning the game was just going to be
over he was going to get that full point
now he's like i don't see the finish
line and that's really nerve-wracking
hey car was talking about game
trajectory when he was here for the
interview and the trajectory of this
game
has improved forward job of you know the
king went up at h5 and it looked like it
was over right but now there are chances
yeah and the longer that rajabov has
some semblance of hope i feel like the
more stressful it is for fabiano and the
more stressful it is for him the more
likely it is for him to go on i'm not
saying it is likely but just becomes
increasingly so yep
no well said and uh
it it is also fair to say like you said
it's it might just be that he lost sight
of the finish line thought he was
winning in a line lost sight so now he's
nervous because he's got to do the work
again right uh but it
doesn't necessarily mean that he doesn't
know he's winning but it can be super
scary when you thought you had the win
in hand and all of a sudden you're
you're resetting plus there's no way
he's not feeling the pressure of just
how much is at stake in this one
particular game at this point
fabiano has to mirror yawn every step of
the way and then he would still have to
beat john in a head-to-head battle to
have a chance to win so john wins he's
got to win john draws he has to at least
draw and head to head bobby would have
to get it done to catch
yana pandashi but uh all right
right now we've got this game here rajab
is
on the clock now he's considering moves
like queen g8 and queen e8 also could be
just very deeply down the variations of
queen takes f6 trying to figure out if
he has any chance to hold there
um
and i
feel like the assumption both players
have their instincts not just assumption
is that
the queenless position is winning for
white
just because it's an extra pawn the f
pawn is running the king is very close
by and that rook d8 move as soon as you
see it you kind of realize that oh okay
that's going to stop my a pawn
advancing
yeah as soon as you see the idea you
recognize okay this is this is kind of
hard for black but
and it's
easier said than done because sometimes
you are you know you get tunnel vision
right robert like you you're calculating
lines
forcing beating your head against the
wall forcing a variation that you
thought was winning and maybe sometimes
you're not looking for a different type
of idea a different type of approach so
it's quite possible that that that is
what uh
was the struggle for faviana though the
longer the job of things and then when
you can work on your opponent's time you
use their clock as a weapon
helps you get get things back on track
yeah i think what rajab wants and he's
just making sure that his king doesn't
get checked made immediately is to keep
those queens on the board get that black
king up to b5 at some point yeah maybe
continue running with that king up the
board and while that will prevent you
from promoting your a-pawn
white's f-pawn isn't going to be
promoting very easily when there's a
queen rook and knight aiming towards the
white king so i think that her job over
here he's just trying to find a
variation oh it is yeah he goes for it
queen eight queen
rather than trading queens he wants to
make sure the queen stay on the board
yeah
which makes sense so probably what let's
let's bring up the analysis board
probably what that means is that
first and foremost he calculated deeply
enough in this line
and saw rook d8 coming and just knew he
was busted so even if this gets the game
to last longer players at this level
aren't trying to keep the game lasting
longer right they they they want it to
be as messy and as complicated and if
you lose 20 minutes or 20 moves faster
but there were real opportunities for
your opponent to go wrong you'll go for
that line and that's why he's gone for
queen e8 because in this line even if
objectively the computer says that white
is winning more quickly after king to d6
as long as fabiano finds that
this is this is a scary position right
everyone wants to go for positions where
your opponent has a chance to blunder
bobby could play king d6 and i wonder
what roger's next move will be it's
going to be something subtle i think but
but keeping it a mess
yeah i think king b5 is not very
good because it's a rook b7 check the
king can't go to a4 without dropping the
rook and if it goes to c4 there's queen
e6 check
and get the queens off and then we're
back to pushing and we see how good the
rook is on b7 can always go to a7 the f
pawn is running up with the king's help
and that bishop on f3 it's such a good
piece it keeps control that diagonal
does not allow black to get anywhere
near the f pawn
okay that's huge so if king to b5 isn't
an easy way to protect the rook
uh
moving the rook
well bishop b7 checkers yeah that's
something that's immediately possible
there may be other things but i'll just
wait but you can't take on c8 there
because there's 94 check
right so bishop b7 check
king b5 but you queen e5 check so as
long as you get the queen off the board
yeah i feel like white is gonna win the
game yep uh but it was just very
important to note that you couldn't just
take this rook on c8 even though you
started with a little bishop fork there
because the knight was coming to e4 with
check yeah
is important to note that king d6 really
is the only move here if you play rookie
black actually has an interesting
draw in hand
by sacrificing here first
then trading queens on f6
then forking with knight d5 check
then both sides push
and we get we get a drawn end game with
queens and i just see one tb table-based
table base
by the way that by itself i guess it
should be obvious because we already
know we've solved table-based positions
up to i think eight pieces but i wasn't
expecting that to happen yeah i mean
yeah so just to draw with both sides
getting a queen so
that's a fun way to blunder into a draw
so that worries you that fabiano's
thinking because you're thinking don't
play rookie seven due to this trick but
you could miss that i mean you know it's
not likely but it's possible to miss
something like that we see probably
shuffling in his chair looking around
that could be a serious blunder and he's
calculating it for sure he's working his
way all the way down to the end because
actually if you just finish off the
sequence with
in that line yep all this stuff and then
let's just push the pawns to show
everybody what it's like yep so a4 f5
and so on
right
so white is still up a pawn
but at the end over here after f8 equals
queen the black one goes to e5 with
check and you don't even need to take
this pawn on h2 which i'm sure you could
get away with but you can keep giving
checks
checking on f5 is is likely good enough
uh even on king g7 queen g5 eventually
even if you're forced to take this pawn
this is still
this is still a theoretical draw and one
of the funny things to note is you just
never put your king on a square like
this
see the table base now go to white
winning uh one of the most dangerous
things about queen
and pawn endings it's the crossfire
check where you check and you force your
opponent to make a trade uh good lesson
for the viewers is actually you kind of
want your king on the most awkward
squares away from your queen these are
the kind of moves you want where like
there's no there's no way for them to be
caught on the same diagonal or file of
course if this palmer on h4 you would
have this move but the point is keeping
your key on awkward squares away from
potential crossfire checks is the right
way to draw these not to try to for
example rush your king over in fact the
closer you get your king to the
potential checks usually that's how you
lose
that's right so
fun little at least you can walk away
from this saying you learned something
a 100 hecarim subs incoming
if if bobby blows this hikara nakamura
dropping 100 subs you heard it
on on uh on stream when he joined us
earlier today in studio
um
the thing is he has no choice queen e7
is the only other way if you're not
gonna play king d6 rookie seven we saw
the draw queen e7 loves queen g6 back
and then you have to play queen f6 again
so this might be smart by fabiano
because they just
played their 48 moves so repeating
will give you a couple moves get you
closer to the next time control yeah
because fabiano he's down under 13
minutes left yeah
but my wonder my wondering is if you
check is there any other check that that
makes it even harder for you because
that's the problem is like if it starts
to become a mess
and now
just saying fabi will never miss that uh
we'll we'll see um
rook d5 check yeah so but the thing is
after queen g you've queen f7 right in
that variation
okay and then you're done with your
checks
uh so now if you have to drink queens
we're back to the spot where white is
in control with the queen's off the
board so that's not what black would
want but still i mean this is
i i agree with you chad i don't think
bobby would miss it either but the
problem is if you're
playing with so much at stake you're
super nervous about keeping the queens
on the board perhaps you're even seeing
a little bit of a ghost right you're
more nervous than you should be
it's hard to keep your king in the
center right i mean
don't judge him right he's working and
this is not easy and the point is
you definitely don't want to lose so if
he panics and says i think i'm gonna
lose you could see him go for something
like that where he's not gonna win but
it's still possible you could swindle
your opponent in a queen upon ending um
so that's what's scary is the longer
fabiano thinks the more you feel that
he's just he's not thrilled about the
required path to win right that's what
i'm saying robert right like the
required path to win has become an
absolute bleep show right it's
absolutely scary to play king d6
he does it okay he does find it and we
expect bobby to do it right he's
he's a very good chess player
but you can see the nerves yeah this is
not easy at all yeah and i think that's
the
misleading part about the evaluation bar
right some plus what does it say plus
six positions
are just very simple right you're up a
full rook it's plus six
this is you only have one pawn your king
on d6 is one check away from getting
checkmated yeah so i completely
understand why fabiano is hesitating and
i think you know for rajabov he needs to
keep it up as you were saying and that's
a really important
defense defensive idea is that instead
of necessarily finding okay this move
looks like it prolongs the game but you
know you're going to lose anyway you
find something that is not just tricky
in the sense that like you're playing
for cheap tricks but tricky in the sense
that white's path is very narrow so at
this point in the game with the king out
on d6 a move like king to b5 right we
can see how that would keep the game to
be quite tricky but we already talked
about this there's rook b7 check and
unfortunately queen e6 happening after
and that's what fabiano wants he wants
that clean trade to get off the board so
what we're job of and why he's thinking
so deeply now is he understands that he
needs to keep the queens on yeah how do
you do that do you play rook to see it
as you pointed out before there's that
bishop b7 check and it looks like the
queens are in fact coming off in that
position with the queen e5 check so he
said okay rook c eliminate yeah i love
that line by the way because after
bishop v7 the idea is not to take the
rook but to force the king where you can
get the queens off go ahead yeah because
no because 94 checked it's really
important
night forks always are a tricky thing so
um
you don't want to make that blunder
that's very clear
and
the bard's
so
eliminating rook c8 because of bishop b7
and queen e5 queen c8 is possible but
then there's bishop b7 check but look at
that variation queen c8 bishop b7 check
queen takes b7
right then it's like oh if i take on b7
with the rook
there's knight e4 check which protects
the rook on c5 in addition to checking
and forking the king and the queen so
that would actually win for black but
the move is instead of rook takes quiz
king takes c5 with a check of your own
and then you take the queen i mean this
is really complicated really complicated
stuff and again we're
we're we're sitting in these chairs
right we're uh we're chess engine
armchair quarterbacking right now and
they're and they are trying to solve
this with everything at stake
big you know every one of these games is
is at this time the biggest game in
their career right i mean you've got to
keep pace if you're fabiano
uh tamer over java wants none of it he
wants to make this an absolute mess to
keep bobby just uh
on his on his toes and again
everything about rajaba's strategy here
is lack of clarity right it's guerrilla
warfare out there right it's just make
it messy and make it make it complicated
and that's where your opponent might go
wrong and after it came to d6 we may
i'm saying that because it means we
might see this game end
quickly right because raja's not gonna
go for a queen trade where we get
you know where it's all just you know
yeah stop the pawn push the pawn yeah be
too easy so what other moves we've
eliminated rook c8 we eliminate queen c8
the rook on c5 is hanging so move like i
don't know knight a4 or something like
that's a way to protect your rook where
else can we go
984 feels
so awkward but what's funny is i don't
have any discovered checks
right i can't move the king and check
you
that's actually a really tricky move
i'm not sure what the best move would be
there oh my gosh
i think there's a meeting i think white
has a
on 984
doesn't work though maybe i'm no i'm
right 984 can play rook a7 check
right away yeah because you take it i've
queen g7 queen b7 mate
oh nice
so
yeah this bishop on f3 is just a really
baller how crazy would that be if the
game ended that way i'm sure fabiano has
seen that idea
of sacrificing the rook onto the seventh
rank we have a move it is rook to c4
so he can by the way the rookie 7 check
idea is still in the air
your idea is actually
maybe
maybe the most straight forward win
again we got to show that rook a7 check
if takes queen to g7
king moves and we've got checkmate
but so you can't take the rook so that
has become clear after rookie so king b6
and then now what
in such a ridiculous position
but you at the very least you can play
rook b7
to protect the rook and now now again if
the king could put itself anywhere else
on any legal square on the board it
would be winning but you can't get out
of the way of your own queen literally
you can't get out of your own way here
if you're fabiano
there's got to be something right just
like
rook e7 looks kind of nice
because d7 makes sense look at this
bishop yet again by the way and by the
way because the queen is blocked if you
check we get out of the way with check
so rookie seven is actually
a serious problem
and no matter where you check i'm
checking you and the moment white gets
on check
it's over yes because the king goes to
b5 once again there's queen e5 check
trading queens yep as as soon as you
have the opportunity to trade queens of
your fabiano you do it and that's
probably why he paused for so long is
when he was visualizing the initial
position after both sides queen
simultaneous promotion he thought the
queens were coming off immediately he
was going to win then he saw queen e8 he
was nervous about king d6 he plays it
but he is down under 10 minutes and he
still has
10 moves to go that was only moved 49.
he's getting into time trouble yep
he plays rook to
c7
oh my god that was so nerve-racking i
was like losing my breath there rook to
c7 it looked like a blunder initially
but black has no
good checks and look at that knight b5
is check with a fork knight b5 checks
and forks and fails to king to d5 and
white is winning gosh
what a freaking game here
rook to c7
and d4 is covered although after rook d4
check queen takes knight b5 check is a
fork but the problem is you have king c5
check that's so much
now that we've seen now that we've seen
this idea you know repeated a few times
now i'm just spotting it yeah every time
i can move the king the game is over you
just you can't let me move the king
this is so awesome rajava going into the
think tank here everything is at stake
for fabiano not as much at stake but
it's not like he's here to you know
you know just kick the can either over
jabba wants to win but right now this is
uh
this entire game hanging by the balance
of whether or not babiano's king can get
out of his own way
and it's a situation where if black
could just give a check with some piece
that doesn't exist on the board it would
be checkmate yeah but you move the
knight this is the king yelling at your
partner and bug house like night mates
get me a piece
no it's true though right if you could
just plant a knight on b5 while still
covering the d5 square that works but as
soon as the knight leaves that square
that previously was covered
covering excuse me is now available to
the white if you could drop a knight on
b5 it's mate it is but you can't drop
you got to move and then you lose
if and when we have fabiano in studio
depending on whether or not he wins this
game
if we do i will ask him just how
nerve-racking this this got to be one of
the most nerve-wracking
games he's ever played in his life at
this point when you miss the queens and
stay on the board you go from okay i'm
just smooth santa oh my goodness my
king's out in the open and i have to
walk my king
into the face of danger right and you
laugh and you laugh
right
danger's my middle name
oh gosh
okay austin
my heart just skipped me a little bit my
heart skipped a beat
it's groovy what it's groovy crewy baby
um
don't get me on that movie quotes from
that movie are no longer okay
they are no longer okay
um
rajab might be realizing that his
position is not okay he has 11 minutes
to make 10 moves fabiano only has nine
but
they both know that a single move could
be the end at this point um
looking yeah i don't see any more moves
for black that's
okay i think we're back to king running
out of the discover check
is the best option but that allows the
queens to get traded and that's that's
actually the opposite human option yeah
right so even though the computer might
say like kingdom b5 is the best if you
trade queens the human beings take a
breath and it's over okay if i play
knight e4 check which forces you to take
because you want to move that king away
but you lose your queen so you can't
move your king ah for the first time i
can't just move my king to d5 right
because you lose your queen and then you
resign
but you would reside
so you take on e4
queen takes e4
is there a way to trade the queens yet i
know it's still bad for black but want
but
actually this seems oh you can trade
queens you're right how well give you a
king d7
and then queen e5 check
but does it
i didn't calculate it if you take it
if you take it you're too slow the e
pull it is too fast here okay so this
one's because what we saw before just
actually let's show the end i think it's
important
that after rook takes c7 kingdom weren't
we just talking about how we both queen
is a draw here it's not because white
queens with check
and then stop saying you're like you
start pushing you're like wait what
let me do it
okay that's nice
so you can't trade but you could play a
move like this perhaps but then i still
trade queens
and then i push
okay and you're still just too fast
okay
so that means
that
knight e4
would go for a forcing line that
probably is
not forcing what java wants because of
yeah i can't see anything else yeah this
would be this would be force so
simple as it is it is also a
he's got a one-track mind right now if
he's fabiano which is get the queens off
the board
get get my king out of this you know
out of this crazy situation he got
himself in and uh
start pushing the pawn and it's amazing
how sometimes we think a game is you
know it's a foregone conclusion yep and
then the opponent puts up such stubborn
defense yeah like whoa
whoa whoa this isn't easy at all and it
goes to show how strong these players
are first you know rajab with the
defense and then fabiano to recognize
that things aren't going according to
plan says that he mapped out what he
thought was a win and then the queens
didn't come off and he's like
oh gosh now i gave him a new lease on
life but then he's like no king d6 rook
c7 i have this under control so yeah
just to be able to calm yourself down to
compose yourself is really difficult and
both players have done that quite well
and now java though he
he's still thinking he's on the clock
and i think he's he heard you there yeah
he's running out of ideas you said his
name and he was like
is that robert hesse here i love that
guy's commentary
i guess commentary is so good
that's what happened right there i don't
think so yeah she does love your
commentary well thank you he's a fan um
not a fan of his position though i think
no
that's pretty clear and
i'm just wondering what move he'll find
here
i love what you said about calming
you're calming your nerves there right
we saw a visibly
visibly shaken fabiano right he was he
was on edge and
i think i think he's much more dialed in
now now you're just like reconfirming
variations which is you're you know when
you're in that moment it's so scary
where you just keep going over the
checks again like okay that check still
loses okay that check still loses right
you're just like reconfirming over and
over again
that you are correct and you are winning
those moments are just so nerve-wracking
and you can mix up your move orders so
easily in a position like this where
like thinking in this variation i move
this piece here and this other variation
i move my pawn first yeah whatever it
may be when you hear your pieces
scattered like this or king out on d6
it is easy to just make that mistake but
i think that rook c7 was a really really
nice move black can't afford to trade
rooks because you lose your queen on the
spot which is pretty cool
tactically speaking so
yeah this is looking like
fabiano yeah i feel like he knows now he
just took that
sip of water yeah that's confident
he's back to a bit of the fobby perch
six minutes and 45 seconds for 10 moves
so
that means we're gonna have an answer
here
in just a few moments
uh he has to make a move in six minutes
where he loses on time and i think he's
uh
he's running out of ideas
he glanced up at fabiano there he's you
know looking at him
trying to study his opponent but yep
this is like a study
this is where experience is paramount
imagine the pressure these two are
feeling right now great comment from one
gm to others one gm to another i loved
your work
in the phantom menace
the one star wars he wasn't in and i was
just glad you didn't start making
chewbacca noises
[Laughter]
the way he would have actually said that
in
um
wookie speak is is he a wookie
i
i lost i stopped following the series
closely when dumbledore died i stopped
paying attention
you did that
what happened after dumbledore died
didn't didn't frodo again lose his way
and then sam saved him yeah yeah just in
time for
for luke to
realize that he couldn't kiss leia
because she said man got like really
tiny yeah that's what i oh yeah man
that was a great series
shout out to you captain kirk you were
the best character in star wars um
okay
here we go um
five minutes to figure this thing out
we have lift up king to b5 okay but that
means the queens are coming off
fabiano might be taking a breath
is there some sort of trick of queen e5
check
queenie let's look at it queen e5 check
queen takes e5
f takes e5 rook d4
king e7
no i mean the knight's under attack so
yeah oh wait i was about to push a4
you're right so i can't even play it for
and that e pawn is just epon is too fast
sprinting in the finish line
is there anything more forcing than i
think that i think bobby will play this
move because it's the human move it's
like oh my god
now i can get the queens off my king is
safe
there is a way to get
the rooks and the queens off but i don't
think it's really worth it like let's
say you start queen f5 check
the king has to move you take on c4 with
check
king takes queen e6 check this whole
thing
and
what's going on here
and we're gonna have another promotion
going on another
promotion fest
i don't want any more of this
shenanigans
two times in one game
yeah this is not what you this is not
what you want forget the email bar human
beings don't play this with that type of
certainty this is this is
this has to blunder into a draw written
all over it right some sort of check and
perpetual so i don't think that's what
bobby wants i think he's going to look
for the much more straightforward
queen e5 check because also when the
queen trades you you kind of gain a
tempo right you gain a full move with
the pawn advance oop sorry again mouse
slips continue today takes takes shaken
big
yeah you want that pawn
just
running up the board so that's what's
happening and fabiano he has plenty of
time right if if you can trade queens
the calculations get easier so that's
why he has plenty of time as both
players have made their 50th move
and fabiano he's just well you still
have to reach move 60 before you get
more time right yeah okay he's just
reassessing like queen e5 check that's
my intuition is that for sure winning
because the last thing you want is to
make some queen trade that just seems
winning but you haven't actually thought
it through yeah and then allows for
jabba to escape so you're always
calculating
always be calculating the abcs of chess
and that looks like queen e5 to 25
queen dixie 5 is the only move
as is pawn takes
and now we'll see what rajab's final
stand
is
what was his what was his last idea
probably didn't really have a choice
anyway but maybe there's some sort of
setup he envisions an opportunity for
caruana to go wrong that's why i said my
instinct was rookie for check because i
thought at least it forces the king in
front of the pawn right which slows
things down
but you made the great point i i played
rook d4 in my line thinking i was
playing a4 next and forgot my knight is
hanging and from the distance that's
exactly what happens you know when
you're trying to calculate and visualize
but it's a little bit too late for that
whole thou shall not pass that pawn
that's a passer and it's going
don't quote merlin on this show thou
shall not pass
all right rook d4 check
king e7
and that white rook is going to have an
easy time
rookie 14 there's no rook ending chances
right you check to make a fork but it
doesn't matter because the pawn is just
too fast
and what's funny is even if you somehow
got an end game where both sides were
sacrificing rooks for the pawn white
still wins because it's actually a
really fun thing to visualize
the king will be here and the white king
will be here way too close right the
white king is and that's you know what
it's likely not possible but it is kind
of an important instructive takeaway
right that in any kind of variation
where
both sides somehow had to magically
sacrifice their rook for each other's
past pawn white is still winning and
that's a security you have absolutely
and not only is your king closer we
can't afraid that white's up a pawn
right we've been so focused on the past
pawns that you can forget to count and
white has an extra pawn here so you can
create another pass pawn if the e pawn
was not good enough
yep yeah
okay well uh i think we're gonna have a
uh
i think
we're gonna have a two horse race
officially and not a everyone's looking
at
at yawn's score like hey
slow down
slow down speed racer yeah wait for me
big brother
believe in me
uh you with your
teenage everyone remembers that when
your big brother's leaving you behind
and you're like out of breath
yeah slow down
[Laughter]
oh dan and dan and danny what are we
gonna do with you
well
right now
oh what
wait no okay oh that was one of those
dgt errors if you
if you when the players slide the pieces
there's that pressure that's put on the
square which sends the relay so that's a
funny little moment where
java
clearly what that showed was how angry
for job off is because he slid that
piece with enough force to trick the dgt
board into thinking he played rook c6
but what what's going on here because a4
e6 and e7 e8 is unstoppable so he's
good like king c5 okay i see he's going
to play king c5 that way he can yeah he
has knight b5 check that's the idea
that's actually
shout out to raja for continuing to find
that was actually one line we didn't
look at he trades rooks because on e6 he
has knight b5 check king d7
he can put the knight on d6 and on e7 a4
queen queen a3 guess who loses
yeah the bishop won't be able to catch
the pawn which is why let's we got to
show that line now that it's now that's
that that's actually a
this is an absolutely stellar defensive
try
because in this line
you can blunder your way
we're going to see it on the board not
the favial blender but in this line you
can blunder your way into losing because
the king is actually perfectly in his
position
to stop the bishop from stopping the
pawn right which is why after you know
that exact variation if we just knight
d6
e7 a4 you first take care of the pawn so
you make the move bishop to d1
then that attacks the pawn if there
pushes you play bishop b3 because black
cannot stop white from promoting the
pawn yep and the bishop covers the a
pawn and that will
game over one more important thing which
isn't that important you know where i'm
going with this oh let's do it light
square bishop
dark square h eight uh square
if somehow black could magically put the
king in this corner and keep all other
things you have to take the g pawns but
yeah it's too much
that's a very nice line again by biver
jabba finding one last trick we knew he
would
and he's thinking about it but
after knight b5 king d7
i think the game will go to here
and after e7 a4
bishop d1
and bishop b3 we will see a resignation
that is my official prediction that this
will be the final position on the board
wanna bet chat
will danny be right vote now will danny
be right in chat let's do it i think
this is the final position and then we
see a resignation
i think
we will see it right
good job
and at that point it will be
game over red rover send fabiano caruana
right over upstairs to the studio he
will go
then onto grandma's house
avoiding the evil queen whatever
to loop
and johnny's prediction on the analysis
board the live position where it stands
for java's 37 seconds left
so i didn't even realize that yeah it
won't matter it's not consequential in
this game because
this is as you predicted likely to be
the final position in a couple moves but
java also doesn't have time to calculate
even if his position was defensible
will he play knight d6 or will he just
resign
i made a prediction it was bold
hopefully chad's voting
down under 20 seconds
under 15. he hasn't even looked at his
clock he might just lose some time yeah
well
would be the first time i was wrong
today okay
and rajaba resigns bobby on our car
wanna maintain space look at that breath
that sigh of relief from fabian you see
that like his body like visibly took
like a huge deep breath right there yeah
no he is definitely ecstatic on the
inside they're just talking through the
game and somewhere yonder machine might
be punching a pillow because he thought
with his win today he could distance
himself from fabiano but fabiano is just
clipped onto his heels yeah he will not
let go
trying to shake him loose but fabiano
will not let go and
analyzing some variation we'll uh we'll
maybe pick bobby's brain when he comes
upstairs and
lets us know uh
what critical lines
he or java got up to here in this little
post game chat but what can you say
about i mean this is
you have to win
right when it matters most right now
fabiano is doing that keeping pace with
yonder pomnishi
i cannot wait for their head-to-head
battle in the second round of the second
set of games i will tell you that yes no
that is going to be an epic because
favorite carwano will get the white
pieces against the player he's currently
trailing and we see them continue to
talk about the game and that's what
happens you know you had so many
unplayed variations that you want to
discuss with your opponent
good on pujabo
sometimes if people lose they're
disgusted they just want to run away or
hijab up here he wants to talk about the
chess and he knows that
at this point his chances of winning the
candidates right there like reports
laptop out the window
but he still is you know a chess lover
and he wants to talk about all these
possibilities and fabiano
equally as perplexed by some of the
moments in the game just like yeah that
was an absolute mess and
oh man
boy am i happy yeah a little bit small
smile there from mr carwana stands up
it is officially a two-horse race here
in madrid with all of the results from
round seven in the books
and uh
we will give you a snapshot of what
those were in just a moment
in fact right now we'll do so
it starts at the top richard report if
you missed it it was an interesting game
interesting things to discuss about how
that game went down but ultimately all
that matters is the scoreboard which is
yonder pomnishi getting another victory
robert yeah and this is starting to look
familiar right what happened in the
round before the rest day in round six
only two players won their games that
was yana pomshi fabiano karwana so these
are the two players round one round one
round six and now round one bobby on
carawana young upon machine round six
rounds okay so there you have it due to
nakamura was interesting maybe there
were some moments that could have been
it could have been a fight as hikaru
said when he was in studio if you missed
the interview it was great
back up and check it out dingley red and
purusha they both fought hard they
played played a strong chess game it was
it was one that they took all the way
down to the wire further than we thought
they would but unfortunately for those
two players it's it's uh not a victory
for either one to try to maintain with
the two maintain pace with the two
leaders and then fabiana carwana just
beat tamora java before our very eyes
which is why he is keeping pace
with yondu panmashi on that note let's
bring up the standings
and talk about what that means for where
all the players sit we see the players
not sitting there standing
standing and still talking in the
playing hall but look at where things
are
now a point and a half separates fabiano
caruana from the next closest person
which is his countrymen hikaru nakamura
and yonda pomneshi two points ahead of
the rest of the field not named fabiano
caruana unbelievable performance by
those two you would think that five on a
caruana would be in the lead if you just
told the world that somebody had five
points out of seven games like yeah that
person's in that person is in the lead
and they're going to win right and last
time around two players at four and a
half and a seven yeah but jan napomneshi
is unstoppable right now he has not lost
a game he has four wins and only three
draws he's playing out of his mind he's
getting a little help from his friends
and competitors today it was not richard
reports day but you have to give credit
where it's due and yonda pomnessy he's
been absolutely stellar
you said it i mean i don't need to
repeat it we still got so much more
ahead here as we uh
back this thing up here in in studio and
prepare to send it to a break before we
are likely and hopefully joined by the
other winner on the day we also had
yonder pawn machine studio by the way we
had such a great interview with the cara
nakamura we forgot that something else
you should back up and check out so
don't go anywhere for my partner robert
hess danny wrench we're going to be
right back on the other side we will
look ahead of course to what tomorrow's
round 8 has for us hopefully we're also
talking to a fabiano caruana much more
ahead as we wrap up round seven coverage
here for chess.com's view on the 2022
fe-day candidates
want to play chess online or learn how
to improve join us at the number one
chess destination in the world chess.com
with thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
[Music]
want to hold a massive chess tournament
with dozens of clubs or hundreds of
players or maybe a small chess
tournament with local but competitive
clubs with club arenas you can
club arenas allow for tournaments of any
size with any number of clubs and
players customize the arena with any
time control with standard chests or
mini chest variants and with any
starting position you want club arenas
are the most flexible tournament format
on chess.com try one out today
[Music]
pretty
popular choice for winning it all here
in madrid
fabi won this prestigious tournament
four years ago in berlin
in his challenger match against magnus
carlson caruana came just one end-game
moment away from his first world
championship
i wasn't
wasn't playing my best chess today and
buying this so
i think played
played very well
soon to be 30 caruana's chess resume is
matched by few in madrid
born in miami with dual citizenship fabi
became the youngest grand master in u.s
history at age 14.
a decade ago he made history at the
sinkfield cup
winning seven straight games on his way
to a 28-44 rating the third highest of
all time
precise calculation and deep knowledge
of opening theory are fabi's calling
cards the italian-american used both to
great effect in the fide grand swiss to
qualify for this event
caruana now aims to become the first
player since vichy anand to win the
candidates in non-consecutive years
but perhaps more importantly fabi looks
towards another shot at the world title
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of danny wrenches games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh
in the last month i am playing 83.12.
i'm less accurate than them in every
stage
yeah and that that's stainless steel
okay do the more game review okay yeah
thanks a lot okay so tuesday sucks i
gotta stop playing cats on twitter oh
it's because it's final tuesday
[Laughter]
look how many blunders there were back
in december 2020 and now december 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number
best
let's go to
uh tactics
mates
i'll probably need to work on these ones
yep
every single rook fork that has
presented itself to me i have found no
one has a higher percentage of rook
forks than i do that's correct
these are literally the night forks that
you i missed knight d6 it you saw it
just now what is wrong with me
i could have done here and then taken
this pawn and i'm winning because my
pawns get held together that's probably
the coolest part about this feature like
these positions against pass
rook there for rookie too
and he plugged his maiden one
oh my goodness i'm awful
[Music]
and we are back here chess.com coverage
of the 2021 world chess championship
from dubai contin oh sorry wrong event
a couple familiar faces here though
grand master fabiano caruana joining
robert hess and i in studio and bobby
just
right off the bat
how nerve-wracking was that game
yeah that was that was the most
difficult game i played in a long time
yeah i was it was kind of crazy at the
end um
i was just worried i'm getting
going under mate or blunder or something
blender or rook but
i i think i kept things under control
for the most part well let's dive into
the chest so you feel like you can kind
of get that off your head for those who
don't bobby came in studio and
immediately was like going to the the
monitor like what was going on in this
position because of so much craziness
we're going to stay at that craziness
that i think really started with i guess
we'll go to queen g6 check right take us
through what happened because here's
what robert and i were observing a
friend who we know we could tell your
body language changed you were you were
visibly nervous
was there something you had missed in
this line it was something that you were
struggling to solve before you
ultimately did by the way played the
best engine line with queen f6
yeah no i saw this at this quite far in
advance i mean i saw his position when i
played
rook d2 and i saw that he has to go for
this and he has to play king e7 which
was my plan first you saw it here yeah
when i played rook d2 okay uh it's it's
all very forcing he doesn't really have
any alternatives and i don't i might
have some alternative but i didn't
really see it
and i you know we have no increments so
right i was trying not to think too much
and
yeah i figured kingston queen b5 but
then i realized that
um like it was sort of theoretical
before and then once we got here i
realized i'm kind of short on time and i
don't know exactly what to do oh so you
were planning king e7 yeah queen b5 at
uh king b5 sorry which is forced i think
otherwise he's just losing materials or
getting mated and then i was trying g4
here
wow um because i i need to cover this f5
square like because if queen f7 or i'm
trying to trade queens but then he
always has rook five and then he plays
a4 because he actually doesn't have any
way to improve his position
and it's very strange
like he's pushing his pawn and
he can't really move his pieces they're
all in like a perfect place so he can't
really improve them
but also i i didn't see what to do here
yeah i was thinking about like rook b7
king c4 f5 and i realized that i could
like easily
um
like queen g5 and if king gate there's
queen e3 so then i realized that i could
easily lose this position
and um
i was a bit scared of the a pawn as well
yeah so then i thought queen f6 i wasn't
sure about queen takes f6 to start with
um
i thought queen 8 should be losing but
this i wasn't sure of take take a4
i was going to play rook d8 because his
pawn is like super strong his knight is
just covering my bishop is kind of
dominated his night is also dominated
like it's a weird standoff between the
pieces yeah um
but the good thing is that usually if i
sack my rook
i will win because uh his knight stays
dominated
uh
even even if there's a very limited
material that's interesting so you're
already evaluating that if if your rook
has to come up for his pawn but his rook
has to come up with your opponent you're
still winning that game
almost always winning so i was looking
at for example king a5 here or king b5 i
don't know
um let's say rook a8 king b4
f5 a3
king g6
and
like rook a5 i thought was losing take
everything and again we both promote at
the same time but this one is even worse
for him because um now my king isn't in
danger so i just went right
and
they're just showing you're alive to die
so the knight a4 i thought instead of
rook a5
knight a4
uh f6
a4
sorry i can't even
and um
i thought this was winning but i now i
see the bar says it's not i thought like
f
um f7 rook g5 king h6 radio 5
and uh bishop
rook f5 now okay sorry
yeah and bishop d1 i thought this would
be winning but now i see it's not
winning so
yeah there was obviously some problems
with my calculation well i mean just
yeah they should just show the end of
that and this is like sorry uh
looking at five percent go back to rook
f5 and bishop d1 a1 equals queen this
looks like you know rook takes a4 i
think this is uh
what you were looking at yeah take group
of seven and i thought this position was
winning somehow
oh this is this is
wow i would have yeah i would also
assume it's winning but i guess i guess
it's not yeah his king is coming back
quickly
but okay yeah wow it's one of those
cases of long variation wrong variation
but it helps us understand because
here's because
i mean twist ending robert and i were
not working nearly as hard as you at
this at the board and so that line is
mind-blowing right robert i mean the
fact that you were we weren't even
considering
g4 you know at all we we did look
quickly at this but this is
a crazy good move and it's one of the
engine's top choices too but okay
yeah no i thought queen of six is a bit
safer because here i gave him kind of a
free choice in some ways like it's
easier to blunder and queen six is more
forcing right um yeah queen eight was a
bit of a relief because i okay not
entirely relief because i wasn't sure
but i thought it should be losing
somehow after king d6
um
that sorry queenie like he played okay
yeah yeah
but you were confident he was losing
here
no not confident oh i i thought i should
be winning but didn't really
see entirely how but
yeah yeah those lines were just looking
at pretty crazy yeah
and here um
when yeah i
i saw this in advance as rook c4 and at
first i thought
uh i'm winning with rookie
and then i realized this is not clear at
all
the main reason i rejected was actually
because of queen b5
rook b7
and queen e8 and i didn't see how to
make progress here
and okay well we discussed this a little
bit before
we before probably came in we were
talking about the rook a7 idea yeah and
this would transpose to rook a7 and rook
p3 i i but i didn't see three at all
like finding that move is just it
doesn't even have like it just had
threatens rook c3 it's kind of amazing i
just
just want to win the night
chess is not fair this is ridiculous
so but rook c7 i i was very happy to
find because yeah it like completely
kills i thought 94 is like the only
chance um bishop before queen e4 yep
uh and yeah i just thought the queen
ended should be winning but it's still a
fight yeah queen endings are always kind
of tough to to play especially low on
time yeah but yeah what he did was was
much easier
what he did was after rook to c7 he
played team to b5 for those who missed
it and then uh the queens came off the
board were you breathing a sigh of
relief as soon as the queens were off
yeah here there was no more not much
more to calculate and i also couldn't
wonder anything all right well i want to
say a little on the chat just about the
other storylines we were looking at um
that uh we we're not gonna do the whole
game don't worry but
how surprised were you on a6 and then
raj's follow-up choice to go for this
super sharp line with d5 and
you obviously were taking your time here
this was this not what you were
expecting him to play without revealing
your prep
well uh tamora is almost always playing
the berlin
he used to be a sicilian player but not
yeah i mean a6 came as a shock yeah it
doesn't really play sicilian too often
these days
and
okay i was hesitating c3 or c4 after a6
and i couldn't quite recall
uh the line so i decided just to
improvise
and it was kind of
yeah it wasn't too pleasant
uh to be so far down on the clock and he
was playing quickly and seemed to be
prepared but still my position seemed
good um
i was a bit surprised by his d5 i
thought he would play
like g6 or
right or something like that i don't
know
crazy
but yeah d5 okay
i just thought i would be better here
and actually i was wondering about queen
takes g2 i thought i thought that was a
very critical move
here yeah it was good for you
yeah it should be four queen eight
plus six
oh queen a4 b5 knight oh my god i just
wondered i thought bishop b7
okay yeah this is this is a bit
embarrassing
no one's watching these shows
okay anyway so you were you were you
were good there and just we won't do the
whole game but when were you feeling
just good about the position like yeah
here like here he's good all right i
thought i'm better yeah uh i wasn't sure
how much better but i thought it's a
very pleasant advantage yep and then
yeah i thought i messed it up a bit
later um
like he was very close to equality i
assume at some point yeah what question
we had during the game was were you
surprised when if we go forward to that
moment after the queen trade um right
around
here that he didn't play he played brook
c8 and allowed you to keep
all the rooks on the board versus
playing the move b5 which is what we
were looking at yeah i thought after b5
i have to take on d8 i have to take on
f7 knight f5 and i have to play rook d1
um yeah but we were thinking if this
happens that all your winning chances
are going i didn't think my wedding
chances were gone here it's not pure
obstacle bishops there are knights on
the board
um
i assume it should be a draw with
correct play but i
like i i wouldn't be confident black
draws this all the time well the idea we
thought at the end that you might have
planned was actually to play them with
bishop f1 if this had happened and go
for a4 yeah but here i thought that b4
uh take take
and
like i guess knight e4
and even um
even knight f5 i wasn't sure about but
probably not probably bishop five is
better
um yeah i just thought he would have
like a lot of activity and
very good chances i know i was gonna go
for the other one instead of this
and while you're in you know this
position knowing you have some winning
chances but the fight ahead
let's talk about what's going on in the
other board right it was the storyline
of the day for for as far as all the
other games were concerned there was
this huge decision by richard to to not
repeat and take the draw
um ultimately we know hindsight 2020 or
not it was also questioned in real time
how were you feeling about what you were
watching over there with the guy you're
chasing i i felt kind of sick to be
honest yeah like that i mean it's one of
the most shocking games i've seen from a
top player in a long time it's like the
line that's played is known it's been
known for like a decade that it's a draw
like you you don't really go for this
for white and if you do go for it you
take a draw because uh f3 is just worse
for white um you actually showed us this
line in studio for the world
championship you were mentioning this
like can i show you we went over some
quick petra offline
it didn't happen on the board right
between magnus and yon but you were
saying there was some there's some lines
for with the bishop h3 i just showed it
yeah it's um
yeah it's it's very very known i i
really don't know
uh why richard didn't know it or or what
was what was going on and
any and
like
once you end up in that situation that
like your preparation has gone wrong
he's down an hour on the clock and he's
out of preparation why is he going for
this i mean it's totally insane yeah
it's like um
it's like some sort of hypnosis or
something right because
i can't explain otherwise
sorry at that moment though when you see
you know you're walking by the board you
see it happening you still have to win
your own game so how were you feeling
you know of course you were saying you
don't understand his decision but did
that affect your own game like did you
feel like emotion was settling into your
game when you you know you're trying to
be objective no it didn't really because
you know i
basically the only way i could play for
win this game was in a safe way
it was just a pawn up slightly better
position um it's not like i could do
anything crazy you know playing for a
win and i probably wouldn't do that
anyway
um
so yeah it didn't affect me it just
really upset me yeah
we were wondering whether it would you
know upset you obviously you have to
focus on what you can control right so
have you ever been in a situation like
that i mean in the in a where your fate
is kind of in
the hands of someone else and you're not
happy about what's happening
well your fate is never entirely in your
own hands i mean it is possible for
someone to win all their games uh you
know and that's just bad luck but you
can only
play your own chess and if you play well
overall it works out you know in the
long run
um it doesn't always work out in a
tournament you know sometimes you play
well and
and someone still manages to
uh just be a bit better right um
but okay overall i'm still happy i'm
only half a point behind yeah it could
have uh
could have been more it could have been
really disappointing today so overall
it's a positive thing well we're gonna
we're gonna bring up your head to heads
uh and the results you had rounds one
through seven real quick just to get
your view on it because if someone had
told you coming in
bobby that you would be five out of
seven
heading into the back half and
regardless of the specific results of
the players
that you wouldn't be leading what would
you have said
i i'd probably take it anyway yeah you'd
be okay um
well i'd yeah i i don't know if there's
a single candidate we're halfway through
some ones plus four yeah
as far as far as our knowledge right now
it's definitely a record in the last
couple decades we haven't gone farther
back but yeah yeah like in 2018 i was
plus three after
seven rounds i think i was at least half
a point clear of a field maybe even a
full point i don't really remember
um
[Music]
so yeah it's it's quite i mean plus four
is a tremendous score it's yeah you you
just can't expect things like that but
sometimes these things happen yeah
looking at your results oh we switched
away from it let's go let's bring it
back rounds one through seven i just
want to say what what stands out for you
in in um i mean obviously
wins here but any particular game you
can take us back through at a certain
point i'll ask you this when you kind of
felt like you were on form feeling good
uh yesterday i i'm not yesterday
yesterday during the restaurant
you were hanging out with robert so you
were feeling good yeah that was the best
part of the day
no i mean my game against alireza okay
day before yesterday i really felt like
i was um seeing a lot and playing well
um
yeah
overall i feel like i'm playing quite
well good yeah we're going to look at
your oh sorry robert i was just going to
ask because throughout these seven games
the only game where you were slightly
worse to my recollection was against
dingley wren where you're down the pawn
so what kind of confidence is that bill
where you played seven games in you know
six of them you were in pretty good
shape never in too much trouble does
that help build your confidence for the
second half it makes me feel like i'm
controlling the situation well
but yeah i know from experience that the
second half is a whole different story
yeah it just feels totally different um
well we're going to bring up uh the
rounds 8 through 14 that are on their
way here and just we won't make you go
round by round and reveal all your
preparation against every player but we
will just ask you
circle a game or two obviously you've
got round nine yonder palmishi right
with the white pieces but
um
[Music]
what uh what game are you most looking
forward to right now
um
well tomorrow and tomorrow
i don't think there's any point thinking
about any game beyond that yeah
okay
well um that was anti-climactic
you knew he was going to say it though
of course you shouldn't but still it's
it's great look ahead obviously you're
playing every player with the opposite
color that's how a double round robin
works in case
you want us to remind you so
at the end of our coverage of the world
championship we asked you which was
harder playing or commentating and you
made the mistake of saying on camera
that commentating was more exhausting
you still feel that way now no i was
definitely wrong you're definitely wrong
like
okay um well we are um enjoying enjoying
the show enjoying the chess um
very much and uh
excited to see what the back half brings
so um i have a quick question for you
after a long game like that obviously
you're exhausted but are you happy that
another game is tomorrow like does that
help you get in a rhythm or would you
prefer tomorrow or another rest day
i'm actually kind of glad that uh i'm
playing black
because it somehow takes more energy to
play with white you have to create more
with black you're a bit more reactive
um
so it's
yeah i
but i i think that despite the fact that
i'm exhausted now and i have no energy
um i still will get under energy
tomorrow usually it renews um
you know after a good night's sleep yeah
well uh
that was awesome to be visited by by you
fabi and again it's right now kind of a
kind of a two horse race between you and
yon so let me leave you this last
question do you
watch his games closely from here on out
and does that have
any effect on decisions you might make
um
not yet maybe going into the final round
but definitely not yet but of course i
follow all the games all the games very
closely um
but especially now that it kind of
seems like i mean i don't want to
you know say anything too speculative
but it seems like nearly
nearly 100 chance that one of us will
win the tournament right um
because yeah i i two points lead
uh for the rest of the field
um it's kind of difficult to to surround
that
so
but again i guess crazier things have
happened yeah in the history of chess
but yeah it does it does feel like um
like pretty much a two-horse race okay
well i don't have any other questions we
really appreciate your time and and i
know you've got so much ahead because
there's a lot more to go as you said and
so we'll
we'll let you go and robert and i will
finish talking about the standings and
doing giving our opinions of how you're
all going to do tomorrow because our
opinions
really matter although by the way i i
predicted for the vote guest result
thing and i was i was kind of just don't
i mean i don't take that stuff seriously
let's be honest but i predicted john was
going to win his black today i also
predicted you would win
you're you're doing better than during
the world championship
that's where you say that's the
stupidest bleeping belief you've ever
seen anyway all right well this has been
fabiana carwana in studio of course
we're all wishing him the best of luck
and hopefully we'll be seeing you again
soon because that probably means good
results for you so good luck fabi and
rob and i are going to bring up the
standings and break things down as you
uh as you head on home
see you see you bobby
all right well that was
the the other man of the day you had yon
napomnishi robert you have fabiana
caruana
and uh those are the two guys to beat at
this point
yeah i mean they're having tremendous
tournaments you asked right if you had
five out of seven someone told you that
five to seven before the tournament
started how would you feel you would
feel great like he's playing great chess
and he himself said yeah we have to
reach for me
you're so close but so far
okay but you know we look at
up and down the standings here right you
see seven total victories
by yonder palm shane five under carwana
hikaru nakamura has the only other win
in the entire field it shows how
difficult it is to win a single game but
also shows the kind of form that jan and
fabiano have in this tournament right
fabiano
i asked him he said i'm feeling good
like i haven't had problems really
dingly ren game that was maybe for a few
moments looking scary but he's been in
control yeah and jana palm she's in the
lead and he deserves all this credit and
he's playing phenomenal chess but there
have been at least two games his game
against fabiano and his game against
hikaru where he was in some shaky
territory so
despite the fact that jan's in the lead
and deserves to be in the lead there
have been
possible moments where he could have
slipped and
jan the way he's been playing it's not
that surprising that he didn't lose
games despite having those rough
positions but it's going to be
interesting to see how these two jockey
for position down the stretch yeah
well said and and if there was a game
where bobby could slip we're going to
bring up tomorrow's matchups you have to
be careful tomorrow right because while
he did win against okara nakamura
already but remember he had white in
that game
now hikaru who's
arguably the only other player in the
field who like bobby said could make it
not a 100 percent certainty that either
karwana or napon rishi wins right and it
would probably have to start with a
hikaru nakamura victory as white against
fabinho caruana so that's to me is the
game that i immediately have circled as
the biggest matchup of tomorrow robert
yeah because hikar has been playing some
great chess himself and he gets the
white pieces now fabiano made this
parting point that the onus is kind of
on the player with the white pieces to
prove some sort of opening advantage and
what we saw the last time hikaru had the
white pieces was extensive preparation
but that didn't lead to an advantage
objectively the position was fine for
dingley wren he found every accurate
move which was extremely impressive so
maybe fabi's you know sitting right now
he's behind yonder palm shape but he
also realized that you know
the burden you know kind of like you got
to prove that you can win with the first
move just the first move advantage isn't
much of an advantage if you aren't
showing that you can get it done and in
this tournament the only players getting
it done are yon and fabiano speaking of
the other player we just talked about
nakamura and caruana yonda pomnesi
will have the white pieces versus
dingley wren uh the highest rated player
in the field he's coming into the
tournament was dingley wren yan already
one is black what will he do as white
now that he's the clear tournament
leader who knows how much of a fight we
have in that game
report and duda i'll be interested to
see how richard rebounds right your
heart went out to him as he set himself
and fabiano backed up
kind of a crazy decision today and
obviously had effect on a lot of things
and this is this is why the game is
played right we have drama we have
interesting stuff to talk about but how
will report rebound against duda and
then last thoughts robert from you on
the farouz or job off match up there
they have played one game in their
careers against each other and it was a
draw yeah that was the first round of
this tournament so
i'm not really sure how the games will
go because jan de palma she still has
seven full games left so if you think
about it from that perspective it's a
long event seven games a lot so will he
go against dingley ren and just be like
let me play peacefully i'm not so sure
he beat dingley wren last time in the
cannons with the white pieces he lost in
the final round when he'd already had
the tournament locked up but he did beat
dingley wren with some really nice play
so i don't think that either jan or
fabiano are looking for specific results
against players it's too early for those
two but it's getting too late for the
rest of the field so for karu with the
white pieces that's i agree with you the
game of the round because will hikaru
use preparation that's maybe a little
bit more dangerous than the preparation
he used against dingley wren will he
take a big risk because it's now or
never for him if he doesn't beat fabiano
and then also try to beat yan later in
the event then as fabiano said it's
nearly guaranteed that one of those two
will win yeah
oh man a lot could play out a lot as uh
a lot has happened so far a lot might
happen tonight right sun's going down
here in madrid and uh we're gonna we're
gonna probably go get some dinner danny
rich robert house we're missing almira
skripchenko uh and and right now fabiano
caruana so shout out to elimira uh so
many you know this is just robert it
just feels so awkward should i go back
over there you don't have to
but
is that what you're you know it seems
like you you have your hand you know
the chair
all right everybody this has been this
has been a lot of fun um and we have
much more ahead so make sure you tune in
tomorrow
we will once again be live from madrid
at the palacio de centonia
it is beautiful it is now empty it's
time for us to shut off the lights and
head home
we will see you for around eight of the
2022 fe-day candidates tomorrow at 3 p.m
local madrid time tune in
[Music]
do
you